This is the 99% Invisible Breakdown of The Power Broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliott Kalin. Today we'll be covering pages 283 to 401 in my book, chapters 16 through 20, and this is the middle section of part four, The Use of Power. And our special guest for today's book club is Representative Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez. She represents the New York 14th Congressional District, which is home to a number of Robert Moses infrastructure projects and atrocities, and it is also the congressional seat once
这里是《99%无形》对《权力掮客》的深度解析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是埃利奥特·卡林。今天我们将讲解我书中的第283页到第401页，即第16到第20章，这也是第四部分《权力的运用》的中段。我们今天读书俱乐部的特邀嘉宾是国会女议员亚历山大·奥卡西奥-科特斯。她代表纽约州第十四国会选区，这里拥有许多罗伯特·摩西的基础设施项目和暴行，这里也曾是
held by Fiorella LaGuardia, who makes his first appearance in this section of the book. We have a long, fun, enlightening discussion with AOC after we do the book summary. So when we left off last episode in a stunning turnabout, young idealist reformer Robert Moses has turned around and embraced corruption and dirty dealings to get things done. And this is the freight train that has been coming at us from page one. The heel turn is taking place. And as a result in three years with the backing of Governor Al Smith, he massively expanded the amount of public park space in New York State.
菲奥雷洛·拉瓜迪亚担任过议员的国会席位，他也是在这部分书中首次登场。在我们做完书评后，我们将与AOC进行一次漫长、有趣且富有启发性的讨论。那么上集节目结束时，在一个惊人的大反转中，年轻的理想主义改革家罗伯特·摩西回心转意，为了办成事情，开始拥抱腐败和肮脏的交易。这就是从第一页起就一直向我们疾驰而来的货运列车。彻底黑化正在发生。因此，在州长阿尔·史密斯的背书下，他在三年内大幅扩展了纽约州的公共公园空间。
He turned Jones Beach into the world's greatest weekend spot and built expressways leading to all that stuff. And he has become this absolute hero to New Yorkers. He's seen as this man who stands up to the wealthy and he can get stuff done. He creates parks for the people. Even though we've seen that he will totally get in bed with these powerful people to make his projects possible and he will ruin some small time farmers. He does some dastardly stuff, but the public doesn't see that. They just see these beautiful parks he's made. And this public idea of Robert Moses and the private reality of how Moses gets things done
他把琼斯海滩变成了世界上最棒的周末胜地，并修建了通往所有这些地方的高速公路。他成了纽约人心目中的绝对英雄。他被视为一个敢于对抗富人、能把事情办成的人。他为人民创造了公园。尽管我们已经看到，为了让他的项目得以实施，他会完全与这些权贵同流合污，他还会毁掉一些小农场主。他做了一些极其卑鄙的事情，但公众看不到这些。他们只看到他建造的这些美丽公园。这种公众眼中的罗伯特·摩西，与摩西实际行事的私人现实
are really diverging at this point. And through this, and the reason why he's able to get all this stuff done is he has the support of Al Smith. And unfortunately, in 1928, Al Smith runs for and loses the presidency. He cannot run for president and run for governor at the same time. So he goes to the presidency. He reaches for that brass ring. He does not reach that brass ring at all.
在这一点上开始真正分道扬镳。通过这一切，以及他能够办成所有这些事情的原因，是他得到了阿尔·史密斯的支撑。不幸的是，在1928年，阿尔·史密斯竞选并输掉了总统大选。他不能同时竞选总统和州长。所以他去竞选总统了。他去争夺那个至高无上的目标。但他根本没有实现那个目标。
And Robert Moses is left trying to do the things he's trying to do. But there's a new governor in office, and this is the man who Carol promises will be one of Moses's most powerful enemies. He is known as the Featherduster, which is the title of chapter 16. Who is the Featherduster? As you can guess, the Featherduster from his name is a figure of power, a figure of strength, a figure of intimidation.
而罗伯特·摩西则只能试图去完成他正在做的事情。但办公室里迎来了新州长，这个人卡罗承诺将会成为摩西最强大的敌人之一。他被称为“掸子”，这也是第16章的标题。谁是“掸子”？正如你所能猜到的，从他的名字来看，“掸子”是一个代表权力、力量和威慑力的人物。
And I'd like to start getting into that chapter with the opening of that chapter, which I love so much. It says, there's an expression used in Albany to describe the relationship of two men between whom there exists bad feeling, when that feeling has existed for years, has resisted every attempt at reconciliation, and has only deepened with the passage of time to a point where dislike is not so fitting a name for it as hatred.
我想从那一章的开篇切入，我太喜欢这段话了。它是这样写的：奥尔巴尼有一种表达，用来形容两个彼此心存芥蒂的人之间的关系，当这种感情已经存在多年，经受住了每一次和解的尝试，并且随着时间的推移不断加深，到了厌恶这个词已经不足以准确形容它，而应该称之为仇恨的地步。
In discussing two such men, one assemblyman will say to another with a knowing shake of his head, They go back a long way. Robert Moses and Franklin Delano Roosevelt went back a very long way. That's right. It's Franklin Roosevelt. We've all heard of him, right? Roman, you're familiar with the name Franklin Delano Roosevelt, right? Once or twice he's come up. Yeah. He comes up sometimes in the talk of American history. But so we all know who this guy is.
在讨论这样两个人时，一个议员会意味深长地摇着头对另一个议员说，他们的恩怨由来已久。罗伯特·摩西和富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福的恩怨由来已久。没错。就是富兰克林·罗斯福。我们都听说过他，对吧？罗曼，你对富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福这个名字很熟悉吧？他曾被提起过一两次。是的。他在谈论美国历史时有时会被提起。但我们都知道这家伙是谁。
He's eventually going to become one of the massive figures of the 20th century. He's going to be known as FDR, but this is the pre-presidency FDR. This is not yet the four-time elected president rallying America through the depression, fighting most of World War II, Franklin Roosevelt. At this point, Franklin Roosevelt is just a snooty state politician with a very famous last name. His distant cousin was president and that gets him a lot in the political world of the early 20th century. And something I wanna point out
他最终将成为20世纪的巨头之一。他将被尊称为FDR，但这还是总统任期之前的FDR。这还不是那个四次当选、在经济灾难中凝聚美国、并参与了大半次二战的富兰克林·罗斯福。此时的富兰克林·罗斯福只是一个顶着大名鼎鼎姓氏的趾高气扬的州政客。他的远房堂兄曾当过总统，这在20世纪初的政治世界里为他带来了巨大优势。而我想指出的一点是
before we get into the death rivalry between Roosevelt and Moses, which doesn't really seem to hamper Moses that much to be honest, is that Caro seems to be making a real point of never saying FDR, but instead saying Roosevelt. He always says Roosevelt or Franklin Roosevelt. And I wonder if that is to keep us from bringing
在我们深入探讨罗斯福和摩西之间你死我活的竞争之前——老实说，这似乎并没有对摩西造成太大影响——卡罗似乎刻意避免说“FDR”，而是坚持说“罗斯福”。他总是说“罗斯福”或“富兰克林·罗斯福”，我很好奇这是不是为了阻止我们把
to his discussion of Roosevelt, all the kind of mythic freight that even by 1974 when this book came out had already been accumulated by FDR. I think he wants us to remember this is not FDR, the Titan. This is Franklin Roosevelt, the upstate New York politician. And so I want us to us to remember this is not FDR the Titan. This is Franklin Roosevelt the upstate New York politician and so I want us to try to follow that it's very hard I was going through my notes and I kept saying FDR in them But I want to try to to incentivize us not to say FDR
各种神话般的历史包袱代入他对罗斯福的讨论中，即便在1974年本书出版时，FDR这个名字早已积攒了无数光环。我想他是想让我们记住，这并非那个泰坦巨星FDR。这是富兰克林·罗斯福，那个来自纽约州北部的政客。所以我想让我们记住这并非那个泰坦巨星FDR。这是富兰克林·罗斯福，那个纽约州北部的政客，因此我想让我们努力保持这种称呼，这其实挺难的，我翻看笔记时总是不由自主地写下FDR，但我希望能提醒自己尽量不说FDR。
So every time we say FDR instead of Roosevelt Franklin Roosevelt, we're gonna have to put a quarter into this jar Insert jar sound effect. That's the FDR jar. If we say FDR, we gotta put a quarter in there. So Roman, I'm gonna need you to be honest with me on this. I hope you have quarters in your pocket. Yeah, I do. I have plenty of quarters. And I think this is totally right because this is actually a point that is brought up a lot
所以每次我们不说“罗斯福”或“富兰克林·罗斯福”，而是说“FDR”时，我们就得往这个罐子里投一枚25美分硬币。插入罐子音效。这就是FDR罐子。如果我们说了FDR，我们就得往里投一枚硬币。所以罗曼，我需要你在这件事上对我说实话。我希望你口袋里有硬币。是的，我有。我有很多硬币。我觉得这完全正确，因为这其实是一个经常被提及的点
in the Lyndon Johnson books is that because Lyndon Johnson is so obsessed with FDR and is this acolyte of FDR, he actually like insists that people call him LBJ and he'll do this thing, he'll go like FDR, LBJ, FDR, LBJ, see, see, see, see. And. Three, three, I have a middle name and he has a middle name,
在林登·约翰逊的书中，因为林登·约翰逊对FDR极其痴迷，是FDR的崇拜者，他甚至坚持让别人叫他LBJ，他会做这样的事，他会说，FDR，LBJ，FDR，LBJ，看，看，看，看。而且。三，三，我有个中间名，他也有个中间名，
we're the same guy. And he does that and it must have just burned his ass that JFK came along before him to usurp the initials as an icon. But what it reminds me of our guest for this episode later on is AOC, which she entered the stage as a national figure very quickly, and that three initial like nickname,
我们是同一种人。他这么做，当肯尼迪在他之前出现并篡取了首字母缩写作为偶像时，他心里肯定气急败坏。但这让我想起了我们这期节目稍后的嘉宾AOC，她作为全国性人物迅速登上了舞台，而那三个首字母构成的昵称，
um, really became part of her brand. It's funny how in the United States, I don't know if it's in other countries, I apologize, foreign listeners, if this is a thing you also do that the three initial branding became such a, became such a branding tool. Like you're saying FDFDR, eventually we had JFK, Harry S. Truman was never H, after FDR, eventually we had JFK,
嗯，真的成为了她个人品牌的一部分。有趣的是在美国，我不知道在其他国家是不是这样，海外听众如果你们也有这种做法请原谅我，首字母品牌化竟然成了这样一种，成了这样一种品牌工具。就像你说的FDFDR，最终我们有了JFK，哈里·S·杜鲁门从来都不是H，在FDR之后，最终我们有了JFK，
Harry S Truman was never HST, you know, and Dwight David Eisenhower was never DDE, but that JFK and then LBJ and that it's such a, there's a rhythm to it that is so, um, inescapable, I guess, if the letters, uh, allow it. And it's such a way of attaching yourself to the feeling that comes off of, I assume FDR. And I have to assume that FDR started being called that
哈里·S·杜鲁门从来都不是HST，你知道的，德怀特·大卫·艾森豪威尔从来都不是DDE，但JFK然后是LBJ，这其中有一种节奏，如果字母允许的话，简直是让人无法摆脱的，我猜。这是一种将自己依附于某种情感的方式，我假设这种情感源自FDR。我不得不假设人们开始叫FDR
partly because Teddy Roosevelt, his, or Theodore Roosevelt, who hated being called Teddy, his distant cousin when he was president was often known as TR. And maybe it was FDR was like, I'm one better. I've got another letter in my name. But, and FR sounds weird. I don't know. I was, you know, I had this sort of a hypothesis that was sort of forming in my name. But an FR sounds weird. I don't know.
部分原因是因为泰迪·罗斯福，他的，也就是西奥多·罗斯福——他讨厌别人叫他泰迪——当他担任总统时，他的远房堂兄通常被称为TR。也许FDR的意思是，我比你更胜一筹。我的名字里多了一个字母。但FR听起来很怪。我不知道，我当时，你知道的，我脑子里曾产生过这样一种假设。但FR听起来很怪。我不知道。
I had this sort of hypothesis that was sort of forming in my head that maybe the middle name has to be kind of a long three syllable middle name for it to work. But that's not true because of LBJ. So, because veins is just one syllable. Yeah, this one amazing, amazing syllable. Gets its own letter. You should do a nine MPI episode about initials.
我脑子里曾产生过这样一种假设，也许中间名必须是那种长长的三个音节的中间名才行得通。但因为LBJ的存在，这并不是真的。所以，因为veins只有一个音节。是的，这个惊人、惊人的音节。拥有它自己的字母。你应该做一期关于首字母缩写的九成无形节目。
I don't know why you haven't done that yet. I mean, I have done some reading about middle names because what's notable is that, you know, John Quincy Adams being our first sort of middle name known president is actually a very early example of an American with a middle name. Oh, yeah. Which is kind of interesting.
我不知道为什么你还没做这个。我的意思是，我确实读过一些关于中间名的书，因为值得注意的是，你知道的，约翰·昆西·亚当斯作为我们第一个拥有众所周知的中间名的总统，其实是一个美国人拥有中间名的非常早期的例子。噢，是的。这其实挺有趣的。
That's true. Middle names don't go back that far. They do not. But John Quincy Adams is because, you know, his since his dad, John Adams, was also president. I assume that the president's guild said you can't have to do John Adams. You have to register your middle name also the same way that like Michael J. Fox had to register his middle initial because there's already a Michael Fox in the guild. Anyway, that's not initial talk. So, Franklin Roosevelt, he is a democratic
确实如此。中间名可没有那么悠久的历史。它们没有。但约翰昆西亚当斯之所以有，是因为，你知道的，既然他的父亲约翰亚当斯也是总统。我猜总统协会规定你不能也叫约翰亚当斯。你必须把你的中间名也登记备案，就像迈克尔·J·福克斯必须登记他的中间名首字母，因为公会里已经有一个迈克尔·福克斯了。不管怎样，这不是首字母讨论。所以，富兰克林·罗斯福，他是一个民主党
politician, but he is a state democratic politician. In the New York state democratic party at the time, Roosevelt and the Al Smith circle, which is the city Democrats, they had this relationship based on need. The Al Smith is part of this Irish Catholic, Tammany urban environment, and they need the help of someone like Roosevelt to get the upstate Protestant, Tammany-hating, city-hating
政客，但他是一个州级民主党政客。在当时的纽约州民主党内部，罗斯福和阿尔·史密斯圈子（也就是城市民主党人）之间保持着一种基于需求的互惠关系。阿尔·史密斯属于天主教爱尔兰裔的坦慕尼协会城市圈子，他们需要像罗斯福这样的人的帮助，来搞定纽约州北部的抗拒新教、憎恨坦慕尼、
country folk. Which is funny because I think a lot of people, if you're not from New York State, you kind of assume New York City and New York State are kind of the same thing. And it is, especially at the time, a huge state compared to other states. And the outside of the city areas are very different from the city itself. But Franklin Roosevelt, he has the trust of those kind of upstate farmers that make up the backbone of the state Republican Party because in 1911, he stopped the Tammany candidate from being appointed to the U.S. Senate. And that made him some enemies on the Tammany side, but made him kind of a name people trusted
憎恨城市的乡村民众。这很有趣，因为我认为很多人，如果你不是来自纽约州，你大概会想当然地认为纽约市和纽约州基本上是一回事。而且它确实是一个大州，尤其在当时与其他州相比。城市以外的地区与城市本身有很大不同。但富兰克林·罗斯福赢得了那些纽约州北部农民的信任，而这些农民构成了州共和党的中坚力量，因为在1911年，他阻止了坦慕尼协会候选人被任命为美国参议员。这为他在坦慕尼协会那边树敌，但也让他成为了一个在城市以外备受信任的名字。而且，正如我们所提到的，他拥有那个著名的姓氏。人们喜爱西奥多·罗斯福。西奥多·罗斯福曾担任总统，并进行了有史以来最成功的第三党总统竞选。人们依然对他的生平记忆犹新。这距离
outside of the city. And also, as we mentioned, he's got that famous name. People love Theodore Roosevelt. Theodore Roosevelt, this has served as president, had the most successful third party run for president anyone's ever had. People still remember him in living memory. This is only 20 some odd years
西奥多·罗斯福担任总统仅仅过了二十多年。罗斯福曾多次支持史密斯竞选总统。在1924年，他在民主党大会上发表了提名演讲，正是在那次大会上，史密斯得到了“快乐战士”的绰号，除了“东区西区”之外，这是阿尔·史密斯品牌的另一部分，被称为“快乐战士”。正如我们所提到的，歌曲《东区西区》后面还会再次出现。还有一件有趣的事，这在一定程度上与罗斯福的故事有关，
after Theodore Roosevelt was president. And Roosevelt had supported Smith for president multiple times. In 1924, he had given the nominating speech at the Democratic convention that was where Smith got the nickname the Happy Warrior, which is along with East Side West Side, that's the other part of the Al Smith brand is being called the Happy Warrior. And the song East Side West Side, as we mentioned, will come up again. And something that was interesting, which plays into the Roosevelt story a little bit,
那就是那次公开露面、那次大会，卡罗指出，这是罗斯福在感染小儿麻痹症并基本上从腰部以下瘫痪之后，第一次重大公众露面。对于史密斯来说，罗斯福来做这个提名意义重大。这给予了他极大的支持。但另一方面，罗斯福在社交上从来没有真正融入史密斯的圈子。卡罗对罗斯福的描述是，他有点尴尬地给罗伯特·摩西打电话说，嘿，如果你要去跟阿尔·史密斯混，能带上我吗？
is that that appearance, that convention, this was the first time, Carol points out, that Roosevelt made a major public appearance after contracting polio and being essentially paralyzed, for the most part, from the waist down. And it meant a lot to Smith that Roosevelt was the one giving that nomination. It gave him that support. But on the other hand, Roosevelt never fit in socially with the Smith crowd. And Carrow kind of describes Roosevelt kind of like awkwardly calling Robert Moses and being like, hey, if you're going to go hang out with Al Smith, like, can I come with you?
就像，你能带上我一起去吗？这看起来太可怜了。而且他每次这么做都很尴尬。史密斯对罗斯福也算喜欢，但卡罗引用史密斯的话说：“富兰克林绝不是那种你能带进撒尿间去推心置腹的人。”这真是老派政客思考盟友的典型方式。这就是我们上一次谈论的事情之一，也是我们这次要大量谈论的，
Like, can you take me with you? Which is, which seems so pathetic. And it's always awkward when he does. And Smith likes Roosevelt well enough, but Carroll quotes him as saying, Franklin just isn't the kind of man you can take into the piss room and talk intimately with, which is a real old school politics way of thinking about your allies. And this is one of the things we were talking
这就是人格政治。尽管阿尔·史密斯和罗伯特·摩西看起来像是某种奇怪的政治同床异梦者，但他们就是互相看得顺眼，你知道吗？事情就是这么简单。而罗斯福跟这些寻欢作乐的家伙并不能真正合得来。
about last time and we'll talk about a lot this time, is this the politics of personality. And even though Al Smith and Robert Moses might seem like sort of odd political bedfellows, they just like each other, you know? And it's real simple. And Roosevelt doesn't really get along with these good time guys.
我觉得我坚定地站在富兰克林·罗斯福这一边，因为我也不是那种能够被带进撒尿间去推心置腹的人。你知道的，就像。所以我此刻对罗斯福感同身受。是的，看到这一切很难不，是的，很难不对那个被排挤在外的人感同身受，尽管罗斯福比这两个家伙中的任何一个都要富有得多，
I feel like I am firmly in the Franklin Roosevelt camp that I'm not also the type of man that you can take into the piss room and talk intimately with. You know, like. And so I feel for Roosevelt at this point. Yeah, it's, it's hard to see it and not, yeah, and not feel for the person who's kept on the outside, even though Roosevelt is much wealthier than either of these
而且在感染小儿麻痹症之前，他的生活在某些方面要更容易一些，但在那之后他的生活变得无比艰难。但是每个人都低估了罗斯福。他，然后在他的生活变得无比艰难之后。但是每个人都低估了罗斯福。他的一生都在被人低估。他被视为反复无常。他在哈佛时得到了“掸子”这个外号。他的同班同学给他起了这个外号，
two guys and has had a, in some ways easier life until that moment that he gets polio and then his life becomes incredibly difficult. Uh, but everyone underestimates Roosevelt. He, he and then his life becomes incredibly difficult. But everyone underestimates Roosevelt. He has spent his life being underestimated. He's seen as flighty. He got that nickname, the feather duster, when he was at Harvard. His classmates nicknamed him that
因为人们认为他不够深沉，也不是那种能对某件事保持长久兴趣的人。在政治上，他被视为那种虚荣傲慢、自以为是但又没有实际成就来支撑的政客。而卡罗指出，他们没有考虑到他在瘫痪后重新回到政治世界所需要的个人力量。
because he was not considered particularly deep or someone you could rely on to stay interested in something. And in politics, he's seen as kind of like this prissy snob who is entitled, but doesn't have the achievements to back that up. And what Carroll points out is they're not taking into account the personal strength it took to get back into the political world after being paralyzed.
在罗斯福一生的故事中，贯穿着一条主线：他绝不让别人知道他的身体残疾到底有多严重。这导致人们完全低估了他，因为这家伙要走到撒尿间需要付出巨大的意志力。仅仅是站起来走到洗手间都需要付出巨大的力量，以至于他能重新振作并成为公众人物，这简直令人震惊。除了贝尔·莫斯科维茨之外，似乎没有人意识到FDR正在为自己某天竞选州长乃至最终竞选总统奠定基础。她看穿了FDR……噢，我正想说FDR正在为自己某天竞选州长乃至最终竞选总统奠定基础，除了贝尔·莫斯科维茨。
And there's a thread that runs through the Roosevelt story throughout his life of him not letting people know just how debilitating his physical handicap is. And it's something that causes people to underestimate him completely, because it takes so much willpower for this guy to get to the piss room. So much strength even to stand up and make it to the bathroom, that to get back and become a public figure is astounding. And nobody seems to realize that FDR is laying the groundwork to run for governor himself someday, and then to president eventually, except for Bel Moskowitz. She sees FDR... Oh, I was about to say FDR is laying the groundwork to run for governor himself someday and then to president eventually, except for Bell Moskowitz.
她看穿了F，她正要说FDR。你知道的，我说出来了。好吧。我得往罐子里投一枚硬币。等等。她将FDR视为一种威胁，但所有人都告诉她她错了。贝尔，你的直觉失准了。你根本不知道自己在说些什么。
She sees F, she's about to say FDR. You know what I said it. Okay. I'll just put a quarter in the jar. Hold on. She sees FDR as a threat, but everyone tells her that she's wrong. Bell, your instincts are off. You don't, you don't know what you're talking about.
但贝尔·莫斯科维茨从不会出错。她从一开始就把FDR当成FDR来看待。是的，是的，她知道罗斯福也把自己看作FDR。把自己看作这样的人物，左一枚右一枚地往里扔硬币。好吧，1924年。我们稍微倒回了一点，回到1924年。当阿尔·史密斯任命摩西为长岛州立公园委员会主席时，
But Bell Moskowitz is never wrong. She sees FDR as FDR, like from the get-go. Yes, yes, she knows that Roosevelt sees himself as FDR too. Sees himself as this figure, just dropping coins in left and right. Okay, 1924. We've sort of jumped back a little bit to 1924. When Al Smith appoints Moses President
他也任命罗斯福为北部州立公园委员会（Taconic State Park Commission）的主席。他们一见面就立刻针锋麦立。摩西告诉卡罗，他认为这是因为他屡次阻止罗斯福给顾问路易斯·豪安排恩赐职位，路易斯·豪在所有人眼中都是个讨厌鬼，
in the Long Island State Park Commission, he also points Roosevelt to chairman of the Taconic State Park Commission upstate. They are immediately at each other's throats. And Moses tells Caro that he thinks this is because he kept stopping Roosevelt from giving a patronage job to this advisor, Louis Howe, who everybody thought was horrible,
但对罗斯福极其忠诚，在罗斯福患上小儿麻痹症后，他放弃了一份丰厚的工作来帮助罗斯福。但卡罗有不同的理论。他认为这两人只是同样傲慢、野心勃勃的家伙。他们都想同时拥有权力。他们都是小池塘里的大鱼，罗斯福也为他在城市郊外、北部家乡达奇斯县的公园和林荫大道制定了自己的计划。而摩西总是说，是的，罗斯福，是的，你可以，你可以建造那些公园。那太棒了。你脑子里有整个公园系统。
but who was very loyal to Roosevelt and who gave up a lucrative job to help Roosevelt after Roosevelt was stricken with polio. But Caro thinks it's a different theory. He thinks these are just two arrogant, ambitious men. They both want power at the same time. They're both big fish in a small pond and Roosevelt also has his plans for parks and parkways for his native Duchess County outside the city, upstate. And Moses is always like, yeah, Roosevelt, yeah, you can, you can build those parks. That'd be great. You've got a whole park system in
是的，绝对的。你肯定能获得建造它的资源，直到摩西掌权为止。然后他就说，不，这笔钱要归长岛州立公园系统。抱歉，达奇斯县。抱歉，抱歉，掸子。每年罗斯福都要申请资金，而摩西都说，不，你不能拿。罗斯福气得威胁要辞职。这真是太讽刺了，他竟然在玩，在玩摩西的把戏，而且阿尔·史密斯不得不亲自出面平息。太讽刺了，他竟然在玩摩西的把戏。
mind. Yeah, definitely. You'll definitely get the resources to build that until Moses is in charge. And then he's like, no, this money goes to the Long Island state park system. Sorry, Dutchess County. Sorry, sorry, feather duster. And every year Roosevelt requests money and Moses says, no, you can't have it. And Roosevelt gets so mad that he threatens to resign. Very ironic that he's, he's pulling, pulling a Moses play and, uh, Al Smith has to personally smooth things ironic that he's pulling a Moses play.
而阿尔·史密斯不得不亲自出面平息，因为他希望罗斯福在1928年的民主党大会上提名他，当时他将再次竞选总统。大会召开了，罗斯福提名了史密斯，史密斯赢得了提名。我们知道，由于全国范围内存在的反城市和反天主教情绪，他不可能赢得总统大选。他请求罗斯福成为他作为州长的继任者。你认为摩西对罗斯福坐上老板位子的想法有什么感觉？摩西恨透了这个主意。
And Al Smith has to personally smooth things over because he wants Roosevelt to nominate him at the 1928 Democratic Convention when he's going to run for president again. That convention happens, Roosevelt nominates Smith, Smith wins the nomination. We know that he's not going to win the presidency due to kind of anti-urban and anti-Catholic sentiment throughout the country. And he asks Roosevelt to be his successor as governor. How do you think Moses feels about that idea of Roosevelt taking the boss's seat? Moses hates this idea.
这也是少数几次摩西将自己的党派归属从共和党改为民主党的情况之一，仅仅是为了当阿尔·史密斯腾出这个席位去竞选总统或者竞选失败不再担任州长时，他或许能被考虑接替这个席位。是的，这是一个体现了摩西惊人直觉的例子，
And this is one of the few times where Moses changes his party affiliation from Republican to Democrat, just so he could maybe be considered for that seat if Al Smith vacates it to either become president or loses and therefore is no longer the governor. Yes, and this is an instance where Moses has such an amazing instinct
他对于某种特定政治——谈判、交易以及把事情办成的政治——有着惊人的直觉。但对于选民政治、选举政治以及如何让人们为事物投票的政治，他的直觉却糟糕透顶，因为对于任何党派人物来说，都很清楚摩西根本不是那种你可以作为州长候选人去参选并能保住席位的人，尤其是在这样一年里，
for a certain type of politics, the politics of negotiations and deals and getting things done. And he has such a poor instinct for the politics of voters and the electorate and getting people to vote for things because it would be very clear to any kind of party figure that Moses is not someone that you can run as governor and keep that seat, especially in a year when,
正如大选不断进行的那样，这越来越成为一场关于他们所谓的罗马主义和坦慕尼协会的选举，他们需要一个与所有这些截然相反的候选人。而摩西，作为阿尔·史密斯的得力助手，不仅是个城市人，而且还带有犹太血统。那种认为“3K党的选票虽然不想投给阿尔·史密斯当总统，但我猜他们会愿意投票给罗伯特·摩西当纽约州北部州长”的想法，根本是不可能的。并不是说纽约州北部每个人都是3K党成员。我绝没有这种暗示，但在当时它确实比现在是一股大得多的势力。因此，他们需要一个在很多方面与阿尔·史密斯截然相反的人，以便在明知阿尔·史密斯无法赢得总统大选的那一年，守住州长职位。但问题是，
as the election continues, it's more and more the election of what they call Rome, Romanism, and Tammany, where they need a candidate who is the opposite of all those things. And Moses, the man who is Al Smith's right-hand man, also is a city guy, is Jewish on top of that. The idea that like, well, the Klan vote doesn't want to vote for Al Smith for president, but I guess they'll vote for Robert Moses for governor upstate. That's not going to happen. Not to say everyone in upstate New York is in the Klan. I'm not making that implication at all, but it was a much bigger force at the time than it is now. And so they need someone who is the opposite of Al Smith in many ways so that they can keep the governorship in a year where it's very clear Al Smith is not going
摩西刚刚重组了州政府。他的重组做得如此出色，以至于各州政党，哪怕像罗斯福这样分量较轻的人，也没法把它搞得太糟。我们这里有摩西系统在运转呢。没错。而且你知道的，在这个时候，你知道的，罗斯福有着那些，你知道的，长期酝酿的计划，想要以风卷残云之势拿下州长职位乃至最终的总统宝座。
to win the presidency. But the thing is, Moses has just reorganized the state government. His reorganization is so good that state parties like even a lightweight like Roosevelt can't screw it up too much. We've got the Moses system working here. That's right. And you know, at this point, you know, Roosevelt has had these, you know, long running, long gestating plans to, you know, take both the governorship and maybe eventually the presidency by storm.
但他知道，从纽约州州长选举的角度来看，这很可能是一个属于共和党的年份，所以他不想参选。但阿尔·史密斯说服了他无论如何都要参选。然而在罗斯福竞选期间，摩西看到了这样一个未来：他将不得不为富兰克林·罗斯福工作，而他对此痛恨至极。
But he knows that this is probably a Republican year, when it comes to like the governorship of New York and he does not wanna run. But Al Smith, persuades him to run anyway. But as Roosevelt's campaigning, Moses is seeing this future where he's gonna be working for Franklin Roosevelt and he hates it.
他私下对罗斯福的评论变得越来越恶毒。而这些评论传到了罗斯福耳中，其中大部分都是在侮辱埃莉诺·罗斯福的长相，这简直是，这简直是太残忍了。这是一种极其卑劣的做法。他在暗示，也许我们并不知道罗斯福的小儿麻痹症到底有多严重，卡罗对此语焉不详，但我不得不认为他在暗示罗斯福失去了性功能，
And his private comments about Roosevelt are getting more and more vicious. And these comments are getting back to Roosevelt and most of this is, uh, insulting Eleanor Roosevelt's looks, which is just like, just a cruel thing to do. Just a mean thing to do. He is implying that maybe we don't know just how debilitating Roosevelt's polio was and Caro dances around this, but I have to assume that he's implying that Roosevelt is impotent, that,ent, that he's not a man anymore.
暗示他已经不再是个男人了。罗斯福得知了这一切，他开始放话：如果我当选州长，我要把摩西踢走。我绝不让他在我的政府里待着。而在选举日当天，正如我们所知，赫伯特·胡佛以压倒性优势击败了阿尔·史密斯。阿尔·史密斯甚至没有赢得纽约州。这太疯狂了。这是他的家乡州，他竟然连这里都没拿下。但罗斯福成功当选了州长，而阿尔·史密斯，
And Roosevelt learns of all this and he starts saying, if I'm elected governor, I want Moses out. I do not want him in my government. And on election day, as we know, Herbert Hoover trounces Al Smith. Al Smith doesn't even win New York state. That's bonkers. It's his home state and he doesn't even get it. But Roosevelt makes it in as governor and Al Smith, there's a couple of
阿尔·史密斯身上发生了一些令人悲伤的事情。他接受了一份私人工作并退出了政坛，但他总是说：“富兰克林，如果你需要任何建议，随时找我。我一直都在。我随时听候你的差遣。随时找我。如果你想要我作为州长的建议的话。”而罗斯福则说：“我会的，阿尔。”
sad things that happen with Al Smith. So he takes this private job and retires from politics, but he's always like, Franklin, if you ever need advice, just call on me. I'm always here. I'm always at your disposal. Just call on me. If you ever want your advice as governor. And Roosevelt's like, I'll do that out.
但他从没这么做过。他从未向阿尔·史密斯求助过。阿尔·史密斯对此感到十分灰心丧气。没有人确切知道原因何在。也许他有政治上的考量。也许他只是喜欢利用别人，等不需要的时候就一脚踢开。或者是因为阿尔·史密斯
And he never does. He never calls on him. Al Smith is demoralized by this. Nobody is ever sure why. Maybe he has political reasons for it. Maybe he just likes to use people and then discard them when he doesn't need them anymore. Or maybe it's because Al Smith
低估了罗斯福的智商，以为罗斯福事后会成为他的傀儡。我们无法确知。好吧，我的意思是，我认为对此最宽容的解释是，罗斯福想要当州长，而他接替的是纽约州历史上最受欢迎的州长，他想要按自己的方式管理政府。
underestimated his intelligence and thought that Roosevelt would be kind of a puppet for him afterwards. We don't know for sure. Well, I mean, I think the most generous interpretation of this is that Roosevelt wants to be governor and he's following up the most popular governor in New York state's history and he wants to run his own administration.
就像，是的，我觉得这是那种宽容、积极的解释，但消极的解释则是他怀恨在心。他想伤害一个老人。但我认为你说得对，富兰克林·罗斯福的想法是：“好吧，我现在是州长了。凭什么我要按照你希望的方式做事，只因为你想让我这么做？”我觉得你说得对。
Like, Yeah, I like that's the generous, that's the generous positive one, but the negative one would be that he's got a vendetta. He wants to hurt an old man. But I think you're right that Franklin Roosevelt is like, well, I'm governor now. Like, why would I, why would I do the things that you want me to do just because you want me to do them? I think you're right.
卡罗太迷恋阿尔·史密斯了，以至于我认为任何对阿尔·史密斯的轻视，他都会变得有点敏感。他确实对阿尔·史密斯和他的角色怀有深厚的感情。书中确实有一些非常温馨的场景，表达了对处于这种处境中的阿尔·史密斯的同情。
Caro's so in love with Al Smith that I think any slight on Al Smith, he gets a little, he gets sensitive about too. He does seem to have great affection for Al Smith and his role. And there are some very sweet scenes that are, you know, empathizing with Al Smith in this position.
我的意思是，你知道的，他当时并不老。我的意思是，我想他才刚过五十岁，对吧？是的。所以，你知道的，对他来说，在这个他真正找到自我、学会政治的世界里变得无所事事，基本上是在奥尔巴尼的法律书籍中自学成才，
I mean, like, you know, he is not old at this point. I mean, he's in his early 50s, I think, right? Yeah. And so, you know, for him at this point to become inactive in this world that like he really found himself, you know, like learned politics, basically taught himself to read in law books in Albany
并成为了一代巨头，这对他来说真的是一次巨大的坠落。我同时也能理解罗斯福的观点，他会想：“你知道的，我必须按自己的方式来管理事务。我的意思是，我是州长，我对此很感激，但我现在不需要任何建议。”所以我也能理解。我也能理解。
and becomes this Titan. Um, it's a real fall for him. I just can also see the point of view of Roosevelt going like, you know, I have to run things my way. I mean, I am the governor and, and I appreciate it, but I don't need any advice right now. And so I kind of get it. So I get it too.
而史密斯对罗斯福说：“你可以解雇行政部门里的任何人，但你必须留下莫斯科维茨太太和罗伯特·摩西。”而罗斯福则说：“不，我不要，我不想留下这个。我不想留下他们。我尤其不想留下摩西。”他告诉史密斯：“不，他让我浑身不自在。”
And Smith Smith says to Roosevelt, you can fire anyone in the administration, but you got to keep Mrs. Moskowitz and Robert Moses. And Roosevelt is like, no, I don't, I don't want to keep that. I don't want to keep them. And I especially don't want to keep Moses. He tells Smith, no, he rubs me the wrong way.
当然，罗斯福只能解除摩西国务卿的职务，因为摩西在起草赋予他公园职务的法律时做得太好了，以至于那些职位根本不在罗斯福的掌控之中。他是长岛公园委员会的主任，那个职位到1930年才到期。他是州公园委员会的主席，该委员会由委员会自身选举产生，而他对此拥有控制权。他的亲信和他自己都在那个委员会里，而且根据规则，摩西只能因违法而被罢免，甚至没有人知道他在公园内部在搞什么鬼。这一切如此不透明，以至于你不得不
Of course, Roosevelt can only remove Moses from the secretary of state office because Moses has done such a good job of writing the law that gives him his parks jobs that those aren't in Roosevelt's control. He's the head of the Long Island Park Commission that position doesn't expire until 1930. He's chairman of the State Parks Council that's elected by the council itself which he has control of. It's his people who along with him are on that council and Moses the rule says he can only be removed for illegality and nobody even knows what he's doing inside the parks. It's so opaque that you'd have to
展开一场调查。他太受欢迎了，如果针对他的调查没有查出任何问题，那将是一个巨大的风险。而且他为自己建立起了独立的权力。卡罗提到了一次与摩西进行了四个小时的严肃采访，在采访快结束时，摩西终于为法律几乎让罗斯福无法罢免他而大笑起来。多年以后，这依然是一个让人忍俊不禁的笑点。当摩西得知自己不会被重新任命为国务卿时，他先发制人地向媒体宣布辞职，以此来让罗斯福难堪。罗斯福不得不发表公开声明，感谢摩西继续留任他的公园职务，尽管他卸任了国务卿，但国务卿这个职位与摩西担任时掌握的大权相比，已经被大幅度降格了。罗斯福重新任命了阿尔·史密斯的所有官员，基本上除了摩西和莫斯科维茨，以及其他几个人之外。在就职典礼上，罗斯福和史密斯表面上表现得十分友好，但摩西特意在罗斯福发表就职演说前就退场了。他们真是太小肚鸡肠了。这些人可是全州最有权势的人物。他们竟然互相耍这么小的脾气。
launch an investigation. He's so popular that an investigation of him, if it didn't find anything, would be a huge risk. And he's established this independent power for himself. And Caro makes a mention of a very serious four-hour interview with Moses, where at the end of it, Moses finally laughs at how the law made it nearly impossible for Roosevelt to remove him. That was still a chuckle buster years later. And when Moses learns he's not going to be reappointed as Secretary of State, he preemptively announces his resignation to the press to embarrass Roosevelt. And Roosevelt has to put out a public statement thanking Moses for staying on in his park posts, that even though he's leaving Secretary of State, that position of Secretary of State gets demoted considerably
这简直荒谬。是的，我想我改变主意了。这可能只是一堆无聊的扯皮，才导致他们不断争吵。不，你知道的，我更喜欢你那种比较宽容的解释。我的意思是，罗斯福这个人，他在书中的形象并不那么光彩，但我觉得他是一个宽容的人。我的意思是，罗斯福这个人，
from the powerful position that it was when Moses had it. Roosevelt reappoints every one of Smith's officials, except for Moses and Moskowitz, basically, and a couple of others. And at the inauguration, Roosevelt and Smith, they put on the show of friendship, but Moses makes a point of walking out before Roosevelt can give his inaugural address. They are being so petty. These are the most powerful people in the state. They're being so petty with each other.
他在书中的形象并不那么光彩，但他是一个我真心觉得——除了他那动摇的总统任期内的一两件事之外，显然比如日裔集中营事件是令人发指的——除此之外，我发现他是一个如此惊人的巨擘，一个如此令人难以置信的泰坦式人物，以至于看到他在书中表现得如此小肚鸡肠，真的，真的很让人失望。但你也可以想象一下，罗伯特·摩西到底有多讨人嫌。我的意思是，是的，我完全可以理解——“我才不要继承这家伙呢，我对这毫无兴趣。”贝尔·莫斯科维茨在很多方面都非常优秀，但也显得对阿尔·史密斯过于忠诚，以至于你会再次觉得：“好吧，她为什么要在我的手下干这个？她在这个角色上分明只是在为阿尔·史密斯效力。”所以我完全能理解那个理由。就像当你处理这一切事情，拥有这么多人和这么多责任时，
It is ridiculous. Yeah, I guess I changed my mind. It's probably just a bunch of back and forth nonsense that's making them fight. No, you know, I like your interpretation of it better that it was generous. I mean, Roosevelt is someone who, he does not come off amazing in this book, that it was generous. I mean, Roosevelt is someone who,
身边一直有个眼中钉，这个罗伯特·摩西，我完全会想：“我非得把这根刺拔出来不可。不管拔出来有多疼，我都得把它从我体内弄出去。”绝对是的。拥有摩西这个深爱阿尔·史密斯的人——后来书中提到他管阿尔·史密斯叫“州长”，但管罗斯福叫“弗兰克”，他从不叫他“州长”——你会想：“我非得应付这家伙不可吗？得了吧，带点我自己的人来。好歹有人叫我州长，大声点告诉我，那才是我的头衔。”
he does not come off amazing in this book, but he's someone who I genuinely, except for one or two things in his tenuous presidency, obviously like the Japanese relocation camps are abominable. But otherwise I find him to be such an amazing figure, such a titanic, unbelievable figure, that to see him being this petty throughout the book is really, it's really disappointing. But you can also just imagine what level of pain
所以，他们现在只能互相将就了。接下来我们进入第17章，下一章《顺应之母》。这一章非常精彩，它解释了为什么罗伯特·摩西在经历阿尔·史密斯不再支持他的这段动荡时期时，依然能够保持并不断增长他的权力。
in the ass Robert Moses is. I mean like yes I could totally just like I'm not inheriting this guy I have no interest in this and Belmoskowitz seems perfectly great in so many respects but also seems so loyal to Al Smith that again, you're just like, well, why is she working for me here? Like she's just working for Al Smith in this role. And so I can totally understand that reason. And like when you're doing all this stuff and you have all these people and all these responsibilities,
原因就在于，正如阿尔·史密斯所学到的那样，罗斯福也明白了，给人们的生活带来显而易见的改善，才是继续当好州长的绝佳途径。是的，完全正确。所以摩西进入这个行政团队时，并不确定自己能否得到史密斯一直给予他的行政支持，而这一点很快就受到了考验，因为事实证明，
having this thorn in your side the whole time, Robert Moses, I could totally say like, I'm just gonna dig this thing out. I don't care how bad it feels to dig it out. I want it out of my body. Definitely. Yeah. To have Moses, this guy who loves Al Smith, it comes up later that he calls Al Smith governor, but he calls Roosevelt Frank. He never calls him governor. That the, that like, you'd be like, do I have to deal with this guy? Like, come on, let's bring in some of my people. Some people call me governor for crying out loud
有一个地方他在修建北部州立公园，在他想要修路的荒地和荒野之间没有留下任何空间，他们似乎打算利用罗斯福的背景来对付摩西，因为他们实际上雇佣了罗斯福的一位老哈佛同窗，一个名叫格伦维尔·克拉克（Grenville Clark）的人，听起来又是一个律师，
that that's my title. So, but they're stuck with each other for now. So we go to chapter 17, the next one, the mother of accommodation. And it's a great chapter that sort of explains why Robert Moses through this tumultuous period of not having the support of Al Smith, still both retains and actually grows his power.
在世纪之交读过哈佛。他们雇他来对抗摩西，而克拉克发现了摩西最大的秘密——这正是多年后卡罗提起时，摩西气得直接不再和卡罗说话的那件事——也就是奥托·卡恩（Otto Kahn）为了让北部州立公园绕过他的高尔夫球场、穿过一系列家族农场（或者主要是其中一个农场），而给摩西筑路工程提供的1万美元贿赂。克拉克将这一信息透露给了那些痛恨摩西的州议员哈钦森和休伊，上一集中摩西像一只立法界的兔八哥、像一只官僚行政界的
And it is because, you know, Roosevelt learns just like Al Smith learned that having noticeable improvements to people's lives, nipples, is a great way to stay governor. Yes, exactly. So Moses, he enters this administration, not sure he's going to have the executive support that Smith always gave him and That gets tested very quickly because it turns out there's there's this one spot where he's building the Northern State Parkway Where there's no space between the barren estates that he wants to run the road and the barrens it seems like they're gonna use Roosevelt's a background against Moses because they actually hire one of Roosevelt's old Harvard classmates, a guy named Grenville Clark, who again, sounds like an attorney,
达菲鸭一样把他们耍得团团转。他们明确表示，任何试图将道路改道穿过这片被称为惠特利山（Wheatley Hills）的富豪区（Barons）的企图，都将引发一场公开的斗争，他们将曝光摩西与卡恩的交易，并且他们要把这事拖到1930年罗斯福竞选连任州长的当口。于是罗斯福同意了这个妥协方案。他们将在该地区周围绕一个两英里的弯，富豪们将承担一小部分改道费用，但这条道路90%以上的成本
went to Harvard at the turn of the century. They hire him to fight Moses and Clark learns of Moses' biggest secret, the thing that literally Moses stopped talking to Caro when Caro brought up years later, which is the $10,000 that OtokCon gave to Moses's road building in order to route the Northern State Parkway around his golf course and through a series of family farms, basically, or one in particular. And Clark gives this information to those Moses-hating state legislators, Hutchinson and Hewitt, that Moses kept outwitting last episode like a legislative Bugs Bunny, like a bureaucratic administrative,
将由纳税人承担。卡罗特意指出，这种妥协以及与奥托·卡恩的妥协意味着，从迪克斯山以东出发、使用北部州立公园上下班进出纽约的通勤者，每个工作日每个方向都必须多走11英里。这意味着每个工作日都有22英里的不必要驾驶，
you know, Daffy Duck. And they make it clear that any attempt to route the road through this area called the Wheatley Hills, where the Barons are, will lead to a public fight, they will expose Moses' deal with Khan, and they'll do it so that it stretches into 1930 when Roosevelt will be running for re-election as governor. So Roosevelt agrees to this compromise. They're going to do a two two mile detour around the area and the barons will pay a little bit toward the cost of the detour, but more than 90% of that road cost
一年下来就是5500英里的不必要里程。因此到了20世纪60年代，成千上万的通勤者因为这些政治交易，在这些额外且不必要的道路上白白浪费了数千万小时的人生。道路上的每一个弯道，都是对那些能够在幕后操纵、挫败表面上属于公众的政府的权贵们权力的献礼。
will be covered by the taxpayers. And Caro takes a moment to point out that this compromise and the compromise with AutoCon meant that commuters from east of the Dix Hills using the Northern State Parkway to commute in and out of New York, they have to go 11 extra miles each way every workday. That's an unnecessary 22 miles of driving every workday,
这一切都契合了卡罗在整本书中贯彻的一个观点：我们生活在其中的人造世界里的每一项选择，都可能基于某种由于权力不民主或反民主而做出的决定。然而，迫使人们做出这些选择的权贵们通常并不需要承担后果。承受代价的，是像你我这样的普通人，乔·播客，对吧，罗曼？没错。是的，我们必须承担这种选择的重量。这也是其中之一。
that's 5,500 unnecessary miles a year. And so by the 1960s, tens of thousands of commuters are wasting tens of millions of hours of their lives on these extra unnecessary miles of road because of these political deals. And each twist in that road is a tribute to the power of the barons who could work behind the scenes to thwart ostensibly public government.
每年多出5500英里不必要的行程。因此，到了20世纪60年代，由于这些政治交易，数以万计的通勤者在这些多余且不必要的道路上浪费了数千万小时的生命。道路上的每一个弯道，都是对那些能够在幕后运作以阻挠表面上是公共政府的权贵们权力的献礼。
It all gets at this idea that Carol has throughout the book that each of the things that we live in in the built world is based on a choice that was made possibly because of power that was undemocratic or anti-democratic. But it's not the powerful people who force those choices that have to live with it usually. It's the ordinary folks like you and me, Joe Podcaster, right, Roman? That's right. Yeah, we have to bear the weight of that choice. And it is one of those things that,
这一切都呼应了卡罗尔在书中贯穿始终的一个观点，即我们所生活的建成环境中的每一件事物，都是基于某种选择，而这种选择可能是因为某种非民主或反民主的权力而做出的。但通常必须承受这些选择后果的，并不是那些强迫做出这些选择的权贵。而是像你我这样的小人物，乔·播客，对吧，罗曼？没错。是的，我们必须承担这些选择的分量。而且这也是其中之一，
I think one of the reasons why it is so devastating reputationally and why it is a good lever to use to control a little bit of what Robert Moses does. It is so antithetical to his image as a champion of people. Yes, I mean, it's the old Trump conundrum. Trump can openly do any number of bad things, but it's like, yeah, we kind of expect that from him. Like, you know, he's a guy that we expect that from.
我想，它在声誉上之所以如此具有毁灭性，之所以成为控制罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）的一点行事的有力手段，原因之一在于：这与他作为民众捍卫者的形象完全背道而驰。是的，我的意思是，这就是特朗普式的难题。特朗普可以公开做出各种坏事，但人们会觉得，好吧，我们对他就这德行，这倒也见怪不怪。就像，你知道的，他就是这么个让人觉得会干出这种事的人。
But if an upstanding type politician gets found out doing something slightly shady, then it destroys that reputation that they have. It's more damaging because of the context of the reputation that it's happening in. So for Robert Moses, it's almost like if people already knew that he was such a deal maker and deal breaker, if he was such a power broker and power smoker that they would-
但如果一个正派的政客被发现做了一些略带阴暗的事，那就会毁掉他们苦心经营的名誉。在所处的声誉背景下，这种伤害往往更大。所以对罗伯特·摩西来说，几乎就好像，如果人们早就知道他是个长袖善舞的幕后交易者、是个专爱毁约的人，如果他是个政坛掮客和政治大鳄，以至于他们会——
And a midnight toker. Yeah, exactly. Oh, if ever there was a guy who was not a midnight toker, I imagine it's Robert Moses. He's too busy tromping the hills of Long Island, looking for roots for roads, and looking for places to build beaches. But it's because, like you're saying exactly, because he has this reputation as this virtuous kind of man of the people, that it would be especially damaging to be seen making deals with the barons who are ostensibly his enemies. Part of this compromise is also that Moses promises he's never going to build parks along
而且还是个半夜抽叶子的。没错，完全是这样。哦，如果说这世上有谁绝对不是那种半夜抽叶子的人，我猜那就是罗伯特·摩西了。他忙着在长岛的山丘间跋涉，为道路寻找路线，为海滩寻找建设地点。但正如你刚才所说，正是因为他有着这种正直的、平民主义者的声誉，所以如果人们看到他和那些表面上是其死敌的资本巨头做交易，将会造成特别巨大的损害。这种妥协的一部分还在于，摩西承诺他绝不会在
that North Shore section that's owned by the barons. And as of the writing of the book in 1974, this was still pretty much the case. Since then, it's not the case. And a lot of the estates up there are now parks and are now open to the public. And they're very beautiful to go to. It makes you mad that it was just privately owned for such a long time. And Caro suggests that maybe Al Smith wouldn't have fallen into this trap, but that Roosevelt suffers a little bit in Albany because he's not seen as trustworthy.
由这些资本巨头拥有的北岸地段修建公园。在1974年本书截稿时，情况基本上依然如此。但自那以后，情况就变了。那里的许多庄园现在都变成了公园，并向公众开放。去那里游玩非常惬意。这让人感到气愤，因为这么好的地方居然被私人占有了那么长时间。卡罗指出，或许阿尔·史密斯（Al Smith）不会陷入这个陷阱，但罗斯福在奥尔巴尼（Albany）的日子有点不好过，因为他没有被视为一个值得信赖的人。
And Moses comes to not see Roosevelt as trustworthy. People expect Roosevelt to lie to them. And it comes to the point where Moses will be like, will you sign this law that I pushed through? And Roosevelt's like, I'll sign it. And then he doesn't do it. So Moses has to literally hang out in Roosevelt's office and physically refuse to leave
而摩西也逐渐认为罗斯福不值得信任。人们本就预料罗斯福会向他们撒谎。事情甚至发展到这种地步：摩西会问，你会签署我极力推动的这项法律吗？罗斯福则回答说，我会签的。然后他却没有兑现。所以摩西不得不字面意义上地赖在罗斯福的办公室里，身体力行地拒绝离开
until Roosevelt signs those laws. Here's the place where I start to feel like Caro was misleading us a little bit, because as you mentioned, despite this big buildup about Roosevelt being his enemy, Moses grows in power during this time. Roosevelt signs most of the bills Moses wants. As we mentioned before,
直到罗斯福签署了那些法律。在这里，我开始觉得卡罗有点误导我们了，因为正如你所提到的，尽管前面大肆渲染罗斯福是他的敌人，但摩西的权力在这期间却不断增长。罗斯福签署了摩西想要的绝大多数法案。正如我们之前提到的，
Moses doesn't even call Roosevelt by his title, just calls him Frank, which I have to imagine most people, at least they call him by his first name, call him Franklin, at least. Like the only worst thing would be if he called him like Frankie, which would be very funny. And he does things without telling Roosevelt, he won't take Roosevelt's patronage suggestions,
摩西甚至不用头衔称呼罗斯福，只叫他“弗兰克”（Frank）。我猜大多数人至少会叫他的全名，或者至少叫他“富兰克林”（Franklin）。唯一更离谱的可能是叫他“弗兰基”（Frankie），那就太搞笑了。而且他做事不通知罗斯福，不接受罗斯福的政治庇护人选推荐，
which is big, because Moses now controls 1500 jobs, at least. And Roosevelt has this dream of turning this old army base in the Bronx into a merchant Marine Academy, which is the kind of stuff he loved. And Moses blocks that really for no reason, just to annoy him. Literally until Roosevelt is leaving to become president on the third to last day of his governorship, he knows he's been elected president. He quietly is
这可不得了，因为摩西现在至少掌控着1500个职位。罗斯福曾梦想把布朗克斯区的这个旧陆军基地变成一所商船学院（Merchant Marine Academy），这是他最喜欢的那类项目。而摩西却无缘无故地将其阻挠了，纯粹是为了惹恼他。直到罗斯福在卸任州长的倒数第三天准备离职去当总统时——当时他已经知道自己当选了总统——他才悄悄地
like, and I signed this law giving this space over to become a merchant marine academy and doesn't tell anybody. And it just seems like Moses is kneeling in for no reason, but he's also able to do this because he understands the mechanics of the state government better than anybody else. He literally wrote the law. And later on in the book, you'll have young people will say to Moses,
表示：“我签署了这项法案，把这个地方划为商船学院”，并且不告诉任何人。摩西这纯粹是在无理取闹，但他之所以能这么做，是因为他比任何人都更懂州政府的运作机制。这法律简直就是他自己起草的。后来在这本书里，你会看到年轻人对摩西说，
oh, well, the law says this thing. And he'll go, yeah, I know, I wrote that law. Like it came out of his head. And that means that he is someone who occasionally Roosevelt can rely on. So in 1929, Roosevelt has his first budget. It's the first state budget drawn up under the Moses budget system. And the legislature is like, we're attaching a rider to this that gives us equal power
哦，法律规定是这样的。而他会回答说：“哦，我知道，那条法律是我写的。”就像那是从他脑子里蹦出来的一样。这意味着他偶尔还是罗斯福可以依赖的人。因此在1929年，罗斯福迎来了他的第一份预算案。这是第一份按照摩西的预算系统制定的州预算案。而立法机关却说：我们要在这上面附加一个修正案，让我们拥有与州长平等的权力
to the governor in allocating government spending. And Roosevelt's like, what do I do about this? And Moses says, just let the courts veto the bill. We'll find other ways to pay for the government. There's always money to be found hidden in place of the government. And the courts will say it's unconstitutional. And that's exactly what happens. Moses is like this kind of frenemy, consulieri, that he can rely on to understand things,
来分配政府开支。罗斯福问：我该怎么处理这事？摩西说：让法院否决这个法案就行了。我们总能找到其他办法来维持政府运转。政府里总能找到藏钱的地方。法院会宣布这是违宪的。结果果真如此。摩西就像是一个亦敌亦友的幕僚长，罗斯福可以依靠他来理解这些事情，
even though I'm sure Roosevelt was mad, even though it helped him, that he was mad that Moses was right. I guarantee it. Yeah, and he really did reform the government to such an extent that he does know the ins and outs of this and, you know, Carrow presents him as being extremely sanguine when everything goes to court because he feels like his writing of these laws is so ironclad that no one would rule against him
尽管我敢肯定罗斯福会很生气——虽然这帮到了他，但他对摩西总是对的这一点感到恼火。我向来如此确信。是的，他确实把政府改革到了这种程度，以至于他对其中的门道了如指掌。你知道的，卡罗把他描绘成这样一个人：当事情闹上法庭时，他表现得极其泰然自若，因为他觉得他起草的这些法律是如此无懈可击，以至于没有人会对他做出不利的裁决。
and he's right. But you're playing a board game against the Parker brothers, and they're like, yeah, we think we're gonna win this one. But the real thing, the real reason why Moses accumulates power is because he gets things done. And this is a time period in which all these things that Moses has been working for are opening up and he's getting more and more attention.
而他确实猜对了。但这就像你在和帕克兄弟（Parker brothers）玩棋盘游戏，而他们说：“行吧，我们觉得这一局我们赢定了。”但真正的原因，摩西之所以能积累权力，是因为他能把事情办成。这是一个黄金时期，摩西为之奋斗的所有这些项目都在陆续开放，他也因此获得了越来越多的关注。
He's getting more and more acclaim and he's just getting more and more power. Yes. Roman, like you mentioned earlier, he is making nipples happen. He is noticeably improving people's lives in ways that are now finally coming to fruition. And so like, for instance, the Wanta causeway opens. Now New Yorkers can drive all the way to Jones Beach on the first day 25,000 cars drive across it in the first month 325,000 people are going to Jones Beach State Park and now that it's accessible to people from the outlying areas
他获得了越来越多的赞誉，权力也随之越来越大。是的。罗曼，正如你刚才提到的，他正在把“快乐”变成现实。他以一种现在终于得以实现的方式，明显地改善了人们的生活。所以，举个例子，旺塔高速公路（Wantagh Causeway）开通了。现在纽约人可以一路开车直奔琼斯海滩（Jones Beach），开通第一天就有25,000辆车驶过；第一个月就有325,000人前往琼斯海滩州立公园。既然它对偏远地区的居民来说也变得触手可及了，
They can see just how amazing it is and reporters from New York and come and see how beautiful it looks and all the little design details and things that that make it like a little swimming fantasy land and have little it like Moses, he's always big on little touches that are kind of whimsical and a lot of like stuff like ship themed water fountains and you know, and everyone who works there is wearing like kind of sailor type outfits. It sounds a little cheesy to me, but I have to imagine 1929, this kind of like whimsical recreation land for ordinary people was mind blowing. Totally.
他们就能亲眼看到它是多么的妙不可言；来自纽约的记者们也纷至沓来，亲眼目睹它的美丽景致，以及所有那些精致的设计细节——正是这些细节让它看起来像一个微型的游泳梦幻乐园。而且摩西总是热衷于那些异想天开的小细节，比如许多带有轮船主题的喷泉，你知道的，那里每个工作人员都穿着某种水手风格的制服。这在我听来可能有点俗气，但我不得不想象，在1929年，这种为普通人打造的奇幻休闲乐园绝对是颠覆三观的。完全如此。
This, and later on we talk about the Central Park Zoo. It's like little, he's like making little like proto Disneyland's that just like feel like you're walking in a different world. I mean, you have to imagine that most of these people's lives were like bereft of delight, you know? Oh, that's such a sad phrase. Yeah, I think you're right.
这个，还有我们后来谈到的中央公园动物园。这就好像，他在打造一个个迷你的原型迪士尼乐园，让你感觉仿佛走进了另一个世界。我的意思是，你得想象一下，当时绝大多数人的生活是多么缺乏快乐，你知道的？噢，这是一个多么让人心酸的短语。是的，我想你是对的。
Oh. And when you see all this stuff and all this attention and all these cute touches, you know, and like, you know, Carol liberally uses the word gay to talk about, you know, happy and light and free. And it is this word that actually like, you know, obviously has, you know, changed so much of our time and how we use it, but it's perfect for describing this feeling
哦。当你看到所有这些东西、所有的关注以及所有这些可爱的细节时，你知道的，就像卡罗经常使用“gay”（欢乐）这个词来形容那种快乐、轻盈和自由一样。这个词实际上，你知道的，显然在我们的时代以及我们的用法上发生了巨大的变化，但它用来描述那种
that is about happiness and lightness and goodness and whimsy that must have just felt like, you know, Dorothy walking into Oz for the first time. That's such a fantastic parallel for it. Like these people coming from the gray world of the city, these are middle or lower class people, mostly middle class people because they have cars, but maybe they brought their lower class friends
关于幸福、轻盈、美好和奇思妙想的感觉是再贴切不过了。那感觉一定就像——你知道的——桃乐丝第一次走进奥兹国一样。这真是一个绝妙的类比！就像这些人从城市的灰色世界中走出来，他们是中产阶级或下层阶级，主要是中产阶级，因为他们有车，但也可能把他们下层阶级的朋友
with them in the back seat of the car. They're able to enter a world where they can forget about the rest of their lives for a day and just enjoy it. And that's such a new experience to people, I have to imagine. And the other thing that everyone is amazed about with Jones Beach, the same as all adults are amazed about with the Disney parks, is how clean it is. It's amazingly clean. And you're coming from a city that still has like horse dung all over the
带在汽车后座上。他们得以进入这样一个世界：在这里，他们可以把余下的生活抛诸脑后一整天，尽情享受。我不得不设想，对人们来说这是一种全新的体验。而关于琼斯海滩，每个人都感到惊叹的另一件事——正如所有成年人对迪士尼乐园的惊叹一样——是它有多么干净。它干净得令人惊叹。而你来自于一个许多街道上仍然到处都是
streets in lots of places. And they make a point that the attendants who are sailor suits, if there's a piece of litter, they don't have sticks to pick it up with. They have to stoop down and pick it up with their hands. So everyone sees that someone dropped a piece of litter and it is especially embarrassing for the litter bug because they know that someone had to put effort into cleaning it up. And Carras says that if a bag of garbage is found on the side of a Moses Parkway, the troopers who work the parkway will open up the bag and try to identify the owner from the contents and they'll go to their home and issue them the summons and they'll bring newspaper reporters with them so that there'll be a story in the paper like,
马粪的城市。他们特别指出，那些穿着水手服的服务人员，如果看到地上有一片废纸屑，他们不会用棍子去挑起来，而是必须弯下腰用手去捡。所以每个人都能看到有人随地扔了垃圾，这对扔垃圾的人来说尤其尴尬，因为他们知道别人必须付出努力去清理它。卡罗说，如果在摩西修建的公园大道旁发现了一袋垃圾，负责该公园大道的巡警会打开袋子，试图从里面的物品中识别出所有者的身份，然后他们会直接去那人的家里向其开出传票，并且还会带上报纸记者，这样报纸上就会登出这样的新闻：
litterbug caught, you know, this litterbug from Manhattan was caught because they analyzed his trash. I'm 100% on most of this side about this. This is the one crime. I believe like firmly in the decriminalization of most things, but littering, I want to have stiffer penalties and fines and shame.
“乱扔垃圾者被抓获”，你知道的，“这个来自曼哈顿的乱扔垃圾者因为垃圾被分析而被抓获了。”对于这一块，我百分之百站在摩西这边。这是唯一的罪行。我对大多数事情都坚信非罪化，但乱扔垃圾，我希望有更严厉的惩罚、罚款和羞辱。
Yeah, you're a hardcore litter bug death penalty advocate. Exactly. And as a result, you know, by 1932, the attendance is in the millions of people, the facilities have to be expanded. It's a huge success. And that all reflects on who's in charge at the time, the governor. It reflects on Moses, but also on Governor Roosevelt. And Moses' projects have this kind of snowball effect where once people see how successful
是的，你是个铁杆的乱扔垃圾死刑拥护者。完全正确。因此，你知道的，到1932年，游客人数达到了数百万，设施不得不扩建。这是一个巨大的成功。而这一切都反映在当时的主政者身上，也就是州长。这既反映了摩西的功劳，也反映了罗斯福州长的功劳。摩西的项目有一种滚雪球效应，一旦人们看到其中一个项目是如此成功
and how beloved one is, they wanna build more. So he opens this two mile long ocean parkway in 1930, and it goes from Jones Beach in the direction of Fire Island. And he's like, actually, I wanna build 98 more miles of parkway all the way from Rockaway to Montauk Point. And these local communities that used to stand in his way,
且如此受人喜爱，他们就想建造更多。于是在1930年，他开通了一条长达两英里的海洋公园大道（Ocean Parkway），从琼斯海滩一直延伸到火岛（Fire Island）方向。他说：“事实上，我还想再修建98英里的公园大道，一路从罗卡韦（Rockaway）延伸到蒙托克角（Montauk Point）。”而那些曾经挡在他路上的当地社区，
they're like, yeah, yeah, this is gonna bring money to us. And he says to the legislature, I've got millions of dollars worth of land that's just been given to the state so I can build this road. Are you gonna let it go to waste? He's still, he's using his whipsawing and his, what's the other one, steak driving methods.
现在却纷纷表态：行啊行啊，这能给我们带来财富。他向立法机关说道：“我有价值数百万美元的土地刚刚无偿捐赠给了州里，好让我修建这条路。你们难道要让它白白浪费吗？”他依然在运用他的极限施压法，还有，那个叫什么来着——划地占位法。
And in 1931, the legislature, they appropriates the money to extend the route. And it doesn't make it all the way through Fire Island, according to Caro, because there's two old lady sisters live there who will not sell their land. They just refuse to. And Moses is like, I'll deal with them later. I'll get around to that.
到了1931年，立法机关拨款延长了这条路线。根据卡罗的说法，这条路并没有一直修到火岛，因为那里住着两个老太太姐妹，死活不肯出让她们的土地。她们就是拒绝。而摩西则说：“我以后再跟她们算账。我迟早会搞定这事的。”
And luckily for everybody, he never does. So I guess we have those two old ladies to thank for Fire Island not having a highway running straight through it, for it still being a place where you can go and it feels like you're not in the New York area anymore. And it's funny that Carol told us in his interview, he was talking to Moses and Moses was pointing out to Fire Island being like,
所幸对所有人而言，他最终没有这么做。所以我想我们要感谢那两个老太太，才使得火岛没有被一条高速公路拦腰穿过，才使它依然是一个你可以去的地方——在那里你感觉自己好像不再身处纽约地区了。有趣的是，卡罗在采访中告诉我们，他当时正和摩西交谈，摩西指着火岛的方向说：
shouldn't there be a parkway out there? Like, shouldn't there? Like he was still was like, I'm insured in his head. He's like, those two old biddies, you know, they stopped me from my dream. And everyone loves Moses' work. He takes a big advantage of that. His projects are an enormous part of the budget.
“难道那边不应该有一条公园大道吗？难道不应该吗？”就像他依然觉得——在他的脑海里，他还在想：“那两个老太婆，你知道的，她们阻挡了我的梦想。”每个人都喜爱摩西的作品，他充分利用了这一点。他的项目是预算中的巨额开支。
There's 70%, more than 70% of the state's metropolitan construction budget. And when, uh, Roosevelt wants to cut the budget, because when he runs for president, he doesn't want to be seen as a spendthrift Moses. He threatens to resign. It becomes his go-to move. And this time it works. But Roman, tell us again, it didn't work when he was a Yale swimmer. Why does it work now? He's got the power.
占了州大都市建设预算的70%，超过了70%。当罗斯福想要削减预算时——因为他竞选总统时不想被看作是一个挥霍无度的人——摩西便威胁要辞职。这成了他的绝招。而这一次，它奏效了。但是罗曼，你再告诉我们一次，当他还是耶鲁游泳运动员时，这招可没用啊。为什么现在管用了？因为他手里有权力。
He's got the power and therefore he cannot be allowed to resign. And this is like the first moment where there's like this move that he goes over and over again, even to the point where like, you know, like, you know, people like LaGuardia kind of laughing them through the process. You know what I mean? And it really works and it works big. And it really matters here because like half a chapter ago, Roosevelt was ready to fire him.
他手握权力，因此绝不能被允许辞职。这也是他第一次使出这一招，并屡试不爽，甚至到了后来——你知道的——像拉瓜迪亚（LaGuardia）这样的人甚至有点笑着看他把这套流程走完。你知道我的意思吗？这招确实管用，而且是大获成功。在这里这非常关键，因为就在半章之前，罗斯福还准备炒他鱿鱼。
Roosevelt was ready to get him out by any means necessary to, to endure whatever pain it was to get rid of them. But now he pulls the resignation move and it totally works. And he's going to use it for the next 50 years. And it's going to work every time until the one time it doesn't work, which was in which case it really doesn't work. But we'll get to that much later in the book. And Moses, he knows his, his playbook now he's going to ask the legislature
罗斯福已经准备好不惜一切代价把他赶走，哪怕要承受再大的痛苦也要甩掉他。但现在，他祭出了辞职这招，结果完全奏效了。而且在接下来的50年里，他将一直使用这招，并且每次都能成功，直到最后那唯一一次失灵——那一次确实没管用。但我们会在这本书的后面详细讲到。而摩西，他现在对自己的这一套剧本门儿清：他会向立法机关
for a big amount of money. He's going to build something part of the way he's going to say, I actually need more money. And they're going to say no. And he's going to say, are you going to let all that go to waste? You're going to tell the voters that you wasted all this money? And he almost always gets what he wants. And by 1930, the Long Island State Parks, according to Caro, they're seeing 3 million visitors a year at a time when the attendance
索要巨额资金，先修好一部分项目，然后说：“实际上我还需要更多的钱。”对方会说不。接着他就会说：“你们打算让之前投进去的钱全部打水漂吗？你们要告诉选民你们浪费了这么多钱吗？”而他几乎每次都能如愿以偿。到1930年，据卡罗统计，长岛州立公园
at all national parks combined is 3.4 million. Like it's hugely popular. And he always includes Roosevelt in the big opening ceremonies and other politicians that he needs. That way they get the media attention and they get the public credit. And Moses starts to say to people,
每年接待的游客达到300万人次，而在当时，全美所有国家公园的游客总数加起来也才340万人次。可见它是多么的受欢迎。而且他总是在盛大的开幕典礼上把罗斯福以及他需要的其他政客带上。这样一来，他们就能获得媒体的关注和公众的赞誉。摩西开始对人们说：
you can get an awful lot of good done in the world if you're willing to let someone else take the credit for it. Which is very funny considering he is also getting a massive amount of credit for every myth. It's not like he's the man in the shadows that nobody knows about. He's still getting credit. but politicians, they need, especially if they're running for reelection, they need that record of achievements.
“如果你愿意让别人揽功，你就能在世界上成就一番惊天动地的好事。”考虑到他自己也从每一个项目中获得了海量的名誉，这话听起来就很搞笑。他又不是那种默默无闻、无人知晓的幕后英雄。他依然在收获赞誉。但政客们需要，特别是如果他们在竞选连任的话，他们需要耀眼的政绩。
And that means very early on in their terms, the projects have to start because they've got to be done in time for election day. They've got to be able to point to it and say, look at that road, look at that beach. They can't point to a plan. They can point to a thing. And a governor, unfortunately, can't, I mean, not unfortunately, for those projects, a governor can't unfortunately just steamroll over people and break the guardrails of democracy. Democracy's whole point is it
这意味着在他们的任期之初，项目就必须开工，因为它们必须在选举日之前完工。他们必须能够指着这些项目说：看那条路，看那个海滩。他们不能指着一张蓝图说事，他们必须拿出实物。而作为州长，不幸的是——哦不，对于这些项目来说倒也不是不幸——州长不能随心所欲地推平一切、践踏民主的护栏。民主的全部意义就在于
slows action down so that you don't run roughshod over people. But because Moses is an appointed official, he doesn't need to be reelected, he can throw his weight around, be a jerk to people, he can be mean to voters. It doesn, he can throw his weight around, be a jerk to people, he can be mean to voters, it doesn't matter. And everyone, if they get mad, they'll get mad at him and not the governor. But then when the project is done, the governor can be like,
放慢行动的步伐，这样你就不会对人民为所欲为。但由于摩西是一名任命官员，他不需要竞选连任，他可以作威作福、对人颐指气使、对选民恶言相向。这都没关系。如果大家愤怒，愤怒也会冲着他去，而不会冲着州长。但等到项目完工后，州长就可以站出来说：
look at this great road I built. Look at this, look at this beach I built. This is an amazing thing because, you know, these terms, they might seem interminable to us when we have to endure a politician we despise, but they are very short in terms of getting things done. And Robert Moses, not only does he have all these qualities to get things done, he might be the only person in history
“看我修了这么棒的一条路！看呐，看我建了这么棒的一个海滩！”这是一件了不起的事，因为你知道的，对于我们这些不得不忍受一个我们痛恨的政客的人来说，这些任期可能显得漫长得看不到尽头，但就办成事情而言，它们其实非常短暂。而罗罗伯特·摩西不仅具备所有把事情办成的特质，他甚至可能是历史上唯一一个
that can put a road in inside of two years. You know, like, I mean, it's really stunning how different as a sort of weapon of accomplishment that Robert Moses is compared to most people. Recently in Los Angeles, we had a problem where a major freeway, there was a fire under it and it fell apart and it was closed for a little bit and people thought it was going to be closed forever, for a long, long time. And they finished rebuilding it in a relatively short amount of time within a matter of weeks
能在两年之内修好一条道路的人。你知道的，我的意思是，作为一种成就武器，罗伯特·摩西与大多数人相比是多么与众不同，这真令人震惊。最近在洛杉矶，我们遇到过这样一个问题：一条主要高速公路上方发生了火灾，导致路面坍塌损毁，道路随之关闭了一段时间，人们以为它会关到地老天荒、永远也修不好了。结果他们竟然在相对极短的几周时间内完成了重建工作，
and everyone was so amazed. You would have thought a magic trick had taken place in Los Angeles. People couldn't stop talking about it for a long time. Can you believe they, it's up already. You can drive on it again. Can you believe it? Because this stuff is so difficult.
所有人都惊呆了。你简直会以为洛杉矶上演了什么魔术。人们好长一段时间都在津津乐道这件事：“真不敢相信他们这么快就建好了！你又能开车上去了！真敢相信吗？”因为这些事情实在是太难了。
It's so hard to push it through. And Robert Moses consistently doing it. I mean, if I had built Jones Beach, I would have been like, that's my monument. I did it. Like that was a lot of effort. Now I'm gonna rest on my laurels a little bit, but he just keeps doing these things. And as a result, he can get away with a lot that other people don't. And Carol talks about how Moses
要强行推进这些项目是如此之难。而罗伯特·摩西却能不断地把它们办成。我的意思是，如果是我修建了琼斯海滩，我就会觉得：“这就是我的丰碑！我做到了！”那可是付出了巨大的努力。现在我得躺在功劳簿上稍微歇息一会儿了，但他却一直在做这些项目。正因如此，他可以逃脱许多别人无法逃脱的惩罚。卡罗谈到了摩西
gets away with actually strangling, not to death, but strangling another member of the parks council during a meeting that the, to be fair, the council member refers to Moses by an anti-Semitic slur. And Moses gets so mad that he starts strangling him. And when he's pulled off of this guy, he picks up a three foot like ashtray stand and hurls it at him. And luckily only misses him because another guy like hit his arm to stop it.
居然在一次会议上掐了公园委员会的另一名成员——虽然严格来说，并非致死，但确实是掐脖子——起因是这位委员会成员用一个反犹太的侮辱词汇称呼了摩西。摩西气得开始掐他。当人们把他从那家伙身上拉开时，他顺手抄起一个三英尺高的烟灰缸支架朝对方狠狠砸去。幸运的是，由于另一个人伸手挡了一下他的胳膊，才算打偏了，
So it wouldn't hit this guy. But he gets so mad and the council members goes to Roosevelt and is like, are you gonna do something about this guy who strangled me? And Roosevelt's like, no, I don't think I'm going to. And the council member resigns. He is so politically important that he can get away with this kind of thing, which to most people would probably lose that job if they strangled a coworker, let's say. That's true. Maybe it's because this is a view of the kind of more negative aspect of Moses, that this is when Kara starts to transition into Moses' efforts to dissuade black people,
没有砸中那个人。但他气成这样，而那位委员会成员跑去找罗斯福告状：“你不管管这个掐我脖子的家伙吗？”罗斯福却说：“不，我想我不会管的。”于是那位委员会成员愤而辞职。他在政治上是如此重要，以至于他可以逃脱这种行径。换作普通人，如果掐了同事的脖子，大概早就丢了饭碗了，可以说是这样的。确实如此。也许是因为这是从更负面的角度来审视摩西，正是在这里，卡罗开始过渡到摩西试图阻止黑人——
especially poor people in general, but black people, especially from using these parks and facilities. And he quotes Francis Perkins, who has known Moses for years and years, saying that Moses saw the public as dirty. And Caro talks about how Moses kept the Long Island Railroad from going to Jones Beach. And he makes the claim that has become surprisingly controversial in recent years, that Moses was deliberately keeping the overpasses on his parkways too low for buses to pass under. And there's been a lively debate over the past few years about whether this was standard parkway practice or not. One of Moses' top lieutenants told Caro that this was a deliberate move, but it's hard to know the truth about that.
尤其是广大穷人，但特别是黑人——使用这些公园和设施的努力。他引用了认识摩西多年的弗朗西斯·珀金斯（Francis Perkins）的话，称摩西视公众为肮脏之物。卡罗讲述了摩西如何阻止长岛铁路通往琼斯海滩，并提出了一个近年来越来越具争议的观点：摩西故意把他的公园大道上的立交桥建得太低，以至于公共汽车无法从下方通行。在过去几年里，关于这究竟是当时公园大道的标准做法还是另有隐情，曾有过热烈的辩论。摩西的一位高级亲信曾对卡罗坦言这是一个刻意的举动，但其中的真相很难考证。
Although every time I've seen it fact-checked, the fact-checker is always like, I guess Caro is technically correct since Moses' lieutenant told him this while Moses did it. But it's become a surprise and controversy recently. Yeah. I mean, I think there was some bus service to Jones Beach. It wasn't widespread. There was from the very beginning. Clearly, it was never meant to expand.
尽管每当我看到相关的事实核查时，核查人员总会说：我猜卡罗在技术上是正确的，因为摩西的亲信确实这么告诉了他，而摩西也确实是这么干的。但这一直是近年来的一个突发争议点。是的。我的意思是，据我所知，通往琼斯海滩的公交服务其实是有的。只不过规模不大。从一开始就有的。显然，它从没打算扩大规模。
It was meant to be very small. And there were lots of other things about how Jones Beach was run that comports to this idea of not complete exclusion, but enough discomfort, enough shame, enough, you just like making people feel uncomfortable that he was designing Jones Beach for a certain type of people and poor people and especially black people were not among them.
它的设计规模就是非常小的。关于琼斯海滩的运营，还有许多其他事情都印证了这种想法：虽然不是完全排斥，但要制造足够的难堪、足够的羞辱，让你感到不适——他就是在按照为某种特定人群设计的方式来建造琼斯海滩，而穷人、尤其是黑人并不在其中。
Yes, they hired a couple of black lifeguards and would post them at the farthest reaches of the beach, farthest from the bathhouses, to kind of give it a little subtle pressure that that's the place where black bathers should go. He would keep the water in the Jones Beach pool cold, under the impression that black people hate cold water, so they won't go into the pool if it's too cold, which is... I remember reading this book years ago, and it was the first time I had ever come across that stereotype. And I was like, really? Like Like what was he basing that on? Like I don't
是的，他们雇佣了几个黑人救生员，并把他们派驻到海滩最边缘的角落，离浴室最远的地方，以此给他们施加一种微妙的压力，让他们觉得那是黑人浴客该去的地方。他会把琼斯海滩泳池里的水调得冰凉，因为他脑子里有一种成见，觉得黑人讨厌冷水，所以如果水太冷他们就不会下水，这简直……我多年前读这本书时，第一次遇到这种刻板印象。当时我就想：真的假的？他这是基于什么得出这种结论的？我简直
but black civic groups noticed this and they complained to Roosevelt and he has an investigation. It finds that Moses is discouraging black people from using the parks and Roosevelt brings up to Moses and Moses goes, no, I'm not doing that. And Roosevelt never brings it up again because I think he just, he needed to be seen to go through the motions, but Moses is too valuable to him. It's too valuable to the state in his mind to get him into trouble for this. And even when Moses, he wants to raise the price of parking at the parks to 50 cents, which is a lot of money in the thirties. That's a huge amount of money to raise it.
但黑人公民团体注意到了这一点，他们向罗斯福进行了投诉，于是罗斯福下令展开调查。调查发现摩西确实在阻挠黑人使用这些公园。罗斯福把这事提出来质问摩西，而摩西矢口否认：“不，我没这么干。”于是罗斯福就再也没有提过这茬，因为我想他只是需要做做样子以应付公众，但在他心目中，摩西对他的价值太高了、对整个州的价值太高了，他不可能因为这事去为难摩西。甚至当摩西
It leads to a backlash and Roosevelt wants him to lower the price. He threatens to resign. Roosevelt goes, Oh, nevermind then. And even Roosevelt even vetoes a bill banning fees in state parks, uh, because 1932 is coming. Roosevelt's running for president. He can't afford a public spat with his incredibly popular guy. Yeah. And the chapter ends with everyone knows Roosevelt's running for the democratic nomination for president.
想要把公园的停车费提高到50美分时——在30年代这可是一大笔钱，涨幅极其惊人——
He's got a very good shot because it's the depression and people want to change. Al Smith, he decides he's going to run against Roosevelt basically out of spite. And Moses, he takes a leave of absence to help his old boss try to defeat his current boss, which is a real, that's a real jerk of a move to do. And Moses does this knowing Al Smith does not have a chance. There's no way he's going to get this nomination. And Moses in a show of loyalty and spite of Roosevelt,
这引发了强烈的民意反弹，罗斯福希望他能降价。摩西则威胁要辞职。罗斯福见状便说：“哦，那就算了吧。”甚至罗斯福还否决了一项禁止在州立公园收取费用的法案，因为1932年大选即将来临，罗斯福正在竞选总统，他承担不起与这位极受欢迎的人当众公开闹翻的代价。是的。本章以所有人都知道罗斯福正在竞选民主党总统提名而告终。
those things dovetail beautifully here. He kind of stands by Smith through the moment when Smith knows he has lost. He doesn't abandon him before then, which is a rare moment of maybe, I don't know if it's compassion or comfort from Moses. He really does feel this relationship with Al Smith that will sit with him for the rest of his life.
他的胜算非常大，因为正值经济大萧条时期，人们渴望改变。而阿尔·史密斯却决定参加竞选，与罗斯福打擂台，基本上纯粹是出于怨恨。摩西则请了假去帮他的老老板试图击败他现任的老老板，这绝对是一个极其混蛋的做法。摩西这么做时，心里很清楚阿尔·史密斯根本没有半点胜算。他绝无可能获得这个提名。而摩西出于对阿尔·史密斯的忠诚以及对罗斯福的怨恨——
And if it means that he gets to try to unseat this guy he hates, his current boss, then he'll do that too. Yeah, yeah. It is really interesting to watch how pure his affection for Elf Smith is. And this comes up, but we'll get there, but one of my favorite sections of the whole book.
这两种情绪在这里完美地交织在了一起——他一直在史密斯身旁，直到史密斯明知自己已经落败的最后一刻。他在此之前并没有抛弃史密斯，这体现了摩西罕见的——我不知道这算不算同情或安慰。他对阿尔·史密斯确实有着一种将伴随他余生的深厚感情。
And despite his general political savvy and political calculations, although as you mentioned before, he has kind of a blind spot for like electoral politics, he has different bureaucratic politics like superpowers, but electoral politics he doesn't have, he seems to just not be able to sort of crack that code. But he really does want to stand with him and he sort of stays with him in all night,
如果这意味着他可以借此机会去试图拉下他痛恨的这个家伙——他现任的老老板——那么他也会这么干。是的，是的。看着他对阿尔·史密斯的喜爱是如此纯粹，真的非常有趣。这一点后面还会提到——我们随后就会讲到，这是整本书里我最喜欢的章节之一。
you know, with the Democratic nomination until he realizes that it is not going to happen and a bunch of people break for Roosevelt and they, you know, secretly leave the convention, you know, by a side door. And he always wants to maintain the dignity of Al Smith. That's very clear. Yes, I think that's a great way to put it, that he always wants Al Smith to be seen the way he sees Al Smith as this just true heroic figure that is deserving of love, deserving of not just respect, but love.
尽管他有着出色的政治敏感度和政治算计——尽管正如你之前提到的，他在选举政治方面确实有一点盲区，他在官僚政治方面拥有超能力，但在选举政治上却不然，他似乎就是无法破解这个密码——但他确实真心想要支持史密斯。在民主党代表大会上，他一直陪着史密斯熬夜通宵，
And there's something very beautiful about that. And it's, you almost wish you could say to Robert Moses, imagine everybody in these buildings that you're evicting to build your expressway was Al Smith. Like, would that change the way you feel about this? And I don't know, maybe it would, but maybe it wouldn't. Al Smith seems to be his one true love, which is very sweet.
直到他意识到大势已去，许多人纷纷倒向罗斯福，他们（指史密斯阵营）从侧门偷偷离开了大会现场。他始终想要维护阿尔·史密斯的尊严。这一点非常明显。是的，我想这是一种极好的说法：他总是希望别人眼中的阿尔·史密斯正如他自己所看到的那样——一个真正英雄般的人物，一个值得去爱、不仅值得尊重更值得去爱的人。
That's right. And while we're piling on all these horrible things that Robert Moses does, except for his devotion to Al Smith, Robert Caro changes gears again in the next chapter that we will get to after this. So the next chapter is chapter 18, New York City before Robert Moses. It's a little bit of a misnomer.
这其中有一种非常美妙的东西。你会忍不住想对罗伯特·摩西说：想象一下，你为了修建高速公路而驱逐的这些大楼里的每一个人都是阿尔·史密斯。这会改变你对这件事的看法吗？我不知道，也许会，也许不会。阿尔·史密斯似乎是他此生唯一的真爱，这非常温馨。
There's like only a little bit of before for Moses and then there's a lot of after Robert Moses in this chapter. Yeah, that's very true. But I think the point here is there is so much bad going on in the world, there's so much bad in comes to parks and to politics and to graft and everything that the environment that Robert Moses steps in
没错。正当我们历数罗伯特·摩西所做的种种恶行时——除了他对阿尔·史密斯的忠诚之外——罗伯特·卡罗在下一章中又调转了方向，我们将在之后进入这一章。所以下一章是第18章：《罗伯特·摩西之前的纽约》。这个名字多少有点名不副实，
and reforms is really in need of reform. You know? And there's a reason why he accumulates this power and goodwill. I think you're exactly right that this chapter is Robert Caro switching gears so that we can't just be like Robert Moses, boo, Rat Fink, boo, but instead to show us why there was a need
因为这一章里关于“摩西之前”的内容只占了一小部分，而剩下的大部分都是关于“罗伯特·摩西之后”的。是的，确实如此。但我认为这里的重点在于：当时世界上存在着如此之多的恶疾——在公园、政治、贪腐以及方方面面都充斥着种种弊端，以至于罗伯特·摩西踏入并加以改革的那个环境，
in some ways for someone like him and that allowed him to do these things. So it's 1932, it's the Great Depression, it's hit the country, New York has hit particularly hard. This chapter is so full of, I feel bad that I get such pleasure out of it, this kind of terrifying urban apocalypse, like everything's falling apart writing. And there's some of this right here where it says, New York in 1932 was half completed skyscrapers, work on them long since halted for the lack of funds that glared down on the city from glassless windows. It was housewives scavenging for vegetables under push carts. It was crowds gathering at garbage dumps in Riverside Park and swarming onto them every time a new load was deposited,
确实亟需一场大刀阔斧的改革。你知道吗？他之所以能积累起如此庞大的权力和民意声望，是有其原因的。我认为你完全说对了，这一章是罗伯特·卡罗在转换叙事齿轮，好让我们不至于单纯地觉得“罗伯特·摩西是个坏蛋、是个卑鄙小人、该遭唾弃”，而是向我们展示为什么在某种程度上确实需要这样一个人，并正是这种需求成就了他的所作所为。时间来到了1932年，大萧条席卷了全国，纽约受到的冲击尤为沉重。这一章充满了——每当我从中获得某种阅读快感时我都觉得挺内疚的——这种令人毛骨悚然的城市末日般的描写，就像一切都在分崩离析的笔触。这里就有这样一段描写：1932年的纽约，到处都是半拉子工程的摩天大楼，由于资金匮乏，施工早已停滞，它们用空洞洞的窗户冷冷地俯视着这座城市。那是家庭主妇们在手推车下搜寻残菜剩饭的场景；是人们在河滨公园的垃圾堆里聚集的场景：每当有新的垃圾车倾倒垃圾，他们就会蜂拥而上，
digging through the piles with sticks or hands in hopes of finding bits of food. New York was the soup kitchens operated from the back of Army trucks in Times Square. It was the men, some of them wearing Chesterfield coats and Homburgs, who lined up at the soup kitchens with drooping shoulders and eyes that never looked up from the sidewalk. And he goes on and on about New York at this time as people being evicted. It's people living on the streets. More than a third of the manufacturing firms in the city have shut down. Nearly a third of the employable people in New York are out of work. There's 1.6 million people on welfare, kids going without proper food. And what makes the problem even worse is that the
用棍子或双手在垃圾堆里翻找，希望能找到一点残羹冷炙。纽约是设在时代广场陆军卡车车厢后面的救济厨房；是那些穿着切斯特菲尔德大衣和洪堡帽的男人们，排着队在救济厨房领救济粮，双肩下垂，目光死死盯着人行道，从不抬起头来。他滔滔不绝地描绘着当时的纽约：人们被扫地出门，流落街头。全市超过三分之一的制造企业倒闭了，近三分之一的纽约有劳动能力的人失业了，有160万人靠救济金过活，孩子们吃不上饱饭。而让问题雪上加霜的是，
previous couple of mayors, Red Mike Hyland and our old Val James Walker, Bo James Walker, they were so ridiculously corrupt. They were so corrupt. They're just hundreds of thousands of dollars in graft every year. Carol has this detail about how common it was for vice cops to just frame women as prostitutes and tell them that if they aren't paid off, they're going to take them to jail. And this stuff doesn't really become super public. Everyone knows that these guys are slimy, but the extent of it doesn't become public until this former judge, Samuel Seabury, who we'll see more of later in this episode, he investigates and he brings it all to light. He confronts Mayor Walker in court. He's like, look at all these bribes you took. And Mayor Walker is like, um, I
前几任市长，“红脸”迈克·海兰（Red Mike Hyland）和我们的老朋友詹姆士·沃克（Jimmy Walker，又称Bo James Walker），他们简直腐败得荒唐。他们贪腐透顶，每年都有几十万美元的贪墨中饱私囊。卡罗提到这样一个细节：扫黄警察诬陷女性为妓女、并以此勒索钱财否则就把她们抓进监狱的做法是多么司空见惯。这些勾当并没有真正被公之于众。每个人都知道这些家伙烂透了，但其严重程度直到前法官塞缪尔·西布里（Samuel Seabury）——我们在本集后面还会更多地看到他——展开调查并将其全部公之于世时，才为人所知。他在法庭上质问沃克市长：看看你收了这么多贿赂！而沃克市长却说：呃，我
resigned and he flees to Europe with his mistress. And his replacement is not much better. His replacement, Mayor O'Brien, he's another Tammany man. And that will put, they ask him who his police commissioner is going to be. And he goes, I don't know. They haven't told me yet. So he's, he is, he is, for instance, is like one of two incredibly bumbling New York mayors. And there's a lot of statistics on top of this about New York's population is getting bigger, the budget costs are ballooning. And what that means especially is that the city is in debt, it has had to borrow so much money to pay its bills. And now the interest is coming due, the payments are coming due on that debt on those loans, and the tax collections
辞职了。然后他带着情妇逃到了欧洲。他的继任者也没好到哪里去。他的继任者奥布莱恩市长（Mayor O'Brien）又是塔慕尼协会（Tammany Hall）的政客。当别人问他谁将出任警察局长时，他回答：我不知道，他们还没告诉我呢。所以他就是——举个例子——那种极为昏庸无能的纽约市长之一。除此之外，还有大量统计数据表明纽约的人口越来越多，预算开支暴涨。这意味着这座城市陷入了严重的债务危机，为了支付账单它不得不借了巨额债务。现在，利息到期了，这些债务和贷款的本息偿还期限到了，而与此同时税收收入
are falling just as all this money is coming due, they're going to have to loans and the tax collections are falling just as all this money is coming due. They're going to have to pay and the only way to pay it is to borrow more money. So the banks demand more budget cuts, which means cutting funds for infrastructure, cutting services, and the TAMI leaders, they won't fire anyone who's politically connected. So in 1931, they fire 11,000 teachers because the teachers have no power. They can just get rid of them. And 1933 is coming. And in that year, hundreds of millions of dollars in loans are going to be coming due and New York simply cannot pay them. And at the same time, this corruption also means that the people working in the
却在下降。正当这笔巨额资金到期之际，他们不得不偿还，唯一的办法就是借更多的新债。因此，银行要求进一步削减预算，这意味着削减基础设施资金、削减公共服务，而塔慕尼协会的头目们却不肯解雇任何有政治背景的人。所以在1931年，他们解雇了11,000名教师，因为教师没有任何权势，最容易被踢出门。1933年即将来临，在那一年里，数以亿计美元的贷款即将到期，而纽约根本无力偿还。与此同时，这种腐败也意味着在政府中工作的人
government are incredibly incompetent. They, you've got engineers working for the city who don't have high school diplomas, uh, every time you want to build something, there's a series of payoffs that have to be made. So nothing is getting built. And the physical infrastructure of New York is so old and so crumbling. Carol mentions that from 1918 to 1932,
极度无能。你甚至能看到连高中毕业证都没有的工程师在为市政府工作。你想建造任何东西，都必须经历一连串的利益输送和回扣。因此什么都建不成。纽约的物理基础设施是如此陈旧和破败。卡罗提到，从1918年到1932年，
the number of cars in New York City multiplied more than sixfold. And at the same time, they were building no new major roads within the city or not finishing any of them. They haven't built a new route between the boroughs in 25 years. It's traffic jams all the time.
纽约市的汽车数量增长了六倍以上。与此同时，他们却没有在市内新建任何主要道路，也没有完成任何一条在建道路。他们已经25年没有在各行政区之间修建过新的通行路线了。到处都是交通大堵塞。
The only way to get across the Harlem River from Manhattan to the Bronx is a three-lane drawbridge. So traffic gets backed up because so many cars would get across it. And then it might have to stop because a ship has to pass through. This is bonkers. This is the early, this is the 20th century. You know, this is, it's, it's, I mean, it's something about it that's kind of quaint. The Queensboro Bridge is 25 years old.
从曼哈顿跨越哈莱姆河到布朗克斯区的唯一通道是一座三车道开合桥。所以由于过河车辆太多，交通严重拥堵。然后它可能还得停下来让船只通行。这简直荒谬透顶。这是早期——这是20世纪啊。你知道的，这——这多多少少带有一种古怪的色彩。皇后区大桥当时都已经25岁了。
They haven't even painted lanes on it yet. So when you're driving on it, you have to navigate where your car is supposed to go. It's incredibly bonkers that this is so not the image I have of New York City, which is skyscrapers, you know, Broadway, you know, the amazing things about New York, but the physical living in it was falling apart. And I'll give you two examples of how unfinished New York was at the time, that in Riverdale in the Bronx, where my mom spent her first 13 years,
上面甚至还没画车道。所以当你开在上面时，你得自己辨认车子该往哪儿开。这简直太疯狂了，因为这完全不是我心目中纽约市的形象，我心目中那是摩天大楼，你知道的，百老汇，你知道的，纽约令人惊叹的一切，但它物理上的日常生活却在分崩离析。我可以给你举两个例子，说明当时的纽约是多么的未完成：在布朗克斯区的里弗代尔，我妈妈度过了她最初的13年，
they had built a hundred foot high marble column. And in 1909, they're like, we're gonna put a statue of, Carroll calls him Hendrick Hudson the whole time, but I was known as Henry Hudson. We're gonna put a statue of Hendrick Hudson up there and we're gonna build a Hendrick Hudson bridge. By 1932, 23 years later, the column is the only thing there from the original plans.
他们建了一根一百英尺高的白色大理石圆柱。到了1909年，他们觉得：我们要在那上面放一座——卡罗一直把这个人叫亨德里克·哈德逊，但我知道他叫亨利·哈德逊——我们要把亨德里克·哈德逊的雕像放在上面，我们还要建一座亨德里克·哈德逊大桥。到了1932年，也就是23年后，原计划里只剩下了那根柱子。
And the statue's not even there. It's just an empty column. Meanwhile, in Brooklyn and Bay Ridge, they tunneled 96 foot deep holes that are gonna be for a narrows tube to link Brooklyn and Staten Island. And from 1921 to 1923, the city spends $7 million digging it and then they just stop. And they just leave these huge holes. And eventually 1921 to 1923, the city spends $7 million digging it, and then
连雕像都不见踪影。那只是一根空柱子。与此同时，在布鲁克林和贝脊，他们挖了96英尺深的隧道洞，本打算用作连接布鲁克林和斯塔滕岛的纳罗斯海峡海底隧道。从1921年到1923年，市政府花了700万美元挖掘它，然后他们就停工了。他们就留下了这些巨大的洞穴。最终，从1921年到1923年，市政府花了700万美元挖掘它，然后
they just stop and they just leave these huge holes. And eventually they put like a fence around it because kids are falling in them or threatening to fall in them. Like it's, the city's falling apart and like to make it even more Moses centric, the parks are in bad shape. They've rented out city parks to private owners in exchange for kickbacks. The parks are staffed by like the Tammammany job seekers they couldn't put anywhere else. Everything's overgrown. Except for the trees, which are stumps. Every single park structure in the city needs to be repaired. Monuments and statues are crumbling in Bryant Park, which is now a kind of weed-filled vacant lot full of drunks. The statues there, I know there's one of Washington Irving, I can't remember what the other statue
他们就停工了，留下了这些巨大的洞穴。最后他们只能在周围围上栅栏，因为有小孩子掉进去，或者差点掉进去。这就好比，这座城市正在分崩离析，为了让它更契合“摩西”这个核心，公园的状况也糟透了。他们把城市公园租给私人老板以换取回扣。公园里的工作人员都是塔慕尼政客安插的、在别处找不到工作的求职者。到处都杂草丛生。除了那些被砍只剩树桩的树。城里每一个公园的建筑都需要修缮。布莱恩特公园里的纪念碑和雕像正在风化崩塌，如今这里变成了一个长满杂草、醉汉游荡的空地。那里的雕像，我知道有一尊是华盛顿·欧文的，我记不得另一尊雕像
was. They're just lost. Nobody knows where they are. They just lost the statues there, I know there's one of Washington Irving, I can't remember what the other statue was, they're just lost, nobody knows where they are. They just lost the statues. And Carol doesn't mention this, but I did some research, in 1934, they were eventually found under the Williamsburg Bridge. So they did find those statues, they were under a bridge. And corrupt vendors who paid for their license are selling kids unsafe hot dogs that make them sick.
是什么了。它们就这么不见了。没人知道它们在哪儿。他们只是把雕像弄丢了，我知道有一尊是华盛顿·欧文的，我记不得另一尊雕像是谁了，它们就是不见了，没人知道它们在哪儿。他们只是把雕像弄丢了。而卡罗没有提到这一点，但我做了一些研究，在1934年，人们最终在威廉斯堡大桥下面找到了它们。所以他们确实找到了那些雕像，它们在一座桥底下。那些付了许可费的腐败小贩正在向孩子们兜售不卫生的热狗，导致他们生病。
Like it's just, everything's going wrong in the parks. And you can see why the reform movement is particularly centered on parks because of all this stuff. I mean, these are the only places of respite in the entire city, a city that is falling apart. And parks just become the symbol of the reform movement. It's like the physical embodiment
可以说公园里的一切都在出问题。你可以理解为什么改革运动会把焦点集中在公园上，正是因为发生了这么多乱七八糟的事。我的意思是，这些是整个城市中仅有的喘息之地，而这座城市正在四分五裂。公园成了改革运动的象征。它就像是
of everything that they want and it's all falling apart. And Robert Moses ends up being the answer to it. I mean, one of my favorite parts of this is that, you know, Central Park, you know, this jewel, you know, like this thing that's, I think to this day, I think is one of the most amazing parks in the world in terms of its like- And you talk to New Yorkers,
他们渴望的一切的实体化，而这一切都在分崩离析。罗伯特·摩西最终成了这一切的解药。我的意思是，我最喜欢的一点是，中央公园，你知道的，这颗明珠，你知道的，我认为直到今天，它依然是世界上最令人惊叹的公园之一——如果你跟纽约人交流，
there's this general admiration for the foresight of the people who laid out the city, that they kept that space open for a park when they could have easily just filled it in with buildings and it would have been worth so much money. Yeah, to have it there is it's so necessary to life the city. But yeah, Roman, tell us about Central Park in 1932. Well, it's been neglected for decades. All the lawns are turned to dirt, the paths are broken, benches and garbage cans are overturned. And what's amazing to me, most amazing to me at all, is the Central Park Menagerie,
大家普遍都很佩服当年规划这座城市的人的远见，他们在本来可以轻松盖满大楼、卖出天价的地方，留出了这片空地作为公园。是的，能拥有它，对这座城市的生存来说是如此必要。但是，罗曼，跟我们讲讲1932年的中央公园吧。嗯，它已经被忽视了几十年。所有的草坪都变成了泥地，小径破损不堪，长椅和垃圾桶到处翻倒。最让我惊讶的是——对我来说最惊掉下巴的——是中央公园的动物园，
which is what the predecessor to the Central Park Zoo has become so rotted. Guards are given rifles to shoot lions in case they break free. Yeah, they're like, in case of a fire, the lions will probably just break through the cages because they're so weak now. So you have to carry this gun so you can shoot this lion,
也就是中央公园动物园的前身，已经破败不堪。看守人员甚至发了步枪，以防狮子挣脱笼子跑出来。对，他们会说，万一发生火灾，狮子很可能会直接撞破笼子，因为它们现在太虚弱了。所以你必须带着这把枪，这样才能开枪打死这头狮子。
which is, it's just, it's such a, that's an extreme situation for, for a zoo to be in. And even a call it a zoo is not fair because as Carol mentions, it's, it was called a menagerie because people would just leave their pets there. Like if you were tired with the pet, you just donate it to central rock menagerie. And the whole thing is full of rats and, uh, in the sheep meadow, uh, there's this flock of inbred sheep that's become malformed over the years.
这，这简直是一种极端情况，对于一个动物园来说。甚至叫它动物园都有点不公，正如卡罗所提到的，它当时被称为“梅纳日里”（menagerie，珍奇异兽园），因为人们会把宠物直接丢在那里。如果你对宠物厌烦了，就可以把它捐给中央公园动物园。整个地方到处都是老鼠，呃，在绵羊草甸上，有一群近亲繁殖的绵羊，多年来已经长得畸形了。
And it's, and of course it's depression, so there's a Hooverville there. And yeah, it's this amazingly beautiful park has just fallen apart and sports facilities are inadequate. There's only two outdoor swimming pools in the entire city, which is amazing. There's not enough baseball diamonds or things like that.
而且，这当然是在大萧条时期，所以那里还有一个胡佛村（棚户区）。没错，这个曾经美得惊人的公园已经破败不堪，体育设施也严重不足。整个城市只有两个室外游泳池，这太惊人了。棒球场和其他类似设施也远远不够。
And Kara talks about these public restrooms where women who are connected to Tammany would be assigned as the overseers, and they would just turn them into private apartments that they would invite people to and host like gatherings in, and you couldn't use them. They were not available to you. You know, it's just, it's really amazing. And so as Roman, as you were saying, parks have become this very potent, very visible symbol for the city reformers and the activists about what could be done to make life so instantly better for so many of the people in the city who don't have cars and can't drive out of the city and are just stuck there. And especially for children, there's on the Lower East Side, there's 500,000 people live there. There are two small parks on the Upper West Side between 110th Street and 150th Street. There's basically no green space. There's just tenements that block out the sun and care.
卡拉谈到这些公共洗手间时说，那些与塔慕尼协会有关系的女性会被指派为监督员，而她们竟然把洗手间变成了私人公寓，邀请别人来做客并举办聚会之类的活动，你根本没法使用它们。它们根本不对公众开放。你知道的，这真的很不可思议。正如罗曼你刚才所说，公园已经成为了城市改革者和活动家们一个非常强有力、非常显眼的象征，体现了如何能为城里许多买不起车、开不出城、只能困在这里的人们，瞬间让生活变得更美好。特别是对孩子们来说，在下东区，居住了50万人口。在上西区，在110街和150街之间只有两个小公园。基本上没有任何绿地。只有遮挡住阳光的廉租公寓，而且卡拉，
It's heartbreaking. I feel like Kara talks about children just standing in spots where the sun happens to be avoiding the buildings, like habit cracks between buildings that sunlight is going through because they want sunlight so badly and waiting for hours online just to dig in like little plots of dirt that are like you have to wait online to dig in dirt. That's how bad the recreation is for children in the city at that time. It's really it's abominable and the ultimate kind of symbol of Tammany's inability to deal with this is the Central Park Casino, which this is the big infrastructure project that Mir Walker is really invested in where there's a nightclub in Central Park. He throws out the owner.
这太令人心碎了。我觉得卡拉提到，孩子们只能站在那些刚好能避开建筑物的阳光洒落的缝隙里，比如建筑物之间能透进阳光的裂缝，因为他们太渴望阳光了，甚至要在土堆前排队等上好几个小时，就为了能在那么一小片泥地里挖土——你甚至得排队去挖泥巴。当时城里孩子们的娱乐条件就是这么糟。这真的很令人发指，而塔慕尼无力处理这一切的终极象征，就是中央公园赌场，这是市长吉米·沃克真正投入心力的大型基础设施项目，他在中央公园里建了一家夜总会。他把原老板赶走，
He leases it to this guy that Carol says he owes him a favor, I guess, because he introduced him to his favorite tailor. And he gives him a sweetheart deal to lease this casino. And Walker's very invested in the building of it, the design of it. And he treats it at his private social club where he and other Tammany politicians, they're drinking champagne. Motorcycle cops are escorting chorus girls when Broadway shows finish to the casino so that the politicians can can spend time with them It's really a bad situation for the entire city
把它租给了一个卡罗说他欠了人情的人，我猜是因为这个人把他引荐给了他最喜欢的裁缝。他以极优惠的条件把这个赌场租了出去。沃克对它的建设和设计投入了极大的热情。他把它当作自己的私人社交俱乐部，他和塔慕尼的其他政客们在那里喝着香槟。每当百老汇演出结束，摩托车警察就会护送歌舞女郎来到赌场，好让政客们能和她们厮混在一起。对整个城市来说，这真是一个糟糕透顶的局面。
Moses he's been trying to get the city to follow through on its promise to build new roads since 1926 and six years later None of those roads are built the lands that he was hoping to use for roads is filling in with housing developments they have the plans to build this Triborough Bridge, and they didn't even make any plans to build roads that would link the Triborough Bridge to the streets in the city. It would just be a bridge with no roads on either side. It's okay. They don't have the money to build the bridge anyway, so it doesn't matter. Why would they plan for it?
摩西自1926年以来一直试图让市政府兑现其修建新道路的承诺，但六年过去了，这些道路一条都没有修。他希望用来修路的土地正被房地产开发项目一点点蚕食。他们有建造三区大桥的计划，但甚至没有做任何规划去修建连接三区大桥与城市街道的道路。它将只是一座两头都没有道路的孤桥。没关系。反正他们也没钱建桥，所以规划不规划也无所谓。
This is when Moses starts to step in. Moses named the chairman of an activist organization, the Metropolitan Parks Conference, and he's got all these workers in his state parks office that he can use to start coming up with plans to submit to the city. And he is driving around New York at night, just kind of dreaming about roads and new parks. And I was like, when does he have the time to do this? He's all, he's so busy.
就在这时，摩西开始介入了。摩西被任命为一个名为“大都市公园会议”的活动组织的主席，他可以调动其州立公园办公室的所有员工，开始起草方案提交给市政府。他会在夜里开着车在纽约四处转悠，脑子里幻想着道路和新公园。我当时就在想：他哪来的时间做这些？他总是那么忙。
How does he have time to just drive around New York City? But it all culminates on February 25th, 1930, there's a big black tie event, and he presents this massive plan for parkways and new bridges to connect New York City to the outside world and between boroughs to make it possible to drive through the city, around the city, out of the city, without getting stuck in local traffic. And he's laying out what's going to become the Belt Parkway, the Bronx-Whitestone Bridge, the Henry Hudson Parkway, these many routes.
他怎么会有时间在纽约市到处兜风？但这一切在1930年2月25日达到高潮，当晚有一场盛大的黑领带晚会，他展示了一份宏大的公园大道和新桥梁计划，旨在将纽约市与外部世界以及各行政区连接起来，让人开车穿过城市、绕过城市、驶出城市时，不再陷入本地交通的拥堵之中。他勾勒出的正是后来的贝尔公园大道、布朗克斯-白石大桥、亨利·哈德逊公园大道等众多路线。
This chapter, I was going to go into more detail about it. It's a lot of New York metropolitan area specific traffic talk. It's bridges that you know if you drive around New York, but otherwise, the point is you can go from New England to Long Island and you won't get trapped in Manhattan traffic jams. That's his big, his big goal is to make it so that people outside of New York can get to Long Island without having to go through Manhattan and you'd have parks alongside all these parkways.
这一章，我本来打算更详细地探讨一下。里面有大量纽约大都市区特有的交通术语。如果你在纽约开车，你就会知道这些桥，但不管怎样，重点是你可以从新英格兰一路开到长岛，而不会被困在曼哈顿的交通大堵塞中。这是他的宏伟目标，他的宏伟目标是让纽约以外的人能够前往长岛而不必穿过曼哈顿，并且所有这些公园大道两旁都将伴随着公园。
And he says, we can do it folks. We can do it. We just have to issue a bond of $30 million. Help me fight to make this happen. And the audiences are like, we love it. Yeah, this is amazing. Yeah. Yeah.
他说，乡亲们，我们能做到。我们一定能做到。我们只需要发行3000万美元的债券。帮我一起奋斗，把这事变成现实。观众们的反应是：太棒了！这太神奇了。是的。
Yeah. Moses, you're the best. And the city is like, Oh, hold on a second. With good cause because at this point, like everything has been deteriorating for so long and nothing gets built and nothing gets maintained. It must seem like complete science fiction to them. It's like he's going to someone who is out of shape and just watches TV, never gets off their couch.
是的。摩西，你太棒了。而市政府则说：噢，等一下。这也是有充分理由的，因为此时此刻，一切都在长期恶化，什么都建不成，什么都维护不好。这在他们看来一定像是完全的科幻小说。这就好比你去对一个严重走样、只看电视、从不离开沙发的人说：
And he's like, next year, you're winning a gold medal in the Olympics. We're gonna make this happen. Like that's how New York feels. And they do pass, next year, you're winning a gold medal in the Olympics, we're gonna make this happen. Like that's how New York feels. And they do pass that bond issue, but most of the money goes unspent until, until 1933. 1933, Roosevelt is now in the White House. He's in the White House.
“明年，你就要在奥运会上拿金牌了。我们要把这事变成现实。”纽约当时的感受就是这样的。而他们确实通过了——明年，你就要在奥运会上拿金牌了，我们要把这事变成现实。纽约当时的感受就是这样。他们确实通过了债券发行法案，但大部分资金直到1933年都闲置未用。1933年，罗斯福入主白宫了。他进白宫了。
There's a new governor, Herbert Lehman, from the son of the Lehman brothers who become famous in other ways. Yeah, he's the Lehman nephew, I guess you'd call him. Yeah. That's right. And he has so much respect for Moses. He's gonna give him even more power. I know, Roman, you thought there was no more power
上任了新州长赫伯特·雷曼，他是因其他领域而出名的雷曼兄弟家族的后代。对，他可以说是雷曼的侄子吧。是的。没错。他对摩西极其尊重。他甚至要赋予摩西更多权力。我知道，罗曼，你本以为再也没有什么权力
left to give to Moses. But he gives him this very important post that sounds very boring. He makes him chairman of the State Emergency Public Works Commission, which means he's the one person who will determine which construction projects are gonna be submitted to the federal government for funding,
可以分给摩西了。但他交给了摩西一个非常重要、听起来却很无聊的职位。他任命摩西为州紧急公共工程委员会主席，这意味着他是唯一能够决定将哪些建筑项目提交给联邦政府以获取资金的人，
now that the government under Roosevelt is doing all this public works funding to try to get out of the depression. And Moses is like, I have some projects I will submit to the federal government. And he immediately gets funding for a ton of work in the Niagara Falls area, which Caro throughout the book will occasionally be like,
既然在罗斯福领导下的政府正在大搞公共工程投资，试图以此摆脱大萧条。而摩西则说：我手头有些项目要提交给联邦政府。他立刻为尼亚加拉瀑布地区的大量工程争取到了资金，卡罗在整本书中会时不时地提到：
oh yeah, this enormous dam that, that Moses builds at Niagara Falls. And he seems to understand that his audience is a New York roughly centered audience and is not that interested in the Niagara Falls stuff. But this is like the dam that bears his name. Yeah. Yes.
噢，对了，那个摩西在尼亚加拉瀑布建造的巨大水坝。他似乎明白他的读者主要是以纽约为中心的受众，对尼亚加拉瀑布的事情并不是那么感兴趣。但这可是以他的名字命名的水坝啊。是的。没错。
Yeah. This is the Robert Moses dam. And so it's very important to Robert Moses. And I, it's almost, I, I admire Caro so much. I feel like I, I like the honesty of him mentioning it, but almost implicitly being like, but that's not why we're here, right folks? We're not here to hear about dams on Niagara Falls.
是的。这就是罗伯特·摩西大坝。所以这对于罗伯特·摩西来说非常重要。我，我简直太佩服卡罗了，我觉得他提到这一点非常诚实，但又近乎含蓄地在表达：不过，大家伙儿，我们今天来不是为了听这个的吧？我们不是来听尼亚加拉瀑布的水坝的故事的。
But also like the Lincoln Tunnel, housing projects, he's starting to get federal funding for those things in New York. Even more important for Moses' future, he's finally able to get the legislature to establish the Triborough Bridge Authority, which as a semi-private, semi-public organization, it can issue its own bonds to be paid back by toll revenue, which makes it immediately eligible for $44.2 million from the Public Works Administration,
但同时，比如林肯隧道、住宅项目，他开始为纽约的这些项目争取联邦资金。对摩西的未来更重要的是，他终于让立法机关成立了三区大桥管理局。作为一个半私半公的组织，它可以通过通行费收入偿还债券来发行自己的债券，这使得它立即有资格从公共工程管理局获得4420万美元的资金，
from the federal government. And this is the moment I feel like when rereading it, where it's really struck me, oh, the federal money is big money. Like there's, there's no more scrounging from the state to a certain extent. He still does plenty of that. But now if he can get the state to get a little invested in something, he can go to the federal government and get an enormous amount of money. Suddenly he has so much more potential to play with. And the authority, of course it's instantly corrupt. So the federal government is like, we're not giving you any more money. This is ridiculous. And most,
来自联邦政府。我觉得这是我在重读时深受触动的一个时刻：哦，联邦政府的资金才是真正的大钱。从某种程度上说，再也不用到州里去四处乞讨了。他当然还是做了不少这种事。但现在，只要他能让州里在某项事业上投入一点资金，他就可以直接去找联邦政府，拿到巨额资金。刹那间，他手里可供施展的潜能变得如此巨大。而这个管理局，不出所料，瞬间就腐败了。所以联邦政府说：我们不会再给你们一分钱了。这简直荒谬。于是摩西——
this is like Tammany guys, we could change the city. Like we can make it so much easier to get around it. And they federal government is like, we're not giving you any more money. This is ridiculous. And Moses is like, Tamany guys, we could change the city. Like we can make it so much easier to get around it. And they're like, yeah, but how much money are we gonna make off of this? And so the city is, it's in bad financial straits. More loans are coming too. Things are really bad. Robert Moses, he sees only one solution.
这就好比塔慕尼的伙计们，我们本可以改变这座城市。我们可以让出行变得轻松得多。而联邦政府却说：我们不会再给你们一分钱了。这简直太荒谬了。摩西则说：塔慕尼的弟兄们，我们可以改变这座城市。我们可以让交通变得顺畅得多。而他们却说：是啊，但我们能从中捞到多少钱呢？所以，城市正处于严重的财政困境中。更多的贷款接踵而至。情况真的很糟。罗伯特·摩西发现只有一个解决办法。
He's gonna have to be mayor. Okay, now we're onto chapter 19, To Power in the City, which I find it to be a little awkward to read out loud. It's a very Marvel Comics type story title, yeah. It's the kind of thing Stan Lee would write, would be like, low a god cometh, you know,
他必须当选市长。好了，现在我们进入第19章，《夺取城市权力》（To Power in the City），我发现这一章大声读出来有点尴尬。这是一个非常漫威漫画风格的故事标题，对吧。这就像斯坦·李会写的那种标题，会写着：“看啊，神明降临了”，你知道的，
to power in the city, you know, daredevil discovers. And this is where we focus on the mayor of New York. A lot of this has been sort of bouncing around to like the governor and this, and we're focusing here more on the city and what it would mean to have a mayor also on Robert Moses's side.
“权倾一城”，你知道的，“夜魔侠发现”。在这一章中，我们将焦点对准了纽约市长。之前的许多内容都在州长和各种事务之间跳来跳去，而这里我们更多地聚焦于这座城市，以及如果能拥有一位站在罗伯特·摩西这边的市长意味着什么。
Yes, to not have to deal with the Tammany machine, which would be a first in New York for a long time. And it starts with one of Caro's best chapter opening lines, which is, he has so many great ones. This is, in New York City, 1933 was the year of the goo goo, which I love. But it's only now that I realize that goo goo is a way of saying good government, like a derogatory way of referring to a good government person, which makes it a little less fun to me. I thought it was Al Smith calling people babies. But I like that it's the year of the goo goo. The good government movement is back.
是的，不必再与塔慕尼机器周旋，这在很长一段时间里的纽约将是破天荒第一次。而这一切始于卡罗书中最好的章节开头之一，他写过太多精彩的开头了。这一句是：在1933年的纽约市，那是“古古”（goo goo）之年，我太喜欢这句了。但直到现在我才意识到，“古古”其实是“好政府”（good government）的谐音，是一种对善治主义者的贬称，这让我觉得它的趣味减了几分。我以前以为是阿尔·史密斯在把别人叫小宝宝。不过我还是很喜欢“古古之年”这个说法。好政府运动又回来了。
Judge Samuel Seabury, who we mentioned earlier, he is spearheading it. And because of the depression, the electorate is seen as being more sympathetic to this type of good government movement because they need help so badly. You can no longer just be like, yeah, the government's corrupt.
塞伯里法官（Judge Samuel Seabury），我们前面提到过，他正在带头挑起这场运动。由于大萧条，选民们似乎对这种好政府运动更加抱有同情态度，因为他们实在太需要帮助了。你不能再轻描淡写地说：没错，政府是腐败了。
What are you gonna do? Because you can't feed your family. And a mayoral election is looming. Public sentiment is against Tammany. It doesn't help that John Patrick O'Brien, the guy they installed after Walker, is a gaffe machine. And Caro points out two genuine gaffes. He's talking to voters in Harlem and he says, my heart is as black as yours, which is crazy. And he's talking to a synagogue audience and he tells them how much he admires the scientist Albert Weinstein, which is... He's like a cartoon version of a bad mayor.
你能怎么办呢？因为你连家人都喂不饱。市长选举即将来临。公众情绪对塔慕尼极为不利。约翰·帕特里克·奥布里恩（John Patrick O'Brien，沃克之后他们扶植的人）简直就是个“失言制造机”，这更雪上加霜。卡罗指出了两个真正的重大失言。他在哈林区对选民们说：“我的心和你们的一样黑”，这简直疯狂。当他在犹太教堂对台下观众演讲时，他告诉大家他是多么崇拜科学家阿尔伯特·温斯坦（Albert Weinstein），这……他就像是一个昏庸市长的卡通漫画版。
And not too long before recording this, we talked to some of our listeners in a Discord AMA, and we were talking about moments of humor in the book, and I feel like Carol is very good at isolating some of these that are just silly. It's silly for him to go to an audience and say Albert Weinstein. So the environment is favorable for that most desired of all things by all reformers who hear about it even now all the time, a fusion candidate. That's right. People from different political parties working together. The political media in the United States loves this. They love the idea of a bipartisan candidate, even though it almost never works, almost never. And it's not always a good idea. It's often not a good idea.
就在录制这期节目不久前，我们在Discord的AMA（问答）活动中和一些听迷们聊过，当时我们谈到了书中那些幽默的时刻，我觉得卡罗非常擅长捕捉那些纯粹透着滑稽的细节。他去对观众说出“阿尔伯特·温斯坦”这种名字，实在是太滑稽了。因此，当时的政治环境对所有改革者梦寐以求、哪怕直到现在也一直津津乐道的那种终极事物——一个融合派候选人（fusion candidate）——极为有利。没错。来自不同政党的政治人物携手合作。美国的政治媒体对这一套简直爱不释手。他们热衷于两党共推的候选人，尽管这几乎从未真正奏效过，几乎从不。而且这并不总是个好主意。它往往是个糟糕的主意。
But so the reformers who would normally be kind of activist liberals, you could say, and the Republican party, they form the city fusion party. They ask Judge Seabury to run for mayor. And he says, no, I don't want to do that. And so they consider Robert Moses and Robert Moses is very attractive to them, to the older reformers who don't know that Robert Moses is a shady individual. They're like, oh, this is our protege.
但无论如何，那些平时属于激进自由派的改革者们，以及共和党人，组成了“城市融合党”。他们邀请塞伯里法官竞选市长。而他拒绝了：“不，我不想干这事。”于是他们开始考虑罗伯特·摩西。罗伯特·摩西对他们有着巨大的吸引力，特别是对那些不知道罗伯特·摩西其实是个黑幕重重之人的老派改革者来说。他们会想：噢，这是我们的门生啊。
Like we saw him come up from a young man. He's our son in a way. And the younger guard are like, they look up to him. They see him as their idol and he is considered a public servant and not a politician, which is not a real differentiation. And Carol kind of criticizes this as a naive way of categorizing officials, but to them, it feels very real. He's not a dirty politician.
就像我们看着他从一个年轻人成长起来一样。从某种意义上说，他就像是我们的儿子。而年轻一代则对他顶礼膜拜。他们视他为偶像，而且他被视为一个公共公仆，而非政客，虽然这其实并不是什么本质区别。卡罗在某种程度上批评这是一种对官员进行分类的天真方式，但对他们而言，这种感觉非常真实。他不是那种满身铜臭的政客。
He is a noble public servant. Moses is like, yeah, I'll take that nomination for sure. But judge Seabury, the latest in a line of Moses opponents, he does not like him. And Caro takes a moment to talk about Seabury, who is this kind of like old fashioned, descended from pilgrims, kind of sternly imposing patrician idealist.
他是一个高尚的公务员。摩西的反应是：好啊，我绝对接受这个提名。但塞伯里法官——作为一连串摩西反对者中的最新一位——却很不喜欢他。卡罗花了一些笔墨来描写塞伯里，他是一个那种老派的、有着清教徒血统的、威严而高傲的贵族理想主义者。
He's elected judge at age 28, and he spends nearly his entire life fighting Tammany Hall. And in 1916, when he was 43, one year older than me, which makes me feel very unaccomplished, he runs for governor and he almost makes it. But Tammany orchestrates his defeat, even though he's their candidate. He's the Democratic candidate. He's their party's candidate. And there's a footnote that I have to mention because I love it. Rucharo says that one of
他28岁就当选法官，几乎用了一生的大部分时间在跟塔慕尼协会做斗争。在1916年，当他43岁时——比我只大一岁，这让我觉得自己太无所作为了——他竞选州长，并且险些成功。但塔慕尼暗中策划让他的竞选流产，尽管他正是他们的候选人。他是民主党候选人。他是他们党派的候选人。这里有个脚注我必须提一下，因为我太喜欢了。卡罗说，塞伯里参选的
the reasons that Seabury ran was that Theodore Roosevelt, who at the time has been president of the United States, Theodore Roosevelt convinces him to run, and at the last minute he pulls his support and supports the Republican. And Seabury goes to Roosevelt's home and calls him a Blatherskite. He's so mad that he goes all the way up to Oyster Bay to call him a Blatherskite, which I just love. Do we know what a Blatherskite is,
原因之一是，当时的美国总统西奥多·罗斯福说服他参选，结果在最后一刻，罗斯福撤回了对他的支持，转而支持了共和党人。塞伯里直接冲到罗斯福家，当面骂他是“废话大王”（Blatherskite）。他气得甚至大老远跑到牡蛎湾去骂他“废话大王”，我简直太喜欢这个细节了。我们知道什么是“Blatherskite”吗？
other than the greatest name ever? I mean, it doesn't sound good. It doesn't sound positive. I'm gonna look, I have to look this up right now. Okay, so a Blathers guide is a person who talks at great length without making much sense. Well, that's a little more mild than I thought it was. Yeah, I thought it was gonna be weird.
除了这绝对是有史以来最棒的名字之外？我的意思是，这听起来就不像什么好词。听起来不怎么正面。我要查一下，我现在就得查查。好，“Blatherskite”是指一个夸夸其谈、废话连篇却说不出什么门道的人。好吧，这比我想象的要温和一点。对，我以为会更古怪呢。
I thought it was gonna be something that involves farm animals or, you know, like, you know. But it's still not a great thing to be called, especially in 1916, that's powerful stuff. And he wants to run for governor in 1918. The nomination goes to Al Smith, who Seabury does not like. He sees him as the friendly guy who puts a nice face on the Tammany tiger. He makes this corruption presentable. And Seabury returns to private life, always believing, according to Moses, who I assume told this to
我以为会是什么跟农场动物有关的词，或者你知道的，那种。但它依然不是什么好听的称呼，尤其是在1916年，这词很有杀伤力。他想在1918年竞选州长。结果提名落在了阿尔·史密斯头上，塞伯里很不喜欢阿尔·史密斯。在他眼里，史密斯不过是个挂着一副友善面孔、给塔慕尼这只恶虎披上温情外衣的家伙。他让这种政治腐败变得体面可亲。于是塞伯里退隐江湖，但据摩西——我猜是摩西把这告诉了
Caro, that if Al Smith had stepped aside, he could have been governor and then someday president. And this is the lesson from every book about politics I've ever read. Everyone who goes into politics assumes they will be president someday. It's the same way you read James Clavel's Shogun, every character is like, yeah, yeah, and I do this and this and I'll become Shogun.
卡罗的——说，塞伯里始终坚信，如果当年阿尔·史密斯肯靠边站，他就能当上州长，然后有朝一日就能入主白宫。而这也是我读过的每一本政治书给我的教训：所有踏入政坛的人都笃定自己有朝一日能当上总统。这就像你读詹姆斯·克拉韦尔的《幕府将军》一样，每个角色都信誓旦旦：“没错，等我做完这个和那个，我就会成为幕府将军。”
And it's like, you're never gonna be Shogun. Like you're four levels down. Everyone who goes into politics is like, yeah, I'll probably be president at some point. Yeah, and this is the one time, or probably one of a handful of times, where Robert Moses' association with Al Smith really hurts him because Seabury really hates Al Smith.
结果现实是：你永远当不上幕府将军。你还差了十万八千里呢。每个从政的人都觉得：嗯，我大概在某个时候会当上总统吧。对，这也是绝无仅有的一次，或者可以说是屈指可数的几次，罗伯特·摩西与阿尔·史密斯的关联真正害了他，因为塞伯里对阿尔·史密斯恨之入骨。
Robert Moses is rightfully considered his right-hand man. And even though I think on the merits, Seabury wouldn't have huge problems with Robert Moses and what he did and how he gets things done. He just hates Al Smith so much that Robert Moses is unacceptable to him. Yes, and so he will not support Moses and his support is crucial for a fusion candidate.
罗伯特·摩西理所当然地被视为阿尔·史密斯的左膀右臂。尽管我认为就事论事的话，塞伯里对罗伯特·摩西其人以及他的做事风格和成事手段，并不会有什么根本性的大问题，但他对阿尔·史密斯的痛恨如此之深，以至于罗伯特·摩西对他来说根本无法接受。没错，因此他绝对不会支持摩西，而他的支持对于一个融合派候选人来说至关重要。
Even today in politics, personal endorsements, personal support from specific individuals is so important. And if Seabury won't support Moses, it's impossible. So the party goes after a lot of different potential candidates, they all turn it down for various reasons. There's one guy though who wants the nomination so badly, but he is literally the reformer's last choice. They do not like him.
即使在今天的政坛，个人的背书、特定人物的个人支持依然至关重要。如果塞伯里不肯支持摩西，那这事就彻底没戏了。于是该党开始物色许多不同的潜在候选人，但他们都因为各种原因拒绝了。不过，有那么一个人，极度渴望得到这个提名，但他偏偏是改革者们最后的选择。他们一点也不喜欢他。
And that is brash, ambitious, ultra liberal, Republican, Jewish, Italian, Fiorello, LaGuardia, the little flower, former congressman, previously failed candidate for mayor. And I just want to mention the way Carol describes him, he says, LaGuardia possessed qualifications for making the run beyond the fact that half Jewish and half Italian married first to a Catholic and then to a Lutheran of German descent, himself a Mason and an Episcopalian. He was practically a balance ticket all by himself. It's such a fun way to describe him. At LaGuardia, he's been anti-corruption before Seabury, but he's this fiery guy from the tenements. He's an outsider to the kind of upper-class reformers, and he's very open about demagoguing, and he's nakedly ambitious ambitious and that repels them. And on top of that, LaGuardia is a New Deal liberal.
这个人就是：性格急躁、野心勃勃、极度自由派、身为共和党人却又兼具犹太和意大利血统的——菲奥雷洛·拉瓜迪亚（Fiorello LaGuardia），人称“小矮人”（小花），前国会议员，此前竞选市长曾惨遭失败。我只想提一下卡罗描写他的方式，他说：“拉瓜迪亚拥有超越竞选本身的种种独特资历：他拥有犹太和意大利血统，先是娶了一位天主教徒，后来又娶了一位有德国血统的路德宗信徒，他本人既是共济会成员又是圣公会教徒。他简直凭一己之力就凑成了一张平衡的选票。”这种描写他的方式太有趣了。拉瓜迪亚在塞伯里之前就已经开始反腐了，但他是个出身廉租公寓的火爆脾气。对于上流社会的改革者来说，他是个彻头彻尾的局外人，而且他毫不掩饰自己的煽动性，有着赤裸裸的野心，这让改革者们深感排斥。最要命的是，拉瓜迪亚是个新政自由派。
Even though he is a Republican, he is all about the New Deal, whereas the older reformers are less liberal. They are pre-New Deal liberals. They don't love the fact that the government is now stepping in and doing so much. He's too radical for them. And yeah, and so because Seabury just hates Moses so much
尽管他是个共和党人，但他对新政顶礼膜拜，而老派的改革者们则没有那么自由主义。他们是前新政时期的自由派。他们一点也不喜欢政府现在大举介入并插手那么多事务。在他看来，他太激进拉。所以呢，由于塞伯里对摩西恨之入骨，
and even though LaGuardia is the last on the list, he becomes the fusion candidate, and then eventually becomes mayor. And you know, Moses is not a fan. He thinks even though he's a Republican, his liberalism and his sort of whatever, commie leanings with the support of the New Deal.
尽管拉瓜迪亚排在候选名单的最末尾，他最终还是成了融合派的候选人，并且最终当选了市长。你可以想象，摩西对此绝无好感。他认为，尽管拉瓜迪亚是个共和党人，但他的自由主义倾向以及他在新政支持下的那些种种……共产主义倾向。
He's very suspicious of all that sort of stuff. And the key to this is, I think, the key to a lot of different parts of the book is these certain individuals who step into Robert Moses' life and alter his course. And so far in Belmotskowitz and Al Smith, they've, you know, seen some potential in him and lifted him up beyond his station and he's delivered for them. Seabury, even probably more than Roosevelt, has just as an individual decided Robert Moses is unacceptable and he just denies him this chance to become mayor. Yes. And Caro says, he lays it out, All the reformers wanted Moses to be mayor. It was the year that a reform candidate was almost certainly going to win. And Seabury said, no,
他对所有这些路数都充满了怀疑。我认为，贯穿全书很多不同部分的关键，都在于这些特定的人物踏入了罗伯特·摩西的生命并改变了他的轨迹。到目前为止，从贝尔·莫斯科维茨到阿尔·史密斯，他们都从他身上看到了潜能，把他提拔到了超越其原本地位的高度，而他也确实没有辜负他们的期望。但塞伯里，甚至可能比罗斯福还要坚定，纯粹作为一个个体，认定罗伯特·摩西是不可接受的，并亲手剥夺了他竞选市长的机会。没错。正如卡罗所分析的，他摆明了讲：所有的改革者都希望摩西当市长。那一年，改革派候选人几乎注定会赢。而塞伯里却说：“不，我绝不让他当候选人。”所以从非常现实的意义上讲，你可以说，除了这个家伙之外，罗伯特·摩西本该当选纽约市长。这就是个人性格之间的碰撞。而这也差点落入了英雄史观的窠臼，即历史不过是巨人们互相挥拳、互相推搡、踩踏小人物，而小人物只能说“我不知道，我对此毫无控制力”，这是一种反民主的历史观。而卡罗本人是非常支持民主的，他想要展示民主是如何运作的、或是如何失灵、如何发生功能障碍的。但在这种情况下，这确实让人觉得，如果你从罗伯特·摩西的角度来看，
I won't have him as the candidate. So in a very practical sense, you can say, except for this one guy, Robert Moses would have been elected mayor of New York. And it's this clash of individual personalities. And it risks falling into the kind of great man school of history where history is just all about Titanic figures punching each other and shoving each other and stepping on little people and little people go, I don't know, I have no control over this, but which is an anti-democratic way of looking at things. And Caro is very much about very pro-democracy and wanting to show how democracy functions or misfunctions or dysfunctions. But in this case, it does feel like one of those things that, if you're looking at it from Robert Moses' point of view,
我敢肯定他的想法会是：要不是卡了这个家伙，我早就当上市长了。就是这个人挡了我的道。埃利奥特，我有个问题想问你：你觉得罗伯特·摩西能成为一个称职的市长吗？我的意思是，我们后来了解到他是一个极具效率的候选人，但是，这会不会让——
I'm sure he felt, I would be mayor except for this one guy. This one guy got in my way. Yeah, but here's a question I have for you, Elliot, is do you think that Robert Moses would have been an effective mayor? I mean, we learn about him being an effective candidate later on, but like, would this have been the, it would have been the end of the book,
《权力掮客》这本书到这里就直接全剧终了呢？当然，它确实会终结。不过，你觉得不当市长时的他，是不是比当了市长时反而更有权势？在对政治并非无所不知的前提下，我的答案是“是的”，理由恰恰和卡罗之前说过的一样。
the power broker to be sure at this point. But it would, would it be, do you think he was more powerful not being mayor than if he would have become mayor? Not knowing everything in the world about politics. I think yes, for exactly the reasons that Carol was was saying earlier Which is that when you're an elected official You have to at least show that you're willing to bow to the will of the electorate and you have to work with different people to compromise because your power if you're an appointed official like Moses comes from
那就是：当你是一名民选官员时，你至少得表现出你愿意向选民的意志低头，你必须与不同的人妥协合作，因为如果你像摩西那样是一名委任官员（appointed official），你的权力来自于你所掌控的资金或工作岗位；而作为一名民选官员，你的权力部分来自于那些资源，但更大程度上来自于你所获得的选票，因为这里面存在一个政治现实——你需要选票来赢得选举从而获取公职。而正如我们后来在书中将要看到的，摩西在竞选候选人这方面简直糟糕透顶。我认为他大概能当一个极其高效的第一任市长，然后就会在连任竞选中瞬间惨败，
The money or the jobs that you control your power as an elected official comes partly from that but in a greater sense from the votes that you get, because there's a political reality to, you need votes to win elections to get elected office. And Moses is so bad, as we'll see later in the book, at being a candidate. I think he would have an incredibly effective first term as mayor and then immediately lose reelection
因为他会把太多人得罪光了。而且我也觉得，他会把大量精力耗费在那些无聊的行政杂务上，那些他深恶痛绝的公众事务上，以至于他根本无法完成那么多建设。当你是市长时，你可没有那么多闲情逸致到处去长岛踏勘，或者在城市里开车兜风去规划公园，你有一堆杂务必须去处理。
because he will have made so many people angry. And I also think he would have been so busy with the boring stuff of administration, the public stuff that he doesn't like, that he wouldn't have gotten as much done. You don't have as much time to just tromp around Long Island or drive around the city planning parks when you're the mayor, you gotta go do things.
对，我也觉得是这样。我觉得他能发挥最大效用的状态，恰恰就是不直接对公众负责，而只是通过诸如媒体上那些阿谀奉承的报道之类的方式，把公众当作一种支持机制来拉拢。但如果他在选票层面上真的、真正地对选民负责，他权力来源的这个巨大支柱就会以极快速度被侵蚀掉。随之而来的其他一切也都会土崩瓦解。但他对于那些能够处理另一部分工作的民选官员来说却至关重要，
Yeah, I think that's right. I think he does his best job not being beholden to the public directly and sort of only inviting them in as a support mechanism through like, you know, fawning coverage in the press and things like that. But if he was really, really beholden to the electorate in terms of votes, this huge source of his power would erode very, very quickly. And then everything else would kind of fall apart. But he is really important to those elected officials
那些擅长拉拢交际、至少在表面上迎合公众和公众需求的人。他就像是那些人箭袋里的一支极其好用的箭。拉瓜迪亚深知这一点，他极其渴望将摩西及其幕僚班底收归麾下。
who can do the other part, can do the glad handing, can at least pay lip service to the public and the public needs. And he's just a really good arrow in the quiver of those people. And LaGuardia knows this, and he wants him and his administration badly. Like.
是的。拉瓜迪亚在这方面简直是罗斯福的对立面。罗斯福的心态是：只要能把这家伙弄走，我什么都愿意做。而拉瓜迪亚的心态则是：我怎么才能把你们这样的人弄来更多？我怎么才能让更多像你们这样的人一直为我工作？他有充分的理由。他想让这座城市的实体机能重新运转起来，重现美丽。他崇拜那些能干成实事的人，并且他已经承诺过，
Yes. LaGuardia's like the anti-Roosevelt in this way, where Roosevelt is like, whatever I can do to remove this guy would be great. Where LaGuardia is like, how can I get more of you? How can I have more of you working for me all the time? And he's got a lot of good reasons. He wants to make the city physically functioning and beautiful again. He admires people who build things and he's promised to
将使用专家而不是党派政客来管理政府。除此之外，拉瓜迪亚还想让阿尔·史密斯保持开心，因为在所有人脑海深处始终盘旋着这样一种可能：阿尔·史密斯随时可能参选市长，如果那样的话，他很可能会以摧枯拉朽之势直接获胜。拉瓜迪亚深知市里根本没钱，但我们又必须大兴土木。我们唯一能搞到钱的途径就是联邦资金。而这里恰恰有一个人深谙如何搞到联邦资金，那就是罗伯特·摩西。没错。
run the government using experts, not partisan hacks. And on top of that, LaGuardia wants to keep Al Smith happy because there's always the chance in the back of everybody's mind that Al Smith could run for mayor, in which case he would probably win almost instantly. And LaGuardia knows the city has no money, but we have to build things. The only money we can get is federal money. And there's one man who knows how to get federal money and that's Robert Moses. Yeah.
为了让他加入政府班底，摩西提出了严苛的要求：他必须完全掌控此前各自独立的各行政区公园部门。他要掌控公园大道的开发，他要掌控三区大桥管理局，同时他还要保留自己的州职职位——这正是他权力的根基所在。但问题在于，法律规定你不能同时兼任州职和市职，于是他开始处心积虑地设计一种既能兼得的方法。
And for this to become part of the administration, he demands complete control over these, previously separate borough park departments. And he wants parkway development and he wants to control the tri-borough bridge authority Authority and he wants to be able to keep his state jobs which is the source of his power and the problem is is that you're legally not allowed to hold state jobs and state jobs at the same time and so he begins to engineer a method in which he can do both.
“法律制定者”摩西再次闪亮登场，他说：听着，这事我来搞定。让我来亲自起草能让这一切合法的法律。他在法案的第607条里悄悄埋下了一行字：无薪的州官员兼任无薪的市职务并不构成资格冲突。因此他所需要做的——这依然在迎合他标榜自己是公众公仆而非政客、绝不贪赃枉法的公众形象——
Moses the lawbringer enters into the story once again, and he says, hey, look, I'll take care of it. Let me write the law that's gonna make all this legal. And he buries in section 607 of the bill. It says, an unsalaried state officer is not ineligible for an unsalaried city post. And so all he has to say, which then still backs up the idea that he is a public servant,
就是说：听着，我干这些可都是一分钱不拿的。所以我完全可以身兼数职，因为我又不是靠这些捞钱。虽然立法机关里的人对此感到有些疑虑重重，但媒体支持摩西，那些本该反对一个人大权独揽的改革者们也支持他，因为他们信任他。那些深知可以跟他做生意的长岛大亨们支持他。市长和州长也都希望他坐上这些位置。于是法案顺利通过，摩西宣誓就职。正如我们将在下一章中所看到的，他一上台就把公园部门里所有不属于他自己人马的家伙统统清洗干净了。此时已是1934年2月。摩西如今身兼长岛州立公园委员会主席、
not a politician, not corrupt, is, look, I'm not getting paid for any of this. So I can hold all these jobs because it's not like I'm making money off of them. And everyone out, the people in legislature are iffy about this, but the press supports Moses, the reformers who would normally be against someone holding all this power, they support him because they trust him. The Long Island Barons who know that they can do business with him, they support him. The mayor and the governor, they both want him in these positions. So the bill passes and Moses is sworn in and as we'll see in the next chapter, he immediately gets rid of everybody who's that is not one of his people in the Parks Department. And at this point, it's February 1934. Moses is now head of the Long Island State Park Commission,
纽约州公园委员会主席、琼斯海滩州立公园管理局主席、贝斯佩奇州立公园管理局主席、纽约市公园局局长、三区大桥管理局局长、以及他随后一手建立的海滨公园管理局局长。所有控制公园和主要道路的机构
the New York State Council of Parks, the Jones Beach State Park Authority, the Beth Page State Park Authority, the New York City Park Department, the Triborough Bridge Authority, the Marine Parkway Authority, which he institutes right afterwards. Every group controlling parks and major roads
纽约州公园委员会、琼斯海滩州立公园管理局、贝斯佩奇州立公园管理局、纽约市公园局、三区大桥管理局、以及他随后不久设立的海滨大道管理局。每一个控制公园和主干道的集团
in the New York metropolitan area, he has pretty much personal control of. He is 45 years old, and he's got this. And he's come a long way from the guy who was about to turn 30, who figured that his career in public life was over. And he gets to work right away. The work that the New Deal has been doing to refurbish the parks has been generally crappy, to use a technical term.
在纽约大都会区，他几乎拥有完全的个人掌控权。他今年45岁，正当壮年。对于那个差点在30岁时以为自己的公共生活生涯已经结束、如今却大有作为的年轻人来说，他已经走过了很长的一段路。他立刻投入了工作。用一个专业术语来说，“新政”此前为修缮公园所做的工作简直是一塌糊涂。
And he has his engineers go out, he goes, do an inventory of New York City parks. There's no complete record anywhere of how much park space New York City even has or what conditions it's in. And they put together this one foot thick notebook with plans for 1800 renovations. It's gonna employ 80,000 people. And there's this constant stream of staff members
于是他让工程师们出动，去盘点纽约市的公园。当时没有任何完整的记录能说明纽约市到底有多少公园绿地，或者它们的状况如何。他们汇编了一本厚达一英尺的笔记本，里面有1800个翻新改造计划。这将雇用8万人。而且，办公室里源源不断地派出了工作人员——
sending them to parks, going with them, dictating his plans as they walk around, sending them to the main office in Babylon that he still has to get it turned into plans. And he's persuading all these experienced landscape architects to work for him. And his ideas are big and they're expensive. And his workers are like, that's going to cost a lot of money. And he's like, let me worry about that. Don't you worry about that. But while you're working on this, make sure the parks are fun. Parks are for fun. Parks are for fun. And Robert Moses is there to work.
把他们派往各个公园，陪同他们实地考察，在边走边看时口述他的规划，把他们派回巴比伦镇（Babylon）的总办公室，以便将这些想法转化成具体的图纸。他正在说服所有这些经验丰富的景观设计师为他工作。他的构想宏大且造价不菲。他的工人们觉得：“那得花一大笔钱啊。”而他的态度则是：“钱的事交给我来操心，你们别管这个。但在你们做这些工作的同时，一定要确保公园充满乐趣。公园就是为了好玩。公园就是为了好玩。”罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）就是为了工作而生。
And the next chapter we learn about all the things he can do in a very short amount of time. That chapter is called One Year and that is after this break. So this is chapter 21 year. It sort of starts at the moment that Governor Lehman signs a legislation allowing Moses to, you know, be the citywide parks commissioner. And one of these great moments of Robert Moses being Robert Moses, he gets sworn in, he steps outside and he tells everyone who works, who used to work for that
在下一章中，我们将了解到他在极短时间内所能完成的所有成就。那一章名为《一年》，将在本次中场休息之后播出。所以，这是第21章：《一年》。这一章的故事大约从勒曼（Lehman）州长签署立法、允许摩西担任全市公园专员的那一刻开始。这也是罗伯特·摩西展现其典型作风的伟大时刻之一：他刚宣誓就职，一走到门外，就对那个部门的所有员工——那些原本为该部门工作的人——
department, uh, you're all fired. Up until that point that each borough had its own parks commissioner, who had their own staff. And he, yeah, he literally is. It's almost as if he swears in and then turns around and is like, they're all gone by the way, like he just fires them instantly, takes his own people to the, uh, the fifth avenue arsenal. That's going to be their headquarters building their first job.
宣布：“你们都被解雇了。”在此之前，纽约的每个区都有自己的公园专员，并且各自拥有独立的工作人员。没错，他真的就这么做了。这几乎就像是他刚宣誓完，转过身就宣布：“顺便说一句，他们全都被开除了。”他就像这样瞬间解雇了所有人，然后带着自己的人马入驻第五大道军械库。这将成为他们的总部大楼，而他们的第一项工作就是——
They're going to make life so unpleasant for all the civil servants who got patronage jobs that they're gonna quit So he's like you you live in the Bronx Well, you work in southern Brooklyn now you live in Brooklyn you work in Harlem now Just make their commutes as bad as possible He gives them jobs that they hate and there's this old lady who is has a do-nothing job That is kind of like a patronage version of a pension. And they force her to work through the night until at 2 a.m. she's like, I'm retiring. That's it, I don't wanna work here anymore.
他们要让那些通过裙带关系获得工作的公务员们日子难过到极点，逼得他们主动辞职。所以他的策略是：你住在布朗克斯吗？好吧，你现在得去布鲁克林南部上班；你住在布鲁克林吗？现在去哈林区上班。总之，就是尽量让他们的通勤痛苦无比。他给他们分配他们最痛恨的工作。其中有一个老太太，一直拿着一份不用干活的闲职，这有点像养老金的裙带关系版本。结果他们硬逼着她通宵工作，直到凌晨两点，她终于崩溃了：“我退休！不干了，我再也不想在这里工作了。”
So they're just, they're ruthless with it. Yeah, yeah. And he also recognizes that there's a lot of these plum jobs where people do nothing, but there's a lot of underpaid positions in this part of the government. And he wants to make parks fun above all. He wants to make roads that are good.
所以他们对待这事极其冷酷无情。没错，确实如此。与此同时他也意识到，政府部门里有很多这种拿钱不干活的肥差，但同时也有很多薪酬过低的职位。然而，他首要的目标是让公园变得好玩，他想修建优质的道路。
He wants to have good plans for these things. And, you know, the architects and, you know, engineers of this time, you know, are, a lot of them are out of work. He wants to attract the best of them, but the jobs, the salaries are set so low that, and they're set so low because of some sort of like different federal guidelines and things like trying to-
他希望为这些项目制定出色的规划。而且，当时许多建筑师和工程师都处于失业状态。他希望吸引其中最优秀的人才，但这些职位的薪水被定得极低，而之所以定得这么低，是因为受到各种不同的联邦准则和尝试的限制——
Yeah, the Civil Works Administration is like, we can't spend too much money on this. So, you know, it can be paid more than this amount. And he's just like, screw all that. I need to get the best people to do this. And so he begins finagling his own sort of system of how to pay people so he can get the best and get these people that instead of having, you know
没错，民政工程署（Civil Works Administration）的态度是：“我们不能在这个上面花太多钱，所以薪酬不能超过这个标准。”而他的反应则是：“去他的规章制度，我需要最优秀的人来做这件事。”于是他开始自行变通，设计出一套发薪酬的系统，这样他就能招揽到顶尖人才，从而不再——
a foot deep of things that have been, you know undone and neglected and done poorly he wants to start working through this. And so he's just trying to solve it in every way possible. Yeah. And he has this kind of cattle call for architects. He wants to hire 600 architects. And this is another occupation that's been hit hard. Like you said, you know
面对一英尺厚、那些已被搁置、荒废且做得一塌糊涂的烂摊子，他想要着手把这些工作逐一推进。因此，他正试图通过各种可能的方式来解决问题。没错。而且他为建筑师们举行了一场类似“牛群大召集”的招聘会。他想招募600名建筑师。建筑师这也是一个遭受重创的行业。就像你刚才说的——
if the depression is going on people are not building things. And so if you're an architect or an engineer you're out of work you can't make any money and this is a time when there's no unemployment right now there's no unemployment insurance like these are all things that are being introduced during this time and so people from all over they flock to this kind of cattle call and in one day in January people are there from dawn until the early evening interviewing for jobs.
如果经济大萧条正在肆虐，人们就不会大兴土木。所以如果你是个建筑师或工程师，就会失业，赚不到钱。而且那是一个还没有失业救济金的时代——眼下还没有失业保险这回事，所有这些都是在这一时期才陆续推出的。因此，来自各行各业的人们蜂拥而至，参加这种像“牛群大召集”一样的面试。在1月的一天里，人们从黎明一直排到傍晚，排队面试工作。
If you meet most qualifications, you're put to work that day and they send you to the basement and they say, that's your desk. There's a cot next to it. Work on this plan. Don't leave, sleep here until it's done. We need those blueprints ready.
如果你符合大部分条件，当天就能上岗。他们会把你领到地下室，对你说：“那是你的办公桌。旁边有张行军床。赶紧做这个规划。不准离开，在这儿睡觉，直到做完为止。我们需要这些蓝图马上准备好。”
And he's also unhappy with the workers that have been doing this refurbishing job in the parks. So he says to contractors who he knows, send me your toughest ramrods. These are the people whose job is just to bully people into working harder, I guess. I guess they're supervisors. He goes, send me your toughest ramrods. I'm gonna have them backed up by police officers. We're gonna force everybody to work harder. And they're working through the winter. And this is winter in New York. Now, Roman, you're a northern California guy. The winters there are pretty mild, right?
而且，他对之前一直在公园里从事修缮工作的那些工人很不满意。于是他对相熟的承包商说：“把你们手下最强悍的工头派给我。”这些人的工作，我猜就是靠蛮横霸道逼迫别人更努力地工作吧。我猜他们就是监工。他对承包商说：“把你们最强悍的工头派给我，我要让警察在后面给他们撑腰。我们要强迫所有人加倍努力地干活。”他们在严冬中日夜赶工。这可是纽约的冬天。罗曼，你是个北加州人，那里的冬天相当温和吧？
They're very mild, yeah. Yeah. I live in Southern California now. The winter's here. It just means rain sometimes, but this is New York. Winter is a real thing there. And the winter of 1934, when this is all happening, is severe.
非常温和，是的。是的，我现在住在南加州。这里的冬天，有时意味着下雨，但这里可是纽约。那里的冬天可是动真格的。1934年的冬天，也就是这一切发生的时候，极其严寒。
The city gets 52 inches of snow, Caro says. The mean temperature for February is 11.5 degrees. And Moses has people working in eight-hour shifts, three shifts a day, through the night, in the cold, to get these projects done. On February 22nd, it's in those 18 inches, they keep working through it. And they're working so hard that they're actually working ahead of plans, and the architects have to keep changing their blueprints to accommodate work that's being done, things that are being dug, pipes that are being laid, because it's happening so fast.
卡罗（Caro）写道，这座城市迎来了52英寸（约1.3米）的降雪。2月份的平均气温仅为11.5华氏度（约零下11.4摄氏度）。摩西却让工人分成八小时一班、一天三班倒，冒着严寒彻夜赶工，以求完成这些项目。2月22日，在积雪深达18英寸（约46厘米）的恶劣天气下，他们依然在继续施工。他们的工作进度如此之快，以至于实际施工甚至超前于规划图纸，建筑师们不得不不断修改蓝图，以适应正在进行的施工进度——比如正在开挖的工程、正在铺设的管道，因为一切都发生得太快了。
And one of the big projects, which we'll spend more time on a little bit later in the chapter, is a new Central Park Zoo to replace this menagerie full of lions that you have to shoot in case they escape. And the architects finished the plans for the zoo in 16 days, because they're working so, just so many hours and they're working so hard on it.
其中一个重点项目是新建中央公园动物园，我们在本章稍后会花更多时间来讲述它。它将取代那个装满了狮子、一旦狮子逃跑就不得不将其射杀的旧动物园。建筑师们仅用了16天就完成了动物园的设计图纸，因为他们工作的时间实在太长、太拼了。
It's amazing. The first culmination of this, Saturday, May 1st, 1934, for anyone who has lived in New York, you know that when spring hits in New York City, it is like the world has turned over. Everything feels so different. Everyone comes out kind of like their eyes blinking because they can't, the sun is so bright, you know, they're all wearing coats and they just shed them. It like, people are just shedding clothes in the street because they're not used to the heat that's coming up. And New Yorkers emerged from the winter doldrums to find that out of this 1,800 park renovation projects, 1,700 have been completed.
这太惊人了。这一切的第一个高潮出现在1934年5月1日，星期六。任何在纽约生活过的人都知道，当春天降临纽约市时，那种感觉就像是整个世界都翻天覆地了。一切都变得如此不同。人们纷纷走出家门，由于阳光太刺眼，他们眨巴着眼睛；每个人都穿着大衣，然后又把它们脱掉。人们简直是在街上边走边脱衣服，因为他们还不习惯随之而来的热浪。纽约人从冬日的沉闷中走出来，惊讶地发现，在这1800个公园翻新项目中，竟然已经完成了1700个。
And there's a, hold on, we're already going long, but I'm going to just say a little bit of this description here. It says, just to give the scale of it, every structure and every park in the city had been repainted. Every tennis court had been resurfaced. Every lawn had been reseeded. Eight antiquated golf courses had been reshaped. Eleven miles of bridle paths rebuilt. Thirty-eight miles of walks repaved.
等等，我们已经聊得很久了，但我还是要念一小段这里的描述。书上说，为了让人直观感受到它的规模：市内的每一个结构和每一个公园都被重新粉刷过。每一个网球场都重新铺设了表面。每一片草坪都重新播了草籽。8个陈旧的高尔夫球场被重新塑造。11英里（约17.7公里）的骑马小径被重建。38英里（约61.2公里）步道被重新铺设。
A hundred and forty-five comfort stations renovated. Two hundred and eighty-four statues refurbished. Six hundred and seventy-eight drinking fountains repaired. Seven thousand waste paper baskets replaced. Twenty-two thousand five hundred benches re-slatted, 7,000 dead trees removed, 11,000 new ones planted in their place, and 62,000 others pruned, 86 miles of fencing, most of it unnecessary, torn down, and 19 miles of new fencing installed in its place.
145个舒适站（公共厕所）被翻新。284座雕塑被修缮。678个饮水机被修复。7000个废纸篓被更换。22500条长椅被重新装上板条，7000棵死树被移除，11000棵新树取而代之，还有62000棵树木被修剪，86英里（约138.4公里）的栅栏（其中大部分是不必要的）被拆除，19英里（约30.6公里）的新栅栏取而代之。
Just like... Necessary fencing, I suppose. Yeah. The unnecessary fencing, I have to assume around things that are like damaged that people can't use anymore. But, and the parks look better than they have in at least a generation. And for the first time in years, the USS Maine Memorial on Columbus Circle, which is still there, you know, I used to walk by it all the time when I worked in that area, is for the first time that anyone can remember. It's clean and has all its pieces like that. Part
简直就像……我想，是指那些必要的栅栏吧。是的。至于那些不必要的栅栏，我不得不猜测，它们大概是围着那些人们已经无法再使用的损毁设施。总之，公园看起来比至少整整一代人以来的样子都要好。多年来，哥伦布圆环上的缅因号战舰纪念碑（USS Maine Memorial）——它现在还在那儿，我以前在那个区域工作时经常路过它——这是人们记忆中破天荒头一次，它变得干干净净，而且所有的部件都完好无缺。这座雕塑的一部分
of that statue is a little boy and the arms of that boy had been missing for so long. And for movie fans, this is where in the movie Taxi Driver, Robert De Niro's character, Travis Bickle, is about to assassinate a presidential candidate and then runs off when he gets noticed. And so you have to imagine that scene loses some of its power, maybe it gains some, I don't know. If the statue behind Charles Palatine,
是一个小男孩，那个男孩的双臂已经失踪了很久。对于电影迷来说，电影《出租车司机》（Taxi Driver）中，罗伯特·德尼罗（Robert De Niro）饰演的角色特拉维斯·比克尔（Travis Bickle）正准备刺杀总统候选人，但在被人发现后仓皇逃跑，场景就是在这里。所以你可以想象一下，如果候选人查尔斯·帕拉丁（Charles Palatine）身后的那座雕塑
the candidate, is just wrecked, is just in bad shape. That's right. And this is happening all over the city. Parks all over the city are getting refurbished. They're getting to a state where people can really enjoy them again. And this is again, why that whole last chapter spent so much time on this.
破烂不堪、状况糟糕，那个场景的冲击力可能会减弱一些，也许会增强一些，我也不知道。就是这样。而且这种情况在全城各地都在上演。全市各地的公园都在翻新。它们的状况恢复到了人们可以真正再次享受它们的程度。这也是为什么上一章要花那么多时间来讲述这一切的原因所在。
It's to show you how far the city had come and how far it had come because of Robert Moses. Caro is presenting a real Moses before and after on this city. That this city is, there's a real rebirth in the parks facilities. And there will be again with the roads later on, but I wanted to highlight two things.
这是为了向你展示这座城市发生了多大的变化，以及因为它而带来的巨大改变。卡罗在展示这座城市在罗伯特·摩西前后的真实对比。这座城市迎来了公园设施的真正重生。后来道路建设也将迎来同样的重生，但我现在想重点强调两件事。
One of the things they did is they rebuilt the Prospect Park Zoo in Brooklyn, which I'm very thankful for because I went to that zoo many times. I took my children there probably a hundred times. It's a great little zoo. And reading this, I was like, oh yeah, like Robert Moses didn't just cause problems in my life
其中一件是他们重建了布鲁克林的展望公园动物园（Prospect Park Zoo），对此我非常感激，因为我去过那个动物园很多次。我带我的孩子们去那里大概有一百次。那是一个很棒的小动物园。读到这里时我想：“哦，对啊，罗伯特·摩西不仅在我们的生活中制造了麻烦——”
about round mass transit. Like he also did things that were still positive in my life years later. Like Bryant Park, which is a like a beautiful, necessary park was garbage. And then they refurbished it. They restore Central Park. They remove the shantytown, they evict the deformed sheep, they kill 230,000 rats,
关于糟糕的公共交通系统。“他在多年后依然在我的生活中留下了积极的影响。”比如布莱恩特公园（Bryant Park），这是一个美丽且必不可少的公园，过去曾是一片垃圾场，后来他们将其翻新。他们修复了中央公园。他们清除了贫民窟，驱逐了那些畸形的羊，消灭了23万只老鼠。
and they build new equipments and facilities, and they build the restaurant Tavern on the Green where 40 some odd years later, my father proposed to my mother before they got married, leading to me. So, Martin Rose is very responsible for me at this point, for my existence, you know? And the city doesn't have money to buy new land for parks. Even the land is very cheap right now during the Depression. So Moses sends one of his men, a man named Bill Latham,
他们建造了新的设备和设施，他们建造了“绿茵台”餐厅（Tavern on the Green）——大约四十年后，我的父亲正是在那里向我的母亲求婚，随后他们结婚，才有了我。所以，从某种意义上说，罗伯特·摩西对我的存在负有重大责任，对吧？当时纽约市根本没有钱为公园购买新的土地。尽管在大萧条时期土地非常便宜，但摩西还是派了他的手下一名叫比尔·拉瑟姆（Bill Latham）的人去——
he goes, inventory every piece of publicly owned land in the city, any city department that owns a piece of land, go find out about it, look at it personally, see if it's being used. And they find just a ton of unused or abandoned land all over the city and most able to convince the Guardia to give the parks department almost all of that land. And he starts plans right away for 69 parks and playgrounds in slum areas. And they redevelop this whole multi-block downtown plot that is now Sara Delano Roosevelt Park, which I mentioned just because as an NYU student in downtown, like if I was going a little bit further downtown, I walked through that park all the time. Like I, you can walk through the city and still see so many footprints of Robert Moses all over
他命令道：“去盘点城里每一块属于公共所有的土地，任何拥有土地的市政部门，去把它们找出来，亲自去查看，看看它们是否得到了利用。”结果他们全城到处都发现了大量闲置或废弃的土地，而且大部分都说服了市长拉瓜迪亚（LaGuardia）将几乎所有这些土地都划拨给公园部门。他立即着手规划在贫民窟地区建设69个公园和游乐场。他们重新开发了市中心这个横跨好几个街区的地块，也就是现在的萨拉·德拉诺·罗斯福公园（Sara Delano Roosevelt Park）。我提到它，只是因为作为纽约大学的学生，如果我要去市中心更往南的地方，我经常会穿过那个公园。你走在纽约这座城市里，到处都还能看到罗伯特·摩西留下的无数足迹。
the place. And he's so knowledgeable about the law and about public funding mechanisms that even when it, it seems like there's no money, he's always finding money. He's like, oh yeah, there's all this land that the state owns in the city that they forgot about. Give it to us. He's like, wasn't there a memorial fund for World War I memorial that never got built? Well, we'll build war memorial playgrounds. We'll use that money. He's like, didn't Arnold Rothstein, the mobster, when he died, didn't he have a lot of unpaid back taxes, but he owns some land? And so he goes to Arnold Rothstein's estate and he's like, well, in exchange for this land, we'll forgive the back taxes. Like he's constantly wheedling and finding ways to get what he wants. He goes to the Catholic Church and the gas company and all these rich philanthropists and he's like, hey, don't you want to give us some land for some parks and playgrounds?
而且他对法律和公共资金筹措机制如此精通，以至于即使在似乎无钱可用的情况下，他也能总能找到钱。他会说：“哦，对了，州政府在市内拥有所有这些他们已经遗忘的土地。把它交给我们。”他还会说：“难道不是有一个从未建成的第一次世界大战纪念碑的筹款基金吗？好吧，我们就用这笔钱来建造战争纪念游乐场。”他甚至会说：“阿诺德·罗斯坦（Arnold Rothstein），那个黑帮分子死的时候，难道没有留下很多欠缴的税款吗？但他名下有一些土地。”于是他去找阿诺德·罗斯坦的遗产管理人说：“好吧，用这块地来交换，我们可以免除这些滞纳的税款。”他不断地巧取豪夺，寻找各种方法来达到目的。他去找天主教会、天然气公司和所有这些富有的大慈善家说：“嘿，难道你们不想给我们捐点土地来建公园和游乐场吗？”
Wouldn't that be wonderful? And the press is orgasmic about all of this. They just love him. He's in the New York Times nearly once a day for all of 1934, which is certainly more times than Albert Einstein to use Caro's earlier metric for how many times Moses is in the paper. Although actually in this chapter, I think he mentions that he's in the paper
“那不是很棒吗？”媒体对这一切简直狂热到了极点。他们爱死他了。在整个1934年，他几乎每天都会登上《纽约时报》一次。用卡罗之前衡量摩西上报频率的标准来看，这绝对比阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦（Albert Einstein）上报的次数还要多。不过事实上在这一章里，我想他提到摩西上报的频率——
more often than J. Edgar Hoover. That's the metric he uses for this chapter. Yeah, yeah. It is really remarkable. And again, this is like one of these things where you just like get through this and you think, you know, if I was a person around at that time, I would be just like,
比J·埃德加·这是他在这一章中使用的衡量标准。真的非常引人注目。而且，这又是那种让人不禁感叹的事情：如果你是那个时代生活在那里的人，你肯定会——
I would have a like Robert Moses foam fangirl. I mean, I would just be all about all of this. And it is really stunning. And I love these ways that he gets around things like using the war memorial fund to in building the war memorial playgrounds and just, he just puts a plaque that just says, you know, war, remember it.
成为罗伯特·摩西的狂热崇拜者。我的意思是，我绝对会全力支持这一切。这确实太震撼了。我特别喜欢他绕过障碍的方式，比如利用战争纪念基金来修建战争纪念游乐场，然后只需要立一块牌子，上面写着：“战争，请铭记它。”
In honor of those we lost. We did it, great. Bring in the playground equipment. But it's something that I'd be curious to talk to a historian of parks, I guess, about whether that started the idea of public parks having war memorials embedded in them. Cause there's certainly a lot of them now.
“为了纪念那些逝者。我们做到了，太棒了。把游乐场器材搬进来吧。”不过，我很好奇，想跟一位公园历史学家探讨一下，这是否开启了“公共公园内嵌战争纪念设施”这种理念的先河？因为现在这样的公园确实有很多。
I was just at a park with my kids where there was this memorial to the soldiers who came from the San Marino area near Los Angeles that lost their lives in World War II in Korea. And there's a statue of a soldier kneeling bareheaded in remembrance and my son could not stop climbing on it. And I was like, please don't climb on that. Like that it's like, let's respect their memory.
我最近才和孩子们去过一个公园，里面就有一个纪念碑，纪念那些来自洛杉矶附近圣马力诺（San Marino）地区、在第二次世界大战和朝鲜战争中牺牲的士兵。那里有一尊士兵赤头跪地悼念的雕像，我的儿子一直在上面爬上爬下，我不得不制止他：“请不要在上面爬，让我们尊重他们的纪念碑。”
But there's so much of that now. And I wonder if it starts here, but this all, so this, this part of the chapter, it culminates in this beautiful section of the book, this five page section, all about the new central park zoo. Those plans were put together so fast on December 3rd, 1934, my birthday. Not that year. I was born, I was born 47 years later, but the, on, on that, on December 3rd, 1934, my birthday, not that year. I was born 47 years later. But the end of the year, Moses opens this new Central Park Zoo as a way to personally honor
现在这种设计太多了。我不知道它是不是从这里发源的。总之，这一部分的章节，最终以书中一个极其优美的段落达到了高潮——那是一个长达五页、专门讲述新建中央公园动物园的段落。那些规划在1934年12月3日（我的生日）以惊人的速度被拼凑在了一起。当然不是那一年，我是在那之后47年才出生的。不过，在那个时候——在1934年12月3日，也就是我的生日那天（当然不是那年，我晚了47年出生），但在那年底，摩西开放了这座全新的中央公园动物园，以此作为对——
Al Smith. Al Smith is so depressed that Roosevelt won't consider him for a federal job. And he spends a lot of time at the Central Park Menagerie. As we know, when he was governor, he had his executive mansion menagerie. He loves animals. And he's like, as a special favor to the old man, just want to improve the central park Menagerie. And Moses, because he loves Smith, he makes the zoo at top priority and he's diverting people from other projects to it. And he turns it into another one of these kind of like not quite early Disneyland kind of fantasy fairy worlds. And he is such a master at public ceremonies, at public kind of like presentations. And he has this ceremony
阿尔·史密斯（Al Smith）个人的致敬。阿尔·史密斯因为罗斯福不肯考虑给他安排一个联邦职位而沮丧万分。他在中央公园的动物园度过了大量时间。众所周知，当他担任州长时，他的官邸里就养着一个动物园，他非常热爱动物。摩西心想：“作为对这位老人的特殊照顾，我只想把中央公园动物园改善一下。”摩西因为深爱史密斯，便将这个动物园列为最高优先级，并不惜从其他项目中调集人手。他把它打造成了另一个有点像早期迪士尼风格的奇幻童话世界。他在主持公共仪式和公共庆典方面绝对是个大师——
and Caro does such a great job describing it. There's 1200 people there and a team of white ponies pulls a miniature coach up and a little girl gets out holding a big gold key and LaGuardia uses that key to unlock a door in the middle of an oversized picture book. And when he opens it, he's like, "'Now the picture book zoo is open.
卡罗把这个场景描写得极其精彩。现场有1200人，一队白色的矮种马拉着一辆迷你马车驶来，一个小女孩走下车，手里拿着一把金钥匙。拉瓜迪亚用这门钥匙打开了一扇位于超大画册中间的门。当他打开门时，他宣布：“现在，画册动物园正式开放了！”
"'It's officially open.' "'And they surprise surprise Smith. They give him a badge naming him honorary knight superintendent of the Central Park Zoo and a horse drawn wagon full of boys from the fourth ward, his old, his neighborhood singing East side, West side shows up and they present Smith with a Christmas turkey, which is this like strangely Dickensian choice. I mean, Christmas is coming up. They're like, here, we love you. Here's the turkey. And Moses is not there because he was working so hard that he collapsed from influenza.
“它正式开放了。”为了给史密斯一个惊喜，他们授予他一枚徽章，封他为中央公园动物园的“名誉夜间总监”。接着，一辆由马拉的车载着一群来自第四选区（他的老社区）的男孩们赶到了现场，他们高唱着《东区，西区》（East Side, West Side），并向史密斯赠送了一只圣诞火鸡——这是一个极其具有狄更斯风格的选择。我的意思是，圣诞节就要到了，他们仿佛在说：“给你，我们爱你，这是给你的火鸡。”而摩西本人当时并不在场，因为他工作实在太拼，结果因流感而累倒了。
He was working through his sickness and he just literally couldn't stand up anymore. So he misses all this. But later that week, he gives Smith a real key, this master key that unlocks the zoo and all the animal houses. And he goes, as night superintendent, you can go in whenever you want.
他带着病坚持工作，直到实在连站都站不稳了。所以他错过了这一切。但就在那周晚些时候，他送给了史密斯一把真正的钥匙——一把能打开动物园大门和所有动物馆舍的主钥匙。他对史密斯说：“作为夜间总监，你想什么时候来都行。”
And Al Smith will spend so many nights, years, I guess, just walking from his apartment to the zoo, unlocking it at night and just going in and like petting the animals at night. If there's a sick animal, he'll go and talk to it for a while and he likes to bring guests and he'll go up to the tiger cage and he'll go, LaGuardia, to make the tiger roar back
于是阿尔·史密斯在后来的许多个夜晚（或者说好几年里），都会从自己的公寓步行到动物园，在夜里打开大门走进去，在夜色中抚摸那些动物。如果有生病的动物，他会走过去跟它聊上一会儿。他还喜欢带客人去，径直走到老虎笼前对拉瓜迪亚说：“快让老虎吼回去！”
because the idea that the Tammany tiger is mad at what LaGuardia is doing to the city. And it's just, it's so, there's something so adorable about all of this. It's so delightful. This like, just the, this, this act of love for Al Smith in making this zoo beautiful and giving him a special, special key to it. I, I love it so much. It just cracks me up. And it's like one of those things of all these sort of different indignities that probably, you know,
因为他觉得坦慕尼协会（Tammany）的老虎对拉瓜迪亚对这座城市做的事情感到愤怒。这其中有着一种极其可爱、极其美妙的特质。这种出于对阿尔·史密斯的爱，把动物园修得美轮美奂，并送给他一把专属钥匙的做法——我太喜欢了。这简直让我忍俊不禁。这就像是那些生活中大大小小的委屈，如果他不是有着那么强烈的自我尊严，也许——
he wouldn't have suffered, you know, if he didn't have the ego he had, like there weren't true indignities. They're just like life moves on and it's okay, you know, type of thing. But like the fact that he gets this in his later life and it means so much to him and it is so innocuous and cute, you know what I mean?
他本不必承受这些。那些其实算不上真正的委屈，只是生活在继续，一切都挺过去了吧。但事实是，他在晚年得到了这个，而且这对他的意义如此重大，又是如此无害和可爱，你们懂我的意思吗？
It's just the greatest. I mean, it's so funny that that, you know, this thing means more to him than his $50,000 a year Empire State job that he does not give a fuck about, you know? And the fact that he has this for the rest of his days Absolutely cracks me up. It's so I feel every adult has a child inside of them Which is what I guess the Disney brand is built on and if you're a pregnant woman
这简直太棒了。我的意思是，太搞笑了：对缝他来说，这件事的意义甚至超过了那份年薪五万美元、他根本不屑一顾的帝国大厦工作。而且他将在余生中一直拥有这个特权，这绝对让我笑喷了。我觉得每个成年人的内心深处都住着一个孩子——我想迪士尼品牌就是建立在这个基础上的。如果你是一位孕妇，
Even more literally so but that's not what I'm talking about here But uh, it's terms like certain powerful people and politicians that child lives even closer to the surface You know It's terms like certain powerful people and politicians that child lives even closer to the surface. You know, you're, I'm always surprised when I read about presidents and I'll just hear about the childish things that they loved or that meant a lot to them. And there's something in Al Smith that he just is,
那就更字面意义上的“里面住着一个孩子”了，但这并不是我今天要谈的重点。我的意思是，对于某些权势人物和政客来说，他们心里的那个孩子甚至更接近表面，你懂的。我的意思是，对于某些权势人物和政客来说，他们心里的那个孩子甚至更接近表面。你懂的，每当我读到关于总统们的生平，听到他们喜爱的那些幼稚事物或者对他们意义重大的东西时，总是会感到很惊讶。在阿尔·史密斯的内心深处，某种程度上——
he just loves the zoo and he just wants to be around these animals and it means so much to him. It's just, it's very sweet. And once again, Moses has done all these amazing design touches that make the zoo a fun place to be. And people go there in droves. And Karo says, he says, the purpose of a park, Moses had been telling his designers for years,
他就是单纯地热爱动物园，只想和这些动物待在一起，这对他的意义非凡。这非常温馨。而且，摩西再次展现了他所有精妙的设计巧思，让动物园变成了一个充满乐趣的地方，人们成群结队地涌向那里。卡罗写道，摩西多年来一直对他的设计师们强调，公园的目的——
wasn't to overaw or impress, it was to encourage the having of a good time. Like we were saying earlier, parks are for fun. Like this is Moses' philosophy in good and bad ways. In good ways because parks should be fun. In bad ways because he's like, why would we want a natural grove of trees that have stood here since the beginning of time when we could have a baseball field?
不是为了令人敬畏或留下深刻印象，而是为了鼓励人们玩得开心。就像我们刚才说的，公园就是为了好玩。这就是摩西的哲学，既有积极的一面，也有消极的一面。积极的一面在于，公园本来就该好玩；消极的一面在于，他会觉得：“既然我们可以建一个棒球场，为什么还要保留自盘古开辟以来就立在这里的天然树林呢？”
You know, it's bad for conservation, but it's good for recreation. But we can't spend too much time on the Central Park Zoo as much as I would love to stay there because on page 386, we get a momentous sentence, and the Triborough Bridge was finally being built. That's right, the Triborough Bridge. This is the biggest project that Moses has taken on yet. And let's just get, let's, how big is it? Well, let's find out by looking at the thing here.
你知道，这不利于生态保护，但有利于休闲娱乐。不过，尽管我很想在那里多留一会儿，但我们不能在中央公园动物园花太多时间，因为在第386页，我们迎来了极其重大的一句话：“三区大桥终于开始建造了。”没错，三区大桥（Triborough Bridge）。这是摩西迄今为止承接的最大项目。让我们来了解一下，它究竟有多大？让我们通过书中的描述来一探究竟。
Its approach ramps would be so huge, this is Caro, not me, its approach ramps would be so huge that houses, not only single-family homes, but sizable apartment buildings would have to be demolished by the hundreds to give them footing. Its anchorages, the masses of concrete in which its cables would be embedded, would be as big as any pyramid built by an Egyptian pharaoh, its roadways wider than the widest roadways built by the Caesars of Rome. To construct those anchorages and to pave those roadways, just the roadways of the bridge proper itself, not the approach roads, would require enough concrete to pave a four-lane highway from New York to Philadelphia, enough to reopen depression-shuttered cement factories from Maine to Mississippi.
卡罗写道，它的引桥将如此巨大——注意，这是卡罗写的，不是我——以至于必须成百上千地拆除房屋（不仅是单户住宅，还包括相当规模的公寓楼）来为其奠基。它的锚碇（也就是用来固定桥梁缆索的大块混凝土）将和埃及法老建造的任何金字塔一样巨大，它的路面将比罗马凯撒建造的最宽的路面还要宽。为了建造这些锚碇并铺设这些路面——仅仅是桥梁本身的路面，还不包括引道——所需的混凝土足以铺就一条从纽约到费城四车道高速公路，其用量足以让大萧条中关门歇业的水泥厂从缅因州一直复工到密西西比州。
To make the girders on which that concrete would be laid, depression-banked furnaces would have to be fired up at no fewer than 50 separate Pennsylvania steel mills. To provide enough lumber for the forms into which that concrete would be poured, an entire forest would have to crash on the Pacific coast on the opposite side of the American continent. It's just like, this is a massive project. It's so huge. It's so like, it's the pyramids. It's the Roman roads.
为了制造铺设这些混凝土所需的钢梁，大萧条中熄火的炼钢炉将不得不重新点燃，涉及宾夕法尼亚州不少于50家独立的钢铁厂。为了提供足够浇筑这些混凝土所需的模板木材，美洲大陆对岸太平洋沿岸的一整片森林都将被砍伐倾倒。这简直是个庞大的工程。它太巨大了。它就像金字塔，就像罗马大道。
It's enormous. And it's really four bridges, which are going to link three boroughs and two islands. There's the Harlem River span that connects Manhattan and Randall's Island, the Bronx Kills span connecting Randall's Island to the Bronx, the Hell Gate span between Ward's Island and Randall's Island. They're basically the same place. I think they filled them in and made it one big thing. Connecting Ward's Island and Queens and the causeway that connects Randall's Island and Ward's Island itself.
它宏伟无比。而且它实际上是四座桥梁，将连接三个区和两个岛屿。其中包括：连接曼哈顿和兰德尔岛（Randall's Island）的哈林河跨海段（Harlem River span），连接兰德尔岛和布朗克斯的布朗克斯基尔跨海段（The Bronx Kills span），连接沃德岛（Ward's Island）和兰德尔岛的地狱门跨海段（Hell Gate span）——它们基本上是同一个地方，我想他们把中间填平了，合成了一个大地方——连接沃德岛和皇后区的跨海段，以及连接兰德尔岛和沃德岛本身的堤道。
This will include the largest vertical lift bridge in the world and one of the largest suspension bridges in the world at that time. And on Randall's Island, there's going to be this cloverleaf exchange where 22 lanes of traffic have to wind around each other, never crossing at the same level. They have to go above and beyond forcing drivers to stop at one, but never more than one toll booth along the way. And Carol calls it the largest traffic machine ever built. It's just this astonishingly sized bridge.
其中将包括当时世界上最大垂直升降桥以及世界最大悬索桥之一。在兰德尔岛上，还将修建一个三叶草形立交桥，多达22个车道的交通在那里交错盘旋，却永远不会在同一平面上相交。它们必须上下错落，迫使司机在一处、但绝不超过一处收费站停车交费。卡罗称其为“有史以来建造的最大交通机器”。这是一座规模令人震惊的大桥。
It's just huge. Yeah. And if you are not from the area, which I am not, and so I'm not sort of intimately familiar with how all these things connect, this section here is like a little jarring. You're like, it does this and this and these things and joins this and stuff.
它实在是太庞大了。是的。如果你不是本地人（我恰好不是，所以我对所有这些地方是怎么连接的并不是那么熟悉），这一部分的阅读会让人觉得有点杂乱无章。你会觉得：它连接了这里、那里、还有这个东西，然后又通向那个地方。
And you're just, just know, I think the big lessons are is that it is a huge project. It's one of the biggest that the world had ever seen. It's linking all these places that had never been linked before. And I think kind of importantly for the rest of the book, this traffic engine funded, you know, with like nickels and quarters
但你只需要知道，我认为其中最重要的教训是：这是一个极其庞大的工程，是世界上有史以来最大的工程之一，它将所有这些此前从未连通的地方紧密结合在了一起。我认为，对于本书接下来的内容而言，一个颇为关键的点在于：这个通过过往车辆的硬币（五分镍币和二十五分硬币）资助运转的交通引擎，将成为罗伯特·摩西从今以后权力的又一个主要支柱。
from people passing through it, is going to be one of the other major pillars of Robert Moses's power from here on out. Yes, and that he will eventually become kind of synonymous with the Triborough Bridge Authority. He has offices all over the city, but the offices on Randall's Island of the Triborough Bridge Authority,
是的，他最终将成为“三区大桥管理局”（Triborough Bridge Authority）的代名词。他在全城各处都设有办公室，但位于兰德尔岛的三区大桥管理局办公室——
that's his headquarters. Roman, I know you'll be delighted when, when they talk about how they had their own flag and their own seal, you know, they were, they're basically like a city within a city and all that, well, all that is going to happen. And so this, this big project and we'll see in, in future episodes, Moses is not just thinking
那才是他的真正总部。罗曼，我知道当听到他们拥有自己的旗帜和自己的印章时，你一定会感到很高兴。他们基本上就像是“城中之国”，所有这些事情都会发生。因此，通过这个宏大的项目，我们将在未来的剧集中看到，摩西不仅仅是在思考——
this is a huge bridge. He's thinking this is a huge lever of power that the Triborough Bridge Authority, which is ostensibly built, ostensibly exists to build this bridge and then go away. To build the bridge and stop. And stop.
“这是一座巨大的桥梁。”他在思考：“这是一个巨大的权力杠杆。”因为三区大桥管理局表面上建立的初衷、表面存在的意义仅仅是为了建造这座桥，然后就功成身退。把桥建好就收手。然后解散。
The key is that it usually stops, but not under Robert Moses. Not under Robert Moses, it doesn't have to stop. But that's all for, we'll get to those future machinations when Carol tells us about them. The point is that in 1934, Moses is, as always,
关键在于，它通常应该就此收手，但在罗伯特·摩西手下却并非如此。在罗伯特·摩西的掌控下，它绝不需要收手。不过，这些都是后话了，等卡罗以后讲到时我们再详细探讨。重点是，在1934年，摩西一如既往地——
seeing this as a way to get his other stuff done too. He's gonna link this up to his parkways. He's going to build new parks on Randall's Island and Ward's Island, even if that means kicking out the city hospital for the feeble-minded and tubercular and the Manhattan State Hospital for the insane. This was, he's so good at finding things
将此视为完成他其他宏伟目标的途径。他要将这座桥与他的林荫大道连接起来，他要在兰德尔岛和沃德岛上修建新的公园，哪怕这意味着要赶走精神病人和结核病人的市属医院，以及曼哈顿精神州立医院。这就是他的过人之处——他太擅长发现那些被低估的事物，然后化腐朽为神奇。
that have been undervalued and then making value out of them. And one of these things is these islands, because until now they've just been a place, even though it's centrally located in the middle of the city, a place just to dump the unwanted, you know. And unfortunately, the plans that Tammany put together for the Triborough Bridge, they're not great. We mentioned already they didn't plan any roads to actually get to the bridge. He
其中之一就是这些岛屿。在此之前，尽管它们地理位置优越、地处市中心正中央，却仅仅是被当作一个用来倾倒城市“废弃人口”的地方。不幸的是，坦慕尼协会为三区大桥制定的规划并不高明。我们之前已经提到过，他们甚至没有规划任何能够真正通往大桥的道路。他——
finds that the Manhattan terminus for the bridge is 25 blocks farther north than it really should be which means that if you go do that you're gonna have to drive kind of 50 unnecessary blocks 25 up and then 25 back again which is like two and a half miles but he learns they did that because William Randolph Hurst one of the most powerful newspaper barons in the city and everyone knows that he was the slight inspiration for Citizen Kane, that he owns some land there that he wanted to sell to the city. And Moses is like, I'm not gonna pick a fight
发现大桥的曼哈顿终点站比实际应该在的位置往北偏了整整25个街区。这意味着如果你按那个规划走，你将不得不白白多开50个街区的冤枉路——往北25个街区，然后再往回开25个街区，这大约是两英里半（约4公里）。但他了解到，他们之所以这么做，是因为威廉·伦道夫·赫斯特（William Randolph Hearst）——这座城市最有权势的报业大亨之一，众所周知他也是《公民凯恩》（Citizen Kane）的原型灵感来源——在那里拥有一些土地，他想把这块地卖给市政府。而摩西的想法则是：“我才不想跟一个拥有一家报社的家伙结怨呢。”所以我们就把它留在那里吧。我们就把终点留在125街。这也是由富人决定的、路线上的又一个弯路，而罗伯特·摩西尽管标榜自己是人民的捍卫者，最终还是接受了这一切。
with a guy who owns newspapers. So we're just gonna leave that there. We're gonna leave that 125th Street. And this is another one of these little jags in the road that were determined by rich people that Robert Moses accepts, you know, despite his character of being the champion of the people. Exactly, when power meets power, power will accommodate power. When power meets not power,
没错，当权势遭遇权势，权势就会对权势作出妥协。而当权势遭遇没有权势的人时——
it will get rid of it. Like for instance, the whole bridge, the original plans called for it to be covered in granite because there's some Tammany guys who own granite quarries. And that means the bridge is going to cost many millions of dollars more than it's supposed to. And they also mentioned, oh, by the way, in the designs, they also, the lanes are too narrow. So where it says eight lanes in this part, it's really only gonna be six lanes on this double deck, 16 lane design. This bridge is, it's not designed properly.
它就会将其彻底铲除。比如，整个大桥最初的规划要求桥身包上花岗岩，因为有几个坦慕尼协会的家伙拥有花岗岩采石场。这意味着大桥的造价将比原本预算多出好几百万美元。而且他们还提到：“哦，顺便说一下，在设计中，车道也太窄了。”所以在这部分被称为八车道的设计中，在这个双层、16车道的规划里，实际上只有六个车道。这座桥的设计根本不合格。
And two years earlier, Moses had looked at these plans and he was like, can we remove the granite? And the engineer on the bridge was a guy who had been a Tammany man since 1886. And he goes, no. And now Moses is boss and he calls him and he says, what's more important, the granite or the excess roads that we should spend the money on? And the guy goes, the granite. And Moses goes, you're fired. So he hires this new engineer,
就在两年前，摩西看这套图纸时曾问过：“我们能把花岗岩去掉吗？”当时大桥的总工程师是一个自1886年起就是坦慕尼协会核心成员的家伙，他回答说：“不行。”现在，摩西成了老板，他把那家伙叫来问道：“到底是花岗岩更重要，还是我们应该把钱花在刀刃上的超额道路更重要？”那家伙回答：“花岗岩更重要。”摩西说：“你被解雇了。”于是他雇用了新工程师——
the Swiss designer of the George Washington bridge. His name is Othmar Herman Ammann, which is my new favorite name in the book. There's so many good names in this book. I've never named anyone to Othmar someday I hope to. And they have this new plan. They're not going to have granite. It's going to be a single deck. There There's gonna be six lanes on the Manhattan arm, eight lanes on the other arms. And the cost of the bridge goes down from a projected $51 million to $30 million. And now there's gonna be a surplus in the budget
乔治·华盛顿大桥（George Washington Bridge）的瑞士设计师。他的名字叫奥特马尔·赫尔曼·阿曼（Othmar Herman Ammann），这成了我在书中最喜欢的名字。这本书里有太多好听的名字了。我以前从没想过给任何人起名叫奥特马尔，但希望有一天我能这么做。他们拿出了全新的规划：不用花岗岩，改用单层结构；曼哈顿一侧设6车道，其他方向设8车道。大桥的造价从预计的5100万美元骤降至3000万美元。现在预算中出现了一笔盈余，
that they can use to build some parkway links as long as they're defined as approach roads. It doesn't matter if the road goes many miles farther as long as it approaches the bridge. Well, that's right. Because the money from the PWA is bridge money. And rightfully, he goes to PWA and says, well, bridge money doesn't matter
他们可以用这笔钱来修建一些林荫大道的连接线，只要这些连接线被定义为引道就行。至于道路向外延伸多少英里并不重要，只要它最终通往大桥。没错，就是这样。因为公共工程署（PWA）下拨的资金是“造桥资金”。所以他理直气壮地去找PWA说：“如果道路无法跟这些桥梁连接起来，造桥资金也就失去意义了。所以，让我们用其中的一部分钱来修建引道吧。”同样的，这又是那种不完全像战争纪念游乐场那样——直接挂个牌子就强行过关的事情。我认为这在某种程度上确实是对理念精神的一种合理解读。有那么一点，我觉得是的。
if roads don't connect to those bridges. So let's use some of that money for approach roads. And again, this is one of those things where it's not quite like the war memorial playgrounds where you just slap a plaque on it and make it work. I think this is legitimately an expansion of the idea in the spirit of the idea. Somewhat, I think so.
他在让这个理念为自己所用。我认为他在让这种精神为自己服务。而且，当没有足够的土地来修建引道时，摩西就自己造地。他在杰克逊高地（Jackson Heights）岸边的水中倾倒沙石来制造土地。书中有一个段落专门讲述了他在125街沿线为了寻找可用土地而不得不做出的那些复杂如魔方般的乾坤大挪移操作。他在当地企业的地契中找到了旧契约，上面写着市政府有权收回部分土地；接着他跟某家企业做交易，承诺只要企业放弃水岸通行权，就为他们修建一条隧道。通过这些手段，他设法从市政府、联邦政府以及管理局那里筹集资金来支付部分费用。他在不仅仅看到“什么地方应该建造”方面是个天才，而且在完成各种交易和安排、确保项目能够真正落地方面更是个天才。不仅关注什么应该在那里，更关注什么能够实现在那里。
He's making the idea work for him. I think he's making the spirit work for him. And when there's not land available for approach roads, Moses makes it. He's dumping sand and stone into the water off Jackson Heights to make land. And there's a section where it's all about these kind of elaborate Rubik's Cube moves he has to do in order to find the land along 125th Street that he can use where he's finding old covenants
他在为自己贯彻这个构想。我认为他在为自己运用这种精神。当没有土地来修建引道时，摩西就自己造地。他在杰克逊海高茨附近的水中倾倒沙石来造地。书中有一个章节专门讲到他必须做出各种复杂的魔方式的腾挪，以便在125th街沿线找到可以利用的土地，他在那里找到了旧的契约
written to the deeds of the businesses there that say the city can take some of the land. And then he's kind of making deals with one business that will build this tunnel if it means you don't have access to the to the water anymore and he manages to kind of a finagle money from the city government the federal government and then the authorities gonna pay for some of it he is he's brilliant at not just seeing what can be built but then making the the deals and the arrangements so that it can be built. So that not just what should be there, but what can be there.
写在当地企业的契约里，上面说城市可以征收部分土地。然后他与某家企业达成协议，如果这意味着你不再拥有通往水域的通道，这家企业就会修建这条隧道，他设法从市政府、联邦政府那里巧妙地筹措资金，然后由管理局来支付一部分费用，他不仅善于看到什么可以建造，而且善于达成交易和作出一系列安排，以便它能够被建造出来。所以，不仅是什么应该在那里，而是什么能够在那里。
And this is kind of a little preview of a chapter we'll see later on where Carol will go into a lot of detail about the different ways Moses cuts down the amount of money that he needs for a project. And finally, by the end, he gets permission to build parks on Randall and Ward's Island. They say, you can build a 10,000 seat stadium. He goes, no, I need a 70,000 seat stadium. And it needs the largest movable outdoor stage
这也是对我们后面将要看到的一个章节的小预告，其中卡罗尔将详细介绍摩西为项目削减所需资金的不同方法。最后，他终于获得了在兰德尔岛和沃德岛修建公园的批准。他们说，你可以建一个1万个座位的体育场。他说，不，我需要一个7万个座位的体育场。而且它需要是世界上最大的可移动户外舞台
in the world. And as we'll see later, this theater gets drastically misused to just to present the kinds of things that Robert Moses thinks people should watch, which is, well, we'll get to that later, but it's, it essentially becomes the private kingdom of, is it Guy Lombardo, I think. And he's like, the labor won't cost the city a thing because the federal government's gonna pay for it. So he convinces the mayor, the governor, kick all the asylum patients off the islands, tear down those buildings, we can do it.
而且正如我们后面将看到的，这个剧院被严重滥用，仅仅用来呈现罗伯特·摩西认为人们应该观看的东西，也就是，嗯，我们稍后再谈这个，但它，它基本上变成了盖伊·隆巴多的私人王国，我想是的。他说，这些劳动力不会花城市一分钱，因为联邦政府会为此买单。于是他说服了市长、州长，把所有精神病院的病人赶出这些岛屿，拆掉那些建筑，我们就能做到。
But while he's doing all this reconstruction for positive reasons, defensible reasons, he has one thing at the end of the chapter that he does out of a sense of pure hatred and spite. Just for hatred of Jimmy Walker, he says, I control Central Park now, I'm gonna tear down the Central Park Casino. And there is no financial sense in spite, just for hatred of Jimmy Walker. He says, I control Central Park now. I'm going to tear down the Central Park casino and there is no financial sense in this.
但在他出于积极的、站得住脚的原因进行所有这些重建的同时，他在这一章的结尾做了一件出于纯粹的恨意和恶意的事情。仅仅出于对吉米·沃克的恨，他说，我现在控制了中央公园，我要拆掉中央公园赌场。这种恶意没有任何财务意义，仅仅是出于对吉米·沃克的恨。他说，我现在控制了中央公园。我要拆掉中央公园赌场，这在财务上没有任何意义。
It's still a functioning business that could give the city money. There's no aesthetic sense in it. It's a beautiful building. It was lavishly and lovingly made. It's a historic piece of the city. There's a community sense to keep it up. It is something that the community could use,
它仍然是一个正常运营的商业场所，可以为城市带来资金。这没有任何美学意义。这是一座美丽的建筑。它是经过奢华而深情的打造的。它是这座城市的一个历史遗迹。维护它具有社区意义。它是社区可以利用的东西，
but he refuses to let it stand because he just hates Walker. He hated the way Walker treated Al Smith. And this causes the first kind of glimmers of defection from these reformers. And they realized that this bill that Moses wrote that they supported, it gives him the power to do anything to any park, anything without oversight,
但他拒绝让它保留，因为他就是恨沃克。他恨沃克对待艾尔·史密斯的方式。这引起了这些改革派中最初的一些倒戈迹象。他们意识到，摩西起草并得到他们支持的这个法案，赋予了他对任何公园做任何事情的权力，任何事情都无需监督，
without reason. He can destroy anything. This one judge, he goes, if he goes, he puts an injunction in place and he goes, if he can tear down this, he can tear down the obelisk in Central Park. You know, this Egyptian obelisk that is thousands of years old that sits outside the Metropolitan Museum. And that gets appealed to the appellate court
无需理由。他可以摧毁一切。有一次，一个法官下达了一道禁令，他说，如果他能拆掉这个，他就能拆掉中央公园的方尖碑。你知道，那座拥有数千年历史、坐落在纽约大都会艺术博物馆外面的埃及方尖碑。这起案件被上诉到上诉法院，
and the appellate court is like, we don't like it, but the way this law is written, yeah, he can tear that down. He can do whatever he wants. And they start to realize, oh, all this stuff that we did because we trusted him, he can do things that we did not intend for him to do. And they tear down the casino and except for some stained glass windows that get repurposed in a police station, it's just gone. It's gone forever. We'll never see it. And I can't
上诉法院的态度是，我们不喜欢这样，但按照这部法律的字面编写方式，是的，他确实可以拆掉它。他可以为所欲为。他们开始意识到，哦，我们因为信任他而做的所有这些事情，他可以做出我们从未打算让他做的事情。他们拆除了赌场，除了少数几块被重新利用在警察局里的彩色玻璃窗外，它就这样消失了。它永远消失了。我们再也见不到它了。而且我不禁
help but wondering if it was still standing, maybe my dad would have proposed to my mom there instead of Tavern on the Green. We'll never know. That's one of those what ifs folks, the sliding doors moment, alternate universe. And this is really true, Spike, because it's really kind of odd because Jimmy Walker has left this stage and gone to Europe with his mistress at this point. He's a non-entity, yeah.
在想，如果它还立在那里，也许我爸爸就会在那里向我妈妈求婚，而不是在绿茵酒馆。我们永远不会知道了。这就是那种“如果当初”的情况，朋友们，那是“滑动门”的时刻，平行的宇宙。斯派克，这确实是真的，因为这真的很诡异，因为吉米·沃克此时已经离开了这个舞台，和他的情妇去了欧洲。他已经是个无名小卒了，对吧。
And he's just associated with this casino because it was his sort of personal playground. There's no reason why you can't scrub it of these associations and make it into something that would work for the city. You could make it something wholesome or whatever, but he just, this symbol, he wants it erased and eradicated and he does it. And as soon as the appellate court rules, he just, before anyone else can appeal to another higher level of court, he just knocks the thing down.
他只是和这个赌场联系在一起，因为这是他个人的某种游乐场。没有理由说你不能抹去这些联系，把它改造成对这个城市有用的东西。你可以把它做成一个健康的地方什么的，但他就是，这个符号，他希望它被抹去和根除，他也确实这么做了。而一旦上诉法院作出裁决，就在其他人能够向更高一级法院上诉之前，他直接就把这东西给砸了。
He just, yeah, he just destroys it. And it's the lesson from this that he learns is I can do whatever I want. I know, I know this in the parks, I'm a king and it's going to eventually lead in a, in a later episode. He will attempt to destroy a much more historic structure in New York City that has much more meaning to it. Fully knowing that the loss that he wrote says he can do it. And if no one else is gonna stop him
他就是，是的，他直接把它毁了。他从中得到的教训是，我能做我想做的事。我知道，我知道我在公园里就是个国王，这最终将导致在后面的某一集中，他将试图摧毁纽约市一座具有更多历史意义、更有内涵的建筑。完全清楚他自己写的法律说他可以这么做。如果没有其他人通过其他权力杠杆阻止他，
through the other levers of power, he's unstoppable. And so it's this first moment, we see Robert Moses started making the bad guy turn in our last episode. He is now kind of a bad guy working for exciting and good purposes. He's building all these parks. He's making this big bridge, but he's gonna get more and more bad guy working for exciting and good purposes. He's building all these parks. He's making this big bridge,
他是不可阻挡的。所以这是最初的时刻，我们在上一集中看到罗伯特·摩西开始走向反派。他现在有点像一个为了激动人心和崇高的目的而工作的反派。他在修建所有这些公园。他在建造这座大桥，但从这一点开始，他将越来越像一个为了激动人心和崇高的目的而工作的反派。他在修建所有这些公园。他在建造这座大桥，
but he's gonna get more and more bad guy from this point on. SIMON The real thing that changes for him is that he's gonna be focused on things that are not just parks anymore, and it's gonna center more on roads, and then it's gonna center more on housing, and all of a sudden these reformers are very much not going to like this man. GEOFF That turns out when the Parks Man turns his godlike eye to things that are not parks,
但从这一点开始，他将变得越来越像个反派。西蒙：对他的改变真正起作用的是，他将不再仅仅专注于公园，而是将重心更多地转向道路，然后更多地转向住房，突然之间，这些改革派将非常不喜欢这个人。杰夫：事实证明，当这位“公园之神”把目光投向公园以外的事物时，
they're like, oh, hold on a second. Maybe we shouldn't have given the best Bill Drafter in Albany the ability to get whatever he wants. Hold on a second. That's right. But we will cover that on the next episode. But on this episode, we're going to now talk to Representative Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez about what it means to get things done and grind people under her heel Be so funny if we talk to her and she's like yes, that's what you have to do. You've got to crush people Wow, this is not what we expected Our special guest on this episode of the 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker is Representative Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez. She has served the 14th New York Congressional District since 2019, taking office at the
他们的反应是，哦，等等一下。也许我们根本不应该赋予奥尔巴尼最优秀的法案起草人想得到什么就能得到什么的权力。等等一下。没错。但我们会在下一集里讨论这个。但在这一集中，我们将采访众议院议员亚历山大·奥卡西奥-科尔特斯，聊聊把事情办成并将人们踩在脚下意味着什么。如果我们采访她时，她微笑着说，是的，这就是你必须做的，你必须粉碎人们，那该多有趣啊。哇，这可不是我们所预期的。在本期《权力的经纪人》99%隐形剖析节目中，我们的特邀嘉宾是众议院议员亚历山大·奥卡西奥-科尔特斯。自2019年以来，她一直担任纽约州第14国会选区的议员，上任时年仅
age of 29, making her the youngest woman to serve in the U.S. Congress. Years ago, in her first term, someone asked her what she did on the train from New York to D.C. and she said that, among other things, she listened to 99% Invisible. So I'm delighted that we get to have her on the show. Representative Ocasio-Cortez, what is your relationship with Robert Moses and this book, The Power Broker? Well, you know, in some ways, I actually think if it wasn't for Robert Moses, I probably
29岁，这使她成为美国国会历史上最年轻的女议员。多年前，在她任职的第一任期内，有人问她在从纽约到华盛顿的火车上做些什么，她说其中一件事就是听《99%隐形》。所以我很高兴能请她来到节目中。奥卡西奥-科尔特斯议员，你和罗伯特·摩西以及这本书《权力的经纪人》有什么渊源吗？嗯，你知道，从某种程度上讲，我甚至觉得如果不是罗伯特·摩西，我可能
wouldn't have run for Congress. You know, my dad grew up when the Bronx was burning, And he actually became an architect as a direct inspiration of, and in a lot of ways, he was inspired by all this calamity around him. He saw all of these buildings that were burning down, the arson that was happening at a very young age, at six years old. at a very young age, at six years old, he decided that he saw all of these buildings tumbling down and he wanted to be one of the people who built them back up. And that's how he decided to become an architect. That's how he remained committed to staying in the Bronx. It was very rare for people, especially from the Bronx, especially Latinos, especially Puerto Rican at that time, to get any sort of higher ed degree in that era, but particularly
都不会竞选国会议员。你知道，我爸爸是在布朗克斯区大火肆虐的年代长大的，他之所以成为一名建筑师，直接受到了周围所有灾难的启发。他在很小的时候——六岁时——就看到了所有这些建筑在倒塌，看到了正在发生的纵火案。在很小的时候，六岁的时候，他决定自己看到了所有这些建筑倒塌，他想成为那些把它们重建起来的人之一。这就是他决定成为建筑师的原因。这也是他坚守在布朗克斯区的动力。在那个时代，人们，尤其是来自布朗克斯区的人，尤其是拉丁裔，尤其是当时的波多黎各人，获得任何形式的高等教育学位都非常罕见，更不用说
to become an architect. And so I grew up with a very unique and distinct perspective about why this happened and also the community response to it and kind of like this alternative perspective of what was happening to the people on the ground while the cross Bronx Expressway was constructed, while landlords were kind of setting fire to their own buildings and all of the fallout and social fallout that that happened as a result of civil engineering and urban design decisions. That's so fascinating. I feel like I was very late to this, like in terms of like incorporating this into my worldview, but
成为一名建筑师了。因此，我在成长过程中拥有一个非常独特和鲜明的视角，关于为什么会发生这一切，以及社区对此的反应；还有一种替代视角，即当跨布朗克斯高速公路修建时，当房东们开始纵火焚烧自己的房屋时，身处现场的人们到底经历了什么，以及城市工程和城市设计决策所带来的所有余波和社会影响。这太迷人了。我觉得我接触到这些东西的时间很晚，我是指将这些纳入我的世界观的时间，但
you had it so young. What did that do to you? I think it really was a big source of the commitment to community in my family, actually. It's interesting because I didn't grow up in a particularly, like explicitly political family, I'd say. Like they didn't strongly identify as Democrats or Republicans. I mean, they always tended to vote for Democrats, were in New York. But it was a family that was very rooted in community and the impact of these decisions. And so, I think I grew up a lot with that idea of the decisions around us are made by people. And it's really important for us to not just pay attention to it, but that we can have a hand in it.
你这么年轻就有了这种认知。这对你有什么影响？我觉得这实际上是我家族对社区承诺的一个巨大源泉。有趣的是，我并没有在一个特别的、明确具有政治色彩的家庭中长大，我是这么认为的。比如他们并没有强烈地把自己归为民主党人或共和党人。我的意思是，他们总是倾向于投票给民主党，毕竟在纽约嘛。但这是一个深深植根于社区以及这些决策影响的家庭。所以，我想我在成长过程中，很大程度上带着这样一种理念：我们周围的决策是由人做出的。不仅要去关注这一点非常重要，而且我们也能参与其中。
And you know, sometimes it wasn't, most of the times it wasn't even through an explicit political process. It was largely done through organizing communities around us and in much less formal ways, getting someone a job down the street, checking in on people, seeing if we could get them a good union city job. And that was a big part of what shaped my upbringing. And when did this idea that there were people
而且你知道，有时这甚至不是，大多数时候甚至不是通过明确的政治程序完成的。它很大程度上是通过将我们周围的社区组织起来，以一种远不那么正式的方式来完成的——比如帮街角的人找工作，关心他人，看看能不能帮他们找一份有工会保障的市政工作。这在很大程度上塑造了我的成长经历。那么，这种“存在着这样一群人，
making these decisions that were possibly or probably making lives worse by those decisions, when did that coalesce into the name Robert Moses in your consciousness? That I think happened maybe a little bit later on. I wouldn't be surprised if I had heard the name growing up, but it probably kind of washed over. I think, like, maybe in my late teens or early 20s is when I started to really connect those
他们做出的这些决策可能或正在让人们的生活变得更糟”的想法，是什么时候在你的意识中与“罗伯特·摩西”这个名字结合在一起的呢？我想这大概要稍微晚一点。如果说我在成长过程中听到过这个名字，我也不会感到惊讶，但它可能只是从我耳边掠过了。我想，大概是在我十几岁快结束或二十岁出头的时候，我才开始真正更明确地把这些点串联起来，
dots more explicitly, because that's when I started really asking my dad these stories, because he would always talk about this time, about why the buildings were going down, and the arsons that were happening. And I started to dig a lot more into why that time happened, and it came to really the construction of the Cross Bronx Expressway. When Reagan came and said that the South Bronx looked like Dresden after World War II. And then I kind of dug into why the Cross Bronx and how did that happen.
因为那时我开始真正向我父亲打听这些故事，因为他总是谈论那个时代，谈论建筑为什么会倒塌，以及当时发生的纵火案。我开始深入挖掘为什么那个时代会发生这些事，最终发现这其实真的归咎于跨布朗克斯高速公路的修建。当时里根来到这里，说南布朗克斯看起来就像二战后的德累斯顿一样。然后我顺藤摸瓜，去了解为什么会有跨布朗克斯，以及这一切是如何发生的。
And I think that's where Robert Moses came into the picture of my consciousness. So your district includes so many Robert Moses projects, the Triborough Bridge, the Bronx Whitestone Bridge, the Throgsnex Bridge, the Cross Bronx Expressway. What is it like living in a district shaped by so many Moses productions? it of entering houses of faith, where, you know, you'll walk into this cathedral and every design decision is to make it feel liberatory and expansive and soaring. And I think one of the things that I really did not appreciate until I went to college and lived in a different city is how much the civic and urban
我想这就是罗伯特·摩西进入我意识画面的时刻。所以你的选区包含了如此多的罗伯特·摩西的项目，三区大桥、布朗克斯怀特斯通大桥、索格斯内克斯大桥、跨布朗克斯高速公路。生活在一个由如此多摩西作品塑造的选区里是什么感觉？这有点像进入一座座信仰殿堂，你知道，当你走进大教堂时，每一个设计决策都旨在让你感到解放、开阔和高耸。我觉得直到我上大学并去了一个不同的城市生活，我才真正领悟到的一件事是，公民和城市
planning really affects the psyche of the communities that occupy and have to endure these decisions. Because until you experience something else, you're just living in it. Like you think it's just life, and there is a psychic weight to living in communities that are designed to be disconnected. There, it affects your social life. My neighborhood that I'm from in the Bronx,
规划对这些身处其中并不得不忍受这些决策的社区的心理产生了多么大的影响。因为在体验别的东西之前，你只是身在其中。就像你以为这就是生活本身，而生活在被设计成彼此隔绝的社区里，确实有一种心理上的重压。这会影响你的社交生活。我来自布朗克斯的社区，
in Parkchester, we have some of the longest commutes in all of New York City. And it is a commute not just to work, it is a commute to do anything. It is a commute to connect socially. It is a commute to connect spiritually if you are part of a faith community. It is a commute to go get your groceries. And so, these decisions are designed to disconnect, disempower, and isolate people. And when you layer that with a lot of Robert Moses's racist intent, to very much do so to a very specific kind of people. Black, brown, low income, poor, etc.
在帕克斯切斯特（Parkchester），我们拥有整个纽约市最长的通勤时间之一。这不仅仅是上班的通勤，这是做任何事情的通勤。这是社交连接的通勤。如果你属于某种信仰社区，这是精神连接的通勤。这是去买杂货的通勤。因此，这些决策旨在将人们断开连接、剥夺赋权并使其孤立。当你把这一点与罗伯特·摩西针对某种特定人群的种族主义意图叠加在一起时——比如黑人、棕色人种、低收入人群、穷人等，
poor, etc. And when you contrast that with other neighborhoods or other cities, you can really see how it actually builds in organizing challenges to communities who actually want to empower themselves politically. It makes sense that it would have that kind of psychic toll that his stated reason is people need to get through this area much faster. And what that means is it's an area that you're not meant to go to or to stay in. Its only value is as a way to get from one place to another. And I was on the Cross Bronx Expressway just a few weeks ago and was thinking about looking from side to side on it, just thinking about like, yeah, this is,
穷人等等。当你把它与其他社区或城市进行对比时，你真的能看到它实际上是如何给那些真正想要在政治上赋权自己的社区制造组织障碍的。这就说得通了，它会带来那种心理负担。他陈述的理由是，人们需要更快地穿过这个区域。而这意味着，这是一个你不需要去、也不需要留下来地方。它唯一的价值就是作为从一个地方到另一个地方的通道。几周前我正好在跨布朗克斯高速公路，当时看着公路两边，心里就在想，是的，
to walk from that building to that building should take a couple of minutes, but there's this enormous, there's this enormous road, there's this cut going right between the two, and what a, like an almost biblical sized division that is between two places. You were saying that it's a real, it gets in the way of organizing things like that.
从那栋建筑走到那栋建筑本该只需几分钟，但中间却有这么一条巨大的、这么一条深深切断两者的道路，这在两个地方之间造成了一条几乎具有《圣经》般规模的巨大鸿沟。你刚才说这确实妨碍了诸如此类的组织工作。
How do you get around something like that to maintain a life that might have to be on opposite sides of this enormous, almost like a moat, cutting off two sections from each other? Well, it still persists today. You know, I think there are things we can do, but there's a certain aspect to it that there's no getting around it. This is a gash through an enormous community, not just in New York City, but also one of the more famed communities in the United States. And it is designed to separate. You know, it was a couple, I think it was like a year or two ago, the New York Times had come out with this New York City visual map and what it kind of pegged what people called certain neighborhoods in the city.
你如何绕过这样的障碍，来维持一种生活，而这种生活可能不得不在这个巨大的、几乎像护城河一样将两个部分隔开的庞然大物的两侧展开？好吧，这种情况在今天依然存在。你知道，我认为有些事情我们可以做，但它在某种程度上是无法绕过的。这是在庞大社区中间割开的一道伤口，不仅在纽约市，也是美国更著名的社区之一。而且它就是为了分隔而设计的。你知道，大约是一两年前，纽约市《纽约时报》曾推出过一张纽约市视觉地图，上面标注了人们如何称呼城市中的某些社区。
Like, what is Greenwich Village? You know, what counts as as Bed-Stuy? And one of the interesting responses that I saw is that when you would go to the Bronx, people a lot of times don't, if you live in the Bronx, they don't always call where they live by their neighborhood. They will say like the street that they live on or they'll call it by the boulevard. So like in Hunts Point, a lot of people don't say, I live by Hunts Point. Sometimes they do. But a lot of people will say, I live on Southern Boulevard.
比如，什么是格林威治村？什么算贝德斯蒂？我看到的一个有趣的反应是，当你去布朗克斯时，人们很多时候不会——如果你住在布朗克斯，他们并不总是用他们所在的社区来称呼他们居住的地方。他们会说他们住的街道，或者用大道来称呼。比如在亨茨角（Hunts Point），很多人不说“我住在亨茨角”。有时他们会说。但很多人会说，“我住在南大道”。
Or people will say, I live by East Tremont. And I think that really shows like even today, the culture of the Bronx is very much defined, even in very small ways in how we relate to the infrastructure around us, because so many of these neighborhoods have been artificially cut through. If you take the example of Hunts Point, Hunts Point is on the other side of Longwood, and what goes in the middle, it's Hunts Point, then you kind of have, I believe, like the Bruckner Express way, and then on the other side you have the neighborhood Longwood. But a lot of these neighborhoods have been artificially segmented, and so people don't even sometimes know what to call where they live. And so they've developed these new ways of relating to the built space around them. And so to me, like how you organize around that, it is very challenging and it's unsurprising
或者人们会说，“我住在东特里蒙特附近”。我认为这确实表明，即使在今天，布朗克斯的文化在很大程度上仍然是由我们如何与周围的基础设施建立联系的方式所定义的，哪怕是很小的细节，因为太多这样的社区都被人为地切断了。以亨茨角为例，亨茨角在朗伍德（Longwood）的另一边，中间夹着什么呢？先是亨茨角，然后大概有——我相信是布鲁克纳高速公路——然后在另一边则是朗伍德社区。但许多这样的社区都被人为地分割了，以至于人们有时甚至不知道该如何称呼自己居住的地方。因此，他们发展出了与周围建筑空间建立联系的全新方式。所以对我来说，如何围绕这一点进行组织，是非常具有挑战性的，而且毫不意外的是，
that now the cross-Bronx itself has become a unifying target of activism in the Bronx. And that is actually the thing that has separated us for decades is now the thing that is starting to unite us in order to build a movement around capping the cross Bronx, around environmental justice activism, and many, many other topics as well. So in a way, you could say Robert Moses is a real hero by giving them something to unite around, finally. He made it happen. In a way. So in the book, The Power Broker, Robert Caro gives, you know, he explains both Robert Moses and Governor Al Smith
现在跨布朗克斯本身已经成为了布朗克斯行动主义的一个统一目标。曾经将我们分离开数十年的事物，现在实际上正在开始联合我们，以围绕给跨布朗克斯加盖帽、环境正义行动主义以及许多其他话题建立一场运动。所以从某种程度上可以说，罗伯特·摩西是一个真正的英雄，因为他终于给了他们一个团结在一起的理由。他促成了这一切。从某种程度上说。所以在《权力的经纪人》这本书中，罗伯特·卡罗讲述了罗伯特·摩西和阿尔·史密斯州长
coming to Albany, studying really hard, learning the way the government works, learning how to get things done. And when we spoke with Jamal Bowie in our second episode, he expressed his sort of disdain for term limits because he thinks that the first couple of terms, you're just learning how to do things. And what is your experience with that?
来到奥尔巴尼，非常努力地学习，研究政府的运作方式，学习如何把事情办成。我们在第二集采访贾马尔·博伊（Jamal Bouie）时，他表达了对任期限制的某种蔑视，因为他认为在最初的几个任期里，你只是在学习如何做事。你的经历是怎样的？
Like has government, you know, is it the same way? Has it gotten more intuitive? Do you still, what does it take to learn the ropes the way they did, you know, a hundred years ago and today? It's really, really true. I am in my third term here in Congress and it really does take years to truly map out and understand how things work. There is the way that people tell you things work or, you know, on paper, or if you read the law, you know, this agency is responsible for that thing.
政府也是这样的吗？它变得更直观了吗？你仍然——要像他们一百年前和今天这样摸清门路，需要付出什么？这真的、真的是这样。我在国会已经进入第三任期了，要真正摸清和理解事情是如何运作的，确实需要花费数年时间。人们告诉你事情是如何运作的，或者纸面上是这么写的，或者如果你阅读法律，你知道这个机构负责那件事。
But then there's the way that the world actually works. And having to map out, yes, like this agency technically has jurisdiction over that thing, but the people who really have influence that make the call as to whether that agency gives it a green light or a red light is someone else entirely. And one of the most effective political tools that oftentimes the opposition uses in government is the wild goose chase. And a lot of times you spend your first couple years trying to do something and being sent on wild goose chases, trying to track down what is the door that actually opens the possibility that you are seeking. And there is no way around that, I don't think.
但接着还有世界实际运作的方式。你必须理清：是的，这个机构在技术上对那件事有管辖权，但真正有影响力、决定该机构是亮绿灯还是红灯的人完全是另一个人。反对派在政府中经常使用的最有效的政治工具之一就是“愚人式的追逐”（wild goose chase）。很多时候，你的头几年都在试图做成某件事，却被派去进行各种无结果的追寻，试图追踪到真正能开启你所寻求可能性的那扇门究竟在哪里。我认为这是无法避免的。
I think that's just part of a function of not just government, but almost any organization, knowing who the real gatekeepers are, who the real positions of influence are, who are skilled and effective, ideally, and of course, democratically, we want to make sure that there's multi-democratic structures around it. But at the same time, you do want the people in charge to be knowing what they're doing, and having that balance between those two things. And so, you know, for me, I feel like I'm just kind of hitting a place where I'm more effective, I'm able to be more effective than I have been before. And the steps between wanting to do something and getting it done are shortening, not just because of a substance understanding, but because of a social and bureaucratic and governance understanding.
我想这不仅是政府的一个职能，几乎是任何组织的一部分——了解真正的守门人是谁，真正的权力位置在哪里，谁是有能力、有效率的（理想情况下，当然从民主角度出发，我们要确保周围有多重民主结构）。但与此同时，你确实希望掌权者知道他们在做什么，并在两者之间取得平衡。所以，对我来说，我觉得我刚刚开始达到一个更能发挥效用的阶段，我能够比以前发挥更大的作用。从想要做成一件事到真正把事情办成的步骤正在缩短，这不仅仅是因为对实质内容的理解，更是因为对社会、官僚和治理机制的理解。
And the only way to learn that, it sounds like, is to really experience it, is to be actively seeking it and paying attention. It isn't like they swear you in and then they're like, here's the, let me hand you the actual instructions for how these things work. Like, don't show anyone what I just gave you. Like, you kind of you have to put in the work of learning it yourself is what it sounds like. Yeah especially to be honest especially if you're a woman or if you come from a community of color or if you run and you come from a working class background and you don't come from a highly connected political or wealth-based background you have have a different track. You have a steeper learning curve. Mentorship is everything and people from certain backgrounds or even sometimes from certain political spaces or political
听起来，要了解这一点的唯一途径就是真正去亲历它，积极去探寻并保持关注。这可不是那种他们给你举行宣誓就职仪式，然后对你说：“来吧，我把这些事情具体怎么运作的说明书交给你。千万别让任何人看到我刚给你的东西。”你得自己去下功夫学习，听起来是这样的。是的，老实说，尤其是如果你是一名女性，或者你来自有色人种社区，或者你竞选时带着工人阶级背景，而你又没有高度关联的政治或财富背景，你就会走上一条不同的轨道。你的学习曲线更陡峭。导师制就是一切，来自某些背景的人，或者有时甚至是来自某些政治空间或政治
circles have access to a certain degree of an inside track of greater mentorship, greater social esteem that can, you know, get you to move faster. And when you are, it's not just a question of identity, but it is a factor. You know, if you come in as a a woman and you don't know how to golf and you are less relatable to the people who have historically held these positions, you either need to really, really fight to win the trust of those folks or you like need to keep really fighting for longer. And so sometimes it's just a scrap. Yeah. That, that makes sense.
圈子的人，更容易获得某种程度的内部通道、更多的导师指导以及更高的社会声誉，这可以（你知道）让你走得更快。而当你身处其中时，这不仅仅是一个身份的问题，但它确实是一个因素。你知道，如果你以女性身份进入政坛，而你不会打高尔夫球，而且你与那些历史上一直把持这些职位的人共鸣较少，要么你必须非常、非常努力地去赢得那些人的信任，要么你就得为之付出更长时间的奋斗。所以有时这真是一场苦战。是的，这说得通。
It's something that has come up a few times while you're talking about the book is personalities and how much personalities they think and that Al Smith and Robert Moses, Robert Moses so depends on Al Smith's mentorship, but it's because Al Smith just likes being around him. Like they just get along as two guys who like to sing together. Whereas if they, I imagine it's much harder if there's not someone already there who sees that connection in you and is like, well, you remind me of me. So I want to be with you and kind of guide you through this, you know, it's all personality. It's hugely personality driven. And I think sometimes people,
当你们讨论这本书时，有几件事反复出现，那就是个性，以及个性有多重要——阿尔·史密斯和罗伯特·摩西，罗伯特·摩西极其依赖阿尔·史密斯的导师提携，但那是因为阿尔·史密斯就是喜欢跟他在一起。他们俩作为两个喜欢一起唱歌的家伙，就是很合得来。然而我想象，如果没有一个已经在那里、能看出你身上这种特质并且说“嗯，你让我想起了年轻时的自己，所以我想带著你，一路指引你”的人，那要艰难得多，你知道的，这完全是个性使然。它在很大程度上是由个性驱动的。而且我认为有时候人们，
It's hugely personality driven. And I think sometimes people, and I think it's understandable to look at things like this and be like, I can't believe this is how decisions are made in our government. Like, really? Like, just because like some guy, like some other guy or whatever, like that's how this happened. But you think about your own workplace, and this is how things happen happen oftentimes in our own workplace,
它在很大程度上是由个性驱动的。而且我认为有时候人们，并且我觉得可以理解，人们看到这样的事情会想：“我简直不敢相信我们政府的决策就是这样做出来的。真的吗？仅仅因为某个家伙，喜欢另一个家伙什么的——事情就是这样发生的？”但你想想你自己的工作场所，我们自己的工作场所里，事情往往也就是这样发生的，
you know, like it's important to like the people that you are spending huge amounts of time with. I see it, I'm going to be honest, I see it behind closed doors. Yeah, sometimes certain decisions suffer because the person advocating for it is annoying. Like just straight up, like I've seen people empower having to choose and like sometimes this happens where it's like all things are equal and there's a tie breaker, right? And what breaks the tie often, it's not that huge, enormous decisions are just like all made just because of this one thing. But you know, there's a lot of ties and people in positions of power are tiebreakers.
你知道，比如你得喜欢那些和你共度大量时间的人。说实话，我亲眼看到过，我亲眼看到过幕后的这些事。是的，有时某些决策会因为倡导它的人很烦人而受损。就是直截了当地说，我见过人们在拥有决策权时——有时会遇到这样的情况：所有条件都完全一样，需要一个决胜票，对吧？而打破僵局的往往是什么？并不是说所有巨大的、重大的决策都只是因为这单一的事情而做出的。但你知道，有很多平局，而处于权力位置的人就是决胜者。
And a lot of times it comes down to gut. Who do I trust? What, how do I feel about this? What do I think about that person's judgment? Do I understand where they're coming from? And it matters. It matters. It's crazy, but it matters. And likeability matters.
很多时候，这归结于直觉。我信任谁？我对这个有什么感觉？我对那个人的判断怎么看？我理解他们的出发点吗？这很重要。这太重要了。这太疯狂了，但它确实重要。而且好感度也很重要。
This comes up a lot in the book because Robert Moses is like a graduate thesis was pretty much a treatise on why people like Al Smith shouldn't be governor, but they become friends and then he amasses so much power because of the support of Al Smith. And you know, contrary to that, Al Smith, you know, pretty much agreed with Roosevelt on almost everything, his successor, but when the New Deal was enacted, Al Smith was just completely against it, even though it sort of contained all the values he seemed to have when he was governing, just because by that point, he was mad at Roosevelt.
这本书里经常提到这一点，因为罗伯特·摩西的研究生毕业论文几乎就是一篇论述为什么像阿尔·史密斯这样的人不应该当州长的论文，但他们却成了朋友，随后他又借助阿尔·史密斯的鼎力支持积累了极其庞大的权力。与此相反，阿尔·史密斯（你知道的）几乎在所有事情上都同意他的继任者罗斯福的看法，但当“新政”颁布时，阿尔·史密斯却坚决反对，尽管它包含了他在执政时似乎所拥护的所有价值观，仅仅是因为到了那个时候，他生罗斯福的气了。
Like he didn't like Roosevelt, and so he hated the New Deal. And it just is like over and over again, you see this in this book, and it sounds like that really rings true to today as well. Oh yeah. I have seen, I mean, it's terrible. It is awful. And you know, it's not to say that everybody operates in this way, but when we think about governance, there are hundreds of members of Congress, there are thousands of people in positions of decision making power, and some of them are going to be spiteful and like human nature. And I have seen people make terrible or hurtful decisions because they had an axe to grind. And especially kind of, you know, the more you are in places of elevated
就像他不喜欢罗斯福，所以他恨屋及乌地痛恨“新政”一样。你在书中一次又一次地看到这种情况，而且听起来这在今天也同样真实。哦，是的。我见过，我的意思是，这太糟糕了。这太可怕了。你知道，这并不是说所有人都以这种方式行事，但当我们思考治理时，国会有数百名成员，有数千人处于拥有决策权的位置，其中一些人会心胸狭隘，这就是人性。我见过人们因为想公报私仇而做出可怕或伤人的决定。特别是那种，你知道的，你越是处于高处
kind of bird's eye view decision making, the more the decisions can feel smaller, even though the impact is so large. And so, yeah, and especially because a lot of times it's about tradeoffs. It's not just, are you going to do this or not? But it's who is going to get this? And that is a lot easier to facilitate if you are like, people are trying to settle scores and things like that. And to be honest, score settling is also a function of power. If you are a person in a position of power and you continue to allow yourself to be disrespected or crossed or you let people break their word to you and there is actually no consequence, then people learn that they can break their word to this person and it won't be a big deal.
拥有俯视全局的决策权，这些决定有时就会显得越发琐碎，尽管它们带来的影响却是如此巨大。所以，是的，尤其因为很多时候这关乎权衡。这不仅仅是你做还是不做的问题，而是谁能从中得到好处。如果你想要解决宿怨之类的事情，通过这种方式来推进就会容易得多。坦白说，算账也是权力的一种职能。如果你是一个手握权力的人，却一再容忍自己被不尊重、被背叛，或者允许别人对你失信却没有任何后果，那么人们就会吸取教训：原来对这个人失信也无所谓，根本不算什么大事。
And if you want to be effective, you need to be able to hold someone accountable. And so sometimes it's spite, but also sometimes it's just accountability. Like you can't let someone walk all over you if you want to get and secure things for the communities that you advocate for. Well, it's interesting, the way you're putting it, it's such a great way of illustrating kind of the two sides of the idea of power,
如果你想有所作为，你就必须具备追究他人责任的能力。所以有时是出于恶意，但有时也仅仅是为了追究责任。比如，如果你想为你所代表的社区争取和巩固利益，你就不能让别人骑到你头上作威作福。有趣的是，你表达这种观点的方式，简直是阐释权力概念两个侧面的绝佳方式，
that when we think about power and someone wants power, there's a kind of an evil feel to that. But in order to accomplish things, you need a certain amount of power and you need to have other people respect your ability to do it and also trust that you can do it. And so what you're saying is like, sometimes you need to be, it's almost like you need to be slightly petty in order to maintain the foundation that allows you to convince other people that they should do things or you can do things. Yeah. Which is unfortunate, I guess, that it can't just be just like sweet wishes and good arguments
每当我们想到权力、当有人渴望权力时，总会有一种邪恶的感觉。但为了把事情办成，你需要一定程度的权力，你需要别人尊重你办事的能耐，同时也得信任你的能力。所以你的意思是，有时你需要——这几乎就像是你需要表现得稍微有一点点小气，才能维系那个基础，从而说服别人配合你，或者证明你能把事情办成。是的。这就有点不幸了，我想，事情不能仅仅靠美好的愿望和精彩的辩论来让别人站在你这一边。我是这样看的，我认为这是一种正确的正义感。
to get people on your side. I think about it, I think about it as a sense, a proper sense of justice. That's a great way to put it. That's a great way to put it. That's a great way to put it. This is the difference between, you are an effective politician and I'm an effective comedy writer. I'm like yeah, yeah, so it's just power. You're like a mob boss and you're like this is about justice. This is about effective justice. But I think you hit at a very good point, which is, but also it illuminates a certain paradox,
这话说得太妙了。这话说得太妙了。这话说得太妙了。这就是区别所在：你是一个务实的政治家，而我是一个优秀的喜剧编剧。我会说：“行吧，行吧，所以这纯粹就是权力的游戏。”而你的态度则是：“你就像个黑帮老大，而你却说这关乎正义。这关乎有效率的正义。”但我认为你切中了一个非常关键的点，那就是它也揭示了一个特定的悖论，
which is if we all think that only terrible people want power and we adopt that as almost like a cultural cliché or norm, then only terrible people will pursue power because people who want to be good and good hearted then associate power with a negative thing and then people that that does not bother so much will seek it. And so then we get a self-selection bias. And so I think that, you know, it's not about power or not power. It's about how you use it. It's about standards of from for which we pursue it and standards for which we allow ourselves to be held accountable to when power is in the mix. Yeah, it gets so at the heart of, um, of what we've been talking about
如果我们所有人都认为只有可怕的人才会渴望权力，并把这当作一种文化陈词滥调或准则来接受，那么最终就真的只有可怕的人才会去追求权力，因为那些想要成为善良、心怀善意的人会将“权力”与负面事物挂钩，而那些对此不太介意的人则会去追求它。于是我们就会得到一种自我选择的偏见。所以我觉得，问题不在于要不要权力，而在于你如何使用它。在于我们追求权力时所坚守的标准，以及当权力卷入其中时，我们允许自己承担责任的标准。是的，这简直直击核心，
with the book where it feels, Margaret Moses at times he's this very ambitious, you know, public civic person and he has goals that are often positive goals, not, not as much when he's this very ambitious, you know, public civic person and he has goals that are often positive goals. Not as much when he's carving up the Bronx, but earlier in his career when he wants to build the best public beach that there's ever been and he wants to have park space for the Risen. And the way he does accomplishes so much that is by misusing that power and being kind of a monster. And so how do you, you strike me as not a monster. And so, like, how do you exert power to achieve those goals without losing sight of the ideals that brought to those goals in the first place? How do you keep yourself balanced in that way? Well, you know, to me, I think of it as a discipline.
我们一直在讨论这本书的焦点——有时罗伯特·摩西是一个极具野心的、公众眼中的公民人物，他有着往往是积极的目标，虽然他在把布朗克斯切得支离破碎时并非如此，但在他职业生涯的早期，当他想建造有史以来最好的公共海滩、想为底层人民争取公园空间时。他之所以能取得如此巨大的成就，正是通过滥用这种权力并表现得像个怪物来实现的。那么你是怎么——在我的印象中你可不是个怪物。所以，你如何在不失去初心、不背离指引你走向这些目标的理想的情况下，运用权力来实现这些目标？你如何在那种状态下保持自身的平衡呢？嗯，对我来说，我觉得这是一种纪律。
You know, people think about politics in terms of like the food fight that you see in the media, but it is a vocation, actually. And I think we don't talk about the vocation of politics that much in our public discourse. And what we rob ourselves, we don't discuss politics as a vocation, are the skills, disciplines, and kind of lifelong sharpening that is required when you know, efficacy and ethics are, that's the, you know, iron sharpened iron element of this is there are certain tight ropes that you're always walking. And you cannot lean too far in one way or another. If you are trying to be far to kind of answering every single ethical question under the sun in whether you decide if you're going to use this, you know, what printer paper you're going to use in the library, then you're never going to get anything done.
人们从媒体上看到的“食物大战”的角度来思考政治，但它实际上是一种职业。我认为我们在公共话语中并没有对政治这一职业进行足够的探讨。当我们不把政治讨论为一种职业时，我们剥夺了自己的是那些技能、纪律以及终身的磨砺，当效能与伦理交织在一起时——也就是“铁杵磨成针”的元素——这就意味着你总是在走钢丝。你不能偏向任何一方太远。如果你试图在决定是否使用某项东西时，去回答天底下每一个微不足道的伦理问题（比如你在图书馆里要用哪种打印机纸），那么你将一事无成。
You're never going to build the world that we're fighting for. At the same time, if you are too expedient in your decision making and too dismissive in the name of efficacy, then you will end up unrecognizable. And so when I think about the sets of questions that I'm asking myself on a near daily basis, this is often one of it. It's on literally day by day, case by case basis. Should we make this trade off or should we stand and fight is a daily question.
你永远也无法建设出我们正在为之奋斗的世界。与此同时，如果你在决策时过于权宜行事，为了追求效能而过于轻率，那么你最终会变得面目全非。所以每当我思考几乎每天都要问自己的那一系列问题时，这往往就是其中之一。这真的是日复一日、具体情况具体分析的。我们是该做出这种妥协，还是该挺身而出据理力争，这是一个天天都要面对的问题。
It's like, what is the hill worth dying on? And that is something that I think is very often communally and community-based. We do a lot of consensus building. And so it's not just me making a decision, but I will ask and talk to a lot of people and say, you know what, this one, let's just say F it and go for it. And on other times it's like, this is too important to get wrong. That's a huge element,
这就好比是：什么才是值得为之牺牲的阵地？我认为这很大程度上是集体性的、基于社区的。我们做了大量的建立共识的工作。所以这不仅是我个人的决定，我会征求许多人的意见并和他们交谈，然后说：“你知道吗，这一次，管他呢，干吧。”而在其他时候，我们会觉得：“这件事太重要了，绝不能弄砸。”这是一个巨大的要素，
but there are many other strings like that too. Yeah. People who really hate Moses can sort of admire him in two different aspects. One is that Jones Beach is pretty great. Okay. So is Orchard Beach, by the way, which is also in the district. I feel like that's the most amazing thing is,
但除此之外还有许多其他的考量。是的。那些极其痛恨摩西的人，其实也可以在两个不同的层面上赞赏他。一方面是琼斯海滩（Jones Beach）真的很棒。好吧，还有奥查德海滩（Orchard Beach），顺便说一句，它也在我的选区里。我觉得最不可思议的是，
it's like, how do I promote my district? Hold on, my district has the better beach. This is great. Hold on. I'm shrewd. Jones is fun. Exactly. Every opportunity, every opportunity to bring somebody to the Bronx, somebody to the district, yeah.
这就像是：“我该如何宣传我的选区？等等，我的选区有更好的海滩。这太棒了。等等。我很精明。琼斯海滩很好玩。”正是如此。每一个机会，每一个把人带到布朗克斯、带到我选区里的机会，是的。
But the other thing is that he got big things done. Like a lot of people say that there should be some more Robert Moses spirit in things, just the things that I want to do. And you have big ambitious plans for the world. You sort of brought the Green New Deal to people's attention when you join Congress. How do you sort of implement big things?
但另一方面是他办成了大事。就像很多人说的那样，人们应该在做事时多一点罗伯特·摩西的精神，只要是他想做的事。而你对世界也有宏大而雄心勃勃的计划。当你加入国会时，你实际上把“绿色新政”带入了大众的视野。你如何去落实这些宏大的事情？
Because I would imagine those like ethical and efficacy questions get more and more complicated, like exponentially more complicated, the bigger and bigger the idea is, the more land you have to move, the more people you have to get on board, the more like social systems you have to change from the ground up.
因为我想象，随着构想越来越宏大，你必须调动的土地越来越多，需要争取的人越来越多，从底层改变的社会系统越来越复杂，那些伦理和效能的问题就会变得越来越复杂，呈指数级地复杂。
How do you make that stuff happen and dream big? Yeah, I mean, we're also in such a different political landscape in terms of power now than we were back then too. Now private interests, special interests have much more sophisticated lobbies. The power of the state was much stronger back then. There was no CBO score and budget hawks back then.
你是如何把那些事情变成现实并胸怀大志的？对，我的意思是，就权力而言，我们现在所处的政治环境也与当年大不相同了。现在私人利益和特殊利益集团拥有更加成熟的游说力量。当年的国家权力要强大得多。那时候没有什么国会预算办公室（CBO）评分和预算鹰派。
But I think now, what it requires too is, is different techniques and a willingness to experiment. I think a lot of times folks talk about efficacy and they'll say like, you hear this all the time. I hate this phrase in DC. They go, oh, I'm not a show horse. I'm a work horse. And it's like, so you're just giving up the entire mantle of public power and the interest of public power?
但我认为现在，它还需要的是不同的技巧以及尝试的意愿。我觉得很多时候人们谈论效能时，他们会说，你总是能听到这种说法。我讨厌华盛顿特区的这种说辞。他们会说，哦，我不是表演型政客，我是实干家。这就好像是说，你放弃了公共权力的整个使命以及公共权力的利益？
It is a part of being effective. And we can't moralize or consider some avenues as more or less virtuous than others. I think that for me, when it comes to implementation, we rallied enormous public interest and continue to rally enormous public interest. And I think like in DC, that's considered dirty or like low brow. And I just lean into it because I'm like, great, Elaine unto myself. I have no competition.
这是发挥效能的一部分。我们不能进行道德说教，也不能认为某些途径比其他途径更有或更没有美德。我认为对我来说，在执行方面，我们调动了巨大的公众利益，并且继续在调动巨大的公众利益。我觉得在华盛顿特区，这被认为是肮脏的或低俗的。而我只是顺应它，因为我想，太好了，这正合我意。我没有任何竞争对手。
Like, I'm from the Bronx, I don't care. I don't care about like if it's high brow or low brow, like it's there, I'm gonna use it. But then on top of that, okay, then you hit the institutional power. This will never get passed, you know. I pissed off all of the gatekeepers and ring holders and all that, and it gets to a point where then they just don't want to move anything out of spite, right? Like you didn't kiss the ring, you didn't do the proper things,
就像我来自布朗克斯区一样，我不在乎。我不在乎这是阳春白雪还是下里巴人，既然它摆在那儿，我就要利用它。但不仅如此，好吧，接着你就会撞上体制权力。你知道的，这永远通不过。我惹恼了所有的守门人、权柄掌握者以及诸如此类的人，事情发展到一定程度，他们就会仅仅出于怨恨而不想推动任何进展，对吧？就像你没有向权势低头，你没有做那些规矩的事情，
so like we're not gonna move it. And that was, I think, the story of those early days. And so then I kind of look around and I say, okay, what other levers can I use? I don't need to pass this thing, to do the thing, actually, because it's passed in the public consciousness. And so what I started to do was to look for these small ways and unnoticed ways. And so I started to turn to how do I do things without my name being on it and without Green New Deal being on it, but it actually being a Green New Deal project.
所以我们就不打算推进它。我认为这就是早期那些日子的写照。因此，我环顾四周然后心想，好吧，我还能利用哪些其他杠杆？实际上，我不需要通过这个法案来办成这件事，因为它已经在公众意识中通过了。所以我开始做的是，寻找这些微小的、不引人注意的途径。于是我开始转向，如何在不把我的名字挂在上面、不把“绿色新政”挂在上面的情况下做事情，但它实际上就是一个“绿色新政”项目。
And so my next step was that I started to marshal community project funds. And so in the last couple of years, for the first time in over a decade, Congress started to renew the practice of community-funded projects by members of Congress. And so I said, how can I make a Green New Deal project in my community? And then also, how can I contact the, you know, hundred or so other co-sponsors of the Green New Deal and get them to build Green New Deal projects in their communities? And we won't put Green New Deal in the text, but it will meet all of the standards that it creates good union jobs, that it focuses on underserved communities, and that it helps us decarbonize our economy in 10 years. And so,
所以我的下一步是，我开始筹集社区项目资金。因此在过去几年里，十多年来首次，国会议员们重新开始了由国会议员资助社区项目的做法。所以我说，我如何在我的社区里打造一个“绿色新政”项目？然后还有，我如何联系其他大约一百位“绿色新政”的共同提案人，让他们也在自己的社区里建设“绿色新政”项目？我们不会把“绿色新政”写进条文里，但它将符合创造良好的工会工作岗位、关注服务不足的社区，以及在10年内帮助我们实现经济去碳化的所有标准。所以，
you know, slowly but surely, one of the things that I did, my project in my first cycle was we went to Throgs Neck, right near the Throgs Neck Bridge built by Robert Moses. And I went to SUNY Maritime College, which is one of the only public merchant marine academies that we have in the United States. That's the one I think we talked about earlier in the episode where Franklin Roosevelt wanted it so badly and Robert Moses would not let him have it until Roosevelt was leaving to become president. Yes. Clash of worlds, yeah.
你知道的，循序渐进地，我所做的事情之一，我在第一个周期中的项目是我们去了瑟奇内克，就在罗伯特·摩西修建的瑟奇内克大桥附近。我去了纽约州立海事学院，这是美国仅有的公立商船学院之一。这就是我们在本集节目早些时候谈到的那个，富兰克林·罗斯福非常渴望得到它，而罗伯特·摩西直到罗斯福卸任去当总统前都不肯让给他。是的。世界的碰撞，对吧。
And so we went to Maritime College and we said we would like to fund a training program where we train folks here to build the underwater pylons that are good union jobs for offshore wind. And the Merchant Marine Academy said, SUNY Maritime said, sounds great, let's do it. We built an entire facility. People go, you got electricians putting on scuba gear and diving into pools, learning how to do electrical work way out in the ocean. And you've got simulators where people are learning how to actually navigate these ships
所以我们去了海事学院，我们说我们想要资助一个培训项目，在这里培训人们建造水下桥墩，这些是海上风电的良好工会工作岗位。海事学院说，听起来不错，我们干吧。我们建造了整个设施。人们会看到，电工们穿上水肺装备潜入水池，学习如何在远海进行电气作业。你还有模拟器，人们在上面学习如何真正驾驶这些船只
through offshore wind farms. And we're training really good union jobs for people in the Bronx to access in order to access jobs and have jobs that help us decarbonize our economy. None of that, none of the people in power knew what I was up to when we were doing that. Not one. That first cycle, we authorized 60 plus such projects across the United States. No one's hearing about it, no one knows about it, and that's all the better for me. Because the more they know about it,
穿过海上风电场。我们在为布朗克斯区的人们培训真正好的工会工作，让他们能够获得这些工作，并拥有能帮助我们经济去碳化的工作。当我们做这些事情的时候，掌权者中没有一个人知道我在搞什么名堂。一个也没有。在第一个周期里，我们在全美授权了60多个这样的项目。没有人听到风声，没有人知道，这对我来说再好不过了。因为他们知道得越多，
the more other people are going to try to block it. And so I did that very quietly because there were too many axes to grind at the time that I didn't want to imperil the goal. And so sometimes being really big and out there is to our advantage and sometimes it's not. But it's not in either or universal application. It's about understanding and having the discernment of when you use what tools. And that takes time. That takes time and practice to develop. Yeah, yeah.
就会有越多的人试图阻止它。所以我非常低调地做了这件事，因为当时有太多的个人恩怨需要处理，而我不想危及目标。因此，有时大张旗鼓、抛头露面是对我们有利的，有时则不然。但这并不是非此即彼的普遍规律。关键在于理解并具备辨别力，知道在什么时候使用什么工具。这需要时间。这需要时间和实践来培养。对，对。
You see that happening with Robert Moses in the book too. Like he's trying to figure out like how much, how much credit do you give the boss upstairs to get things done? How much do you take on your own so that when the boss gets mad at you, the public rallies to your support. Um, it's, it's, it's fascinating how universal this is and it totally makes sense. Yeah.
你在书中也能看到罗伯特·摩西身上发生这种情况。就像他在琢磨，为了把事情办成，你该给楼上的老板记多少功劳？你自己要揽下多少，这样当老板对你发火时，公众才会团结起来支持你。嗯，这，这，这真是太神奇了，这种现象是如此普遍，而且完全说得通。对。
We, it's like with organizations or sometimes you're frustrated at work and it's like, uh, you know, this, the personality stuff, But also, humans are a medium, and we would love for it to be just like math or science, but it's not because we also need to weigh costs and benefits that are not always immediately apparent. And I think sometimes that's the part of the social science of decision-making. Yeah. So also in this section of the book that you're the episode that you're gonna be on is the introduction of Fiorello LaGuardia who is your predecessor in your district, not your immediate predecessor. There were
我们，这就好比在组织里，或者有时你在工作中感到沮丧，就觉得，呃，你知道的，这些个性方面的东西，但同时，人类也是一种媒介，我们希望它能像数学或科学一样简单，但事实并非如此，因为我们还需要权衡那些并不总是立竿见影的成本和效益。我认为有时这就是决策社会科学的一部分。是的。所以在书中的这一部分里，也就是你将要参与的那一集，介绍了菲奥雷洛·拉瓜迪亚，他是你所在选区的你的前任，但不是你的直接前任。在他和你之间有
a number of predecessors between him and you. My ancestor. Yes, your ancestral predecessor. How does LaGuardia loom in your consciousness growing up and your consciousness in this job? You know, I think LaGuardia, while he's not as large of a looming figure as Moses is, I think he's also an example of someone that marshaled the public. And that is in contrast to Moses, who was much more of an internal operator. And it shows how both of these kinds of power can be wielded and also that it's not necessarily an either or decision either. And that a lot of times people kind of sh into both, then you can really clear a lot of road, if you will.
好几位前任。我的前辈。是的，你的前辈先贤。拉瓜迪亚在你的成长记忆中以及你从事这份工作的意识中占据着怎样的分量？你知道的，我认为拉瓜迪亚虽然不像摩西那样是一个极其庞大的压迫性身影，但我觉得他也是一个动员公众的榜样。这与摩西形成了鲜明对比，摩西更多是一个内部操盘手。这也展示了这两种权力可以如何被运用，同时也说明这不一定是一个非此即彼的决定。而且很多时候，人们将两者结合起来，你确实可以扫清很多道路，如果你愿意的话。
Or I should say, subway tracks. Yeah, yeah. We're all about mass transit. Express! We're not taking the local. We can make the express from one place to another. But you're right, we see that in Moses and LaGuardia working together where Moses is very much the backstage operator and LaGuardia is the one who specializes seemingly in appearing publicly everywhere in the city every day at all times. And even when Moses before that is working with Governor Al Smith, where he's the one behind the scenes and Governor Al Smith is the one who's out in public making the case for things and rallying people to it, that they are, they're such complimentary modes of power. And I guess if you can have two people who partner in that way, they can, you know, those are some of the times that
或者我应该说，地铁轨道。对，对。我们全力关注公共交通。快车！我们不坐慢车。我们可以开通从一个地方到另一个地方的快车。但你说得对，我们在摩西和拉瓜迪亚的合作中看到了这一点，摩西非常像幕后操盘手，而拉瓜迪亚则似乎专门在全城的每个地方、每时每刻都公开露面。甚至在此之前，摩西与阿尔·史密斯州长合作时，他是幕后主使，而阿尔·史密斯州长则是公开阐述观点并将人们团结在周围的人，他们是如此互补的权力模式。我想如果你能有这样合作的两个人，他们就能，你知道的，这就是为什么有时候
Moses is able to accomplish so many of his better, kind of bigger projects, you know, before he goes into the darker side and he's just like, well, why should we have people in the city when we can just have roads in the city? We can just go through it all the time. Do you find that something that, something that's a method that you're thinking about, where it's like, who can I partner with on this thing? Who's someone who can take this aspect of a project and I'll take this aspect so we can get it, we can, we can handle it in different ways to get it finished. Yeah, absolutely. You can't accomplish anything without public will and public
摩西能够完成那么多他那些较好、规模较大的项目，你知道的，在他陷入黑暗面并开始觉得，既然我们可以在城市里修建道路，为什么还要在城市里留着人呢？我们可以一直开车穿过它。你觉得这也是一种方法，一种你在考虑的方法吗，比如：我能和谁在这件事上合作？谁能承担项目的这个方面，而我承担那个方面，这样我们就能以不同的方式来处理它以完成任务？对，绝对是这样。如果没有公众的意愿和公众
sentiment. It's, you know, there are some things that you can, but it's going to take a lot longer. And when you have public support for something, for better or worse, by the way, there are entire industries that are built around influencing public sentiment. And sometimes we see that even today in our politics where there's some issue or there is something that has sometimes captured the public sentiment
情绪，你什么也做不成。你知道的，有些事情你可以做到，但会花费更长的时间。当某事获得公众支持时，不论好坏，顺便说一句，整个行业都是围绕着影响公众情绪而建立的。有时我们甚至在今天的政治中看到这一点，某个议题或某种事物有时捕获了公众情绪，
and it actually doesn't line up with public health data at all. It doesn't line up with facts on the ground at all. But if people just, if the vibe just gets, really like if the vibe just gets contagious and everyone just starts feeling a certain way, even if it's completely divorced from data, reality, what we're seeing. There are times when people just feel like crime is up when crime is actually down. I think that's a classic example. And it happens, I'm not even talking about just present times, it's happened throughout history and it is a very effective political tool. And so making sure that you have that public sentiment is important even if it's
而它实际上与公共健康数据完全不符。它与地面的事实完全不符。但如果人们只是，如果这种氛围变得，真的就像氛围变得具有传染性，每个人都开始产生某种特定的感觉，即使它完全脱离了数据、现实以及我们所看到的情况。有时候人们就是觉得犯罪率上升了，而实际上犯罪率在下降。我认为这是一个经典的例子。而且这种情况一直在发生，我甚至不只是在谈论当下，它贯穿了整个历史，而且是一个非常有效的政治工具。因此，确保你拥有这种公众情绪是很重要的，即使它
not explicitly around the project that you are talking about because whatever has public sentiment is what your goal is competing with. And so that, you know, it can make things very, very easy. But if you don't have the internal path, it can also be ineffective as well and vice versa. And so having both the decision makers and building that coalition is really important. I often think about, you know, when in the house, you author a bill and sometimes you have co-leads on the bill and who you select as your co-leads sends a message to the rest of the house about what kind of mission you're on. And so if all of your co-leads are very outside-facing, then sometimes people get the message that this is more of a messaging effort.
并非明确围绕着你正在谈论的项目，因为无论什么东西拥有公众情绪，都是你的目标在与之竞争。所以，你知道的，这会让事情变得非常非常容易。但如果你没有内部途径，它也同样会失效，反之亦然。因此，既有决策者又建立这种联盟是非常重要的。我经常想到，你知道的，当在众议院时，你提出一项法案，有时你会有法案的共同领衔人，而你选择谁作为共同领衔人，会向众议院的其他成员传达一个关于你肩负着什么使命的信息。所以，如果你所有的共同领衔人都非常注重对外，那么有时人们就会得到这样的信息：这更像是一次宣传造势活动。
This is not to pass, this is to send a message, which is a tool that has its own role. But sometimes you have a coalition of people that indicate something else, that you are very serious about passing this thing, or this is a shot off the bow, or sometimes someone has a primary and they're trying to get their base off their back, and that's why they signed on to it. And so people read your coalition as a signal of what your plans and intentions are. Yeah, that makes sense. You're an advocate for public housing.
这不是为了通过，这是为了发出一个信号，这个工具本身有它的角色。但有时你拥有一个由不同人组成的联盟，表明了其他的事情，表明你非常严肃地想要通过这件事，或者这是一个试探信号，或者有时某人面临初选，他们正试图让其基本盘别再找麻烦，这就是他们签署加入的原因。因此，人们将你的联盟解读为你计划和意图的信号。是的，这说得通。你是公共住房的倡导者。
I'm an advocate for public housing. If it wasn't for HUD paying my rent as a kid, I don't know where I would be today. Robert Moses built most of the public housing in New York City, and a lot of it is considered not very functional, not very good. The execution and administration of public housing has often been lacking. And I think it is unfairly sullied, the public housing as a concept. How do you do it right? I mean, it's important. I think that the divestment and the dissolution of public housing is a story about race.
我是公共住房的倡导者。要不是HUD（美国住房和城市发展部）在我小时候帮我付房租，我不知道今天会在哪里。罗伯特·摩西建造了纽约市大部分的公共住房，其中很多被认为不太实用、不太好。公共住房的执行和管理往往有所欠缺。我认为公共住房作为一个概念被不公平地玷污了。你该怎么把它做好呢？我的意思是，这很重要。我认为公共住房的撤资和解体是一个关于种族的故事。
Yes. And I think it's important for us to talk about that very explicitly because the public housing that of Robert Moses's day, even though he was discriminatory and had a lot of class bias in addition to racial bias, when public housing was occupied by mostly white families, it was at its peak. It was quite idyllic in terms of public policy. You had housing that was affordable that you could raise a family in, that was built with community infrastructure in mind. These weren't just apartments in a building, but there were playgrounds. There are community spaces. There's senior programming.
是的。我认为我们明确地讨论这一点非常重要，因为罗伯特·摩西那时的公共住房，尽管他具有歧视性，除了种族偏见外还有很多阶级偏见，但当公共住房主要由白人家庭居住时，它是处于巅峰时期的。就公共政策而言，它是相当田园诗般的。你拥有负担得起的住房，你可以在里面抚养家庭，在建造时考虑到了社区基础设施。这些不仅仅是建筑里的公寓，还有游乐场。有社区空间。有老年人节目。
There's childcare. And it worked. It worked. It worked. It was when public housing began to be integrated and you started to have black residents move in. In New York City, a lot of Puerto Rican residents start to move in that we started to see the through a politically racialized lens. And in my view, it still is. But we also know that public housing has been enormously successful. And in fact, you know, one of the pieces of legislation that I have introduced is the repeal of the Faircloth Amendment,
有儿童保育。而且它奏效了。它奏效了。它奏效了。正是当公共住房开始被整合，你开始看到黑人居民搬进来时。在纽约市，许多波多黎各居民开始搬进来，我们开始通过政治化的种族视角来看待这个问题。在我看来，现在依然如此。但我们也知道，公共住房取得了巨大的成功。事实上，你知道的，我提出的立法之一就是废除《费尔克劳斯修正案》，
which currently bans construction of new public housing units in the United States. And if we repeal that, I think once people experience public housing in an integrated and socially integrated way, it would create public will for more of it. In addition to social housing models, in addition to lots of other kinds of housing models that can de-commodify the housing market that we're currently living in. That is completely unsustainable. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, this is the thing that people talk about when they really examine public housing
该修正案目前禁止在美国建设新的公共住房单位。如果我们废除了这一条款，我认为一旦人们以一种融合的、社会融合的方式体验到公共住房，它就会为建设更多公共住房创造民意基础。除了社会住房模式之外，还有许多其他类型的住房模式，可以去商品化我们目前所生活的住房市场。那是完全不可持续的。是的。是的。我的意思是，这就是人们在认真审视公共住房项目时所谈论的事情，
projects, even ones that are sort of notorious like Pruitt-Igoe. There's a section or there's a period of time when that existed when it was integrated and there was proper investment and proper maintenance and proper care and it functioned in all the high ideals in which it was intended. And then when white flight happened and the divestment happened, then that's when it falls apart because these design systems are not quite as robust and they need to be more robust,
甚至是那些诸如普鲁伊特-戈格（Pruitt-Igoe）这样臭名昭著的项目。有一个时间段，它存在的时候是融合的，并且有适当的投资、适当的维护和适当的照顾，它按照其本意的所有崇高理想运作。然后，当白人群飞和撤资发生时，它就开始崩溃了，因为这些设计系统并没有那么强大，它们需要更加强大，
like to take a light that goes out and that doesn't turn into a hallway that becomes dangerous, that doesn't become into this. It takes people constantly thinking about it as a system and treating it as a system. And I just, you know, I just think that people have gotten the wrong idea of it. And I like want a better world in which public housing is just part of the fabric of our cities, you know. Yeah, and it's a similar thing actually in New York City with free public college tuition.
比如一个灯泡坏了，不会变成一条变得危险的走廊，不会演变成这样。这需要人们不断地将它视为一个系统来思考，并将它当作一个系统来对待。而我只是，你知道的，我只是觉得人们对它产生了错误的看法。我想要一个更好的世界，在这个世界里，公共住房只是我们城市结构的一部分，你知道的。是的，在纽约市，关于免费公立大学学费的情况其实也类似。
Our CUNY system was free. It was free. You could go to college for free. It was after the Civil Rights Act and the Civil Rights Movement, which forced integration of our public systems, that we started getting divestment from our public systems. And it's really important that I think people understand that is that this is not just like just government abandonment. This is a story about race. And part of our journey in healing our racial divide is by advocating for the reestablishment of integrated economic social safety nets that aren't blind to racial injustice, that are conscious of it. But I think that the way
我们的城市大学（CUNY）系统曾经是免费的。它是免费的。你可以免费上大学。正是在民权法案和民权运动迫使我们的公共系统进行融合之后，我们才开始从公共系统中撤资。我认为人们理解这一点非常重要，即这不仅仅是政府的抛弃。这是一个关于种族的故事。我们治愈种族分歧的征程的一部分，是通过倡导重建融合的经济社会安全网来实现的，这些安全网对种族不公正并非盲目不见，而是对此有着清醒的认识。但我认为我们实现这一点的方式，
that we do that is by reminding ourselves that we as a people, as a society, as a working class, even as a poor class, we deserve nice things. We deserve human dignity. And we deserve tuition-free public college. It's not a pipe dream. We deserve housing that we're not spending every single ounce of our non-food or medicine income. Oftentimes people making those trade-offs. We deserve housing that doesn't suck all of that up. We deserve good schools. But we have to demand them across lines of race and culture. And if we're not fighting for black Americans' right to that, if we aren't seeing cultural
是通过提醒我们自己：作为一个人群、一个社会、一个工人阶级，甚至是一个贫困阶级，我们理应拥有美好的事物。我们理应拥有人类尊严。我们理应拥有免学费的公立大学。这不是白日梦。我们理应拥有这样的住房：我们不用花掉除了食物或医药之外的每一分钱。通常人们都在做这样的权衡。我们理应拥有不会吸干这一切的住房。我们理应拥有好的学校。但我们必须跨越种族和文化的界限去争取它们。如果我们不为美国黑人获得这一权利而战，如果我们看不到文化
inequities, then what it means is that we're denying it to ourselves. And it's not just a fight for equality. It's a fight for access. That's really what it is. It's like if you can, because if you can, we see this over and over again. If you make public housing like when what people think, like let's just get real about it, right? If what people think of public housing is black residents and then we have this this internalized racialized construct about what that means, or there's some sort of like media value on what that means, then people are going to otherize it and think that's somebody else, this benefits somebody else, it's not
不平等，那么这意味着我们是在剥夺我们自己的权力。这不仅仅是一场争取平等的斗争。这是一场争取获取途径的斗争。这才是真正的本质。这就好比如果你能，因为如果你能，我们一次又一次地看到这一点。如果你把公共住房搞得就像人们所想的那样——让我们对此现实一点吧，对吧？如果人们对公共住房的看法是黑人居民，然后我们对此产生了一种内在的种族化构建，意味着那代表着什么，或者媒体对这有什么价值判断，那么人们就会将其异化，认为那是别人的事，这对别人有利，不是
for me, so I'm okay, I'll look the other way if it's, you know, defunded or if, you know, in the wintertime the gas goes out and the heat's off. But when we reject that as another and we say, wait, you know, if that's happening to them, it's gonna happen to me. It happening to them, is it happening to me, then that's how we get there. That's how we do that. And that's why I think that the racial dimension of Robert Moses' legacy is not just a cautionary tale. It's not just, oh yeah, oh, and by the way, this guy was like, mad racist. It's not just, oh yeah, oh and by the way this guy was like mad racist. It's not just that.
为我准备的，所以我没问题，如果它（资金）被砍了，或者你知道的，冬天断气暖气停了，我也只会睁一只眼闭一只眼。但当我们拒绝把那视为“他者”，并说“等等，你知道的，如果这种事发生在他们身上，也会发生在我身上。发生在他们身上，就是发生在在我身上”，这才是我们达成目标的方式。这才是我们做事的方式。这就是为什么我认为罗伯特·摩西遗产的种族维度不仅仅是一个警示故事。这不仅仅是“哦，是的，顺便说一句，这家伙是个狂热的种族主义者”。这不仅仅是“哦，是的，顺便说一句，这家伙是个狂热的种族主义者”。不仅仅是这样。
If only Robert Carroll could have said it that way, the book would be so much shorter. It's not that. It's like, it actually shows us the way forward. Like, if this was truly unacceptable, not from a, not from a, oh, we don't believe in inequality, but like we are one, like we are one. If we oppose it on that basis, we probably would have a lot more public transit in New York City right now.
要是罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）能那样写就好了，那这本书会短得多。不是那样的。它实际上为我们指明了前进的道路。就像，如果这是绝对不可接受的，不是从一种“哦，我们不相信不平等”的角度，而是像我们是一体的——我们是一体的。如果我们以此为基础进行反对，我们现在在纽约市可能会有更多的公共交通。
We would absolutely without a doubt have a lot more and well invested public housing. I think that we would still have a tuition-free public college system and it's not an accident that in the aftermath of Moses's kind of peak era you see the emergence in New York City of the Young Lords, of the Black Panthers, who are directly advocating for the infrastructure investments and speaking to the inequities that he was starting, that he had just created. And I think that's part of the story, right, where his chapter ends, ours begins. It feels like it, for me, it hearkens back to something you said at the beginning of
我们绝对毫无疑问会拥有更多且投资良好的公共住房。我认为我们仍然会拥有免学费的公立大学系统，而且这绝非偶然：在摩西鼎盛时期之后，你在纽约市看到了“青年领袖党”（Young Lords）和“黑豹党”（Black Panthers）的崛起，他们直接倡导基础设施投资，并直面他开始创造的、他刚刚制造的不平等。我认为这也是故事的一部分，对吧，他的章节结束的地方，我们的章节开始了。在我看来，这让我想起了你在对话开始时
the conversation where you're talking about choices. And it's something that comes up in our discussions on the episodes too is each of these things is a choice. There's no inevitable way that public housing has to be. It's not that, oh, it always has to be like that, or if the light bulb goes out, you just leave it out. There's nothing you can do about it. And if those are choices that they made,
谈到选择时所说的话。这也是我们在各集节目讨论中经常出现的内容：每一件事都是一种选择。公共住房并不是非得变成某种不可避免的样子。并不是说，哦，它总是必须是那个样子的，或者如果灯泡坏了，你就任由它坏着，你对此无能为力。没有任何办法。如果那是他们做出的选择，
then it feels like we can make the other choice. The other choice is available. You know, it's not, they haven't fully foreclosed it, even if it does seem like it's a lot harder after all that stuff's been built to change things. It's amazing how systems get so tied to physical things. Yeah, yeah. And I mean, the thing is, like, kind of to your point earlier about some of Robert Moses' earlier work that there were benefits for, you know, his advocacy for public
那么感觉我们就可以做出另一种选择。另一种选择是存在的。你知道的，这并不是说他们已经彻底封死了这条路，尽管在所有这些东西建成之后，要改变事情确实看起来要难得多。系统与实体事物绑定得如此紧密，真是太惊人了。对，对。我的意思是，事情是这样的，正如你之前提到的罗伯特·摩西早期的一些工作，确实给纽约市带来了好处，比如他倡导修建公共
pools in New York City, the construction of public pools, the construction of beaches. You know, he of course had racist intent with that. However, earlier on you saw that in how he administered, like the administration of the pools, but not necessarily in the construction of them. And so as a result, to this day, now actually, public pools in New York City are, and access to public pools are an enormous racial benefit, and not just a racial benefit, but a class benefit, that people from all sorts of backgrounds who would normally not be able to
游泳池，修建公共游泳池，修建海滩。当然，他在其中有着种族主义的意图。然而，早些时候你在他管理游泳池的方式中看到了这一点，但在修建游泳池时却不一定如此。因此，直到今天——实际上现在也是——纽约市的公共游泳池以及使用公共游泳池的权利，带来了巨大的种族红利，不仅是种族红利，也是阶级红利，那些背景各异、通常无法
access a club or whatever it may be, can learn how to swim, can enjoy the pools that we have in places like Astoria Park. And Orchard Beach is like, I think of Orchard Beach and City Island as working class Hamptons. That's where everyday people go to soak up the sun and enjoy the space and those same plazas that Robert Moses built around that time. During this New Deal era, those same plazas still exist today and in fact are in the process of having just been reinvested in and overhauled because that is actually a hundred plus year legacy that has withstood the test of time.
进入俱乐部或类似场所的人们，可以学习游泳，可以享受我们在阿斯托里亚公园（Astoria Park）等地拥有的游泳池。果园海滩（Orchard Beach）就像——我认为果园海滩和城市岛（City Island）就像是工人阶级的汉普顿。那是普通人去沐浴阳光、享受空间的地方，罗伯特·摩西当时围绕此建造的那些广场，
And you know, I think he would be appalled at who is going there today. But it is to all of our benefit. Luckily, he doesn't have a say in it anymore. Yeah. Well, thank you so much, Representative Acosta-Cortez, for spending time with us and having us talk about Robert Moses and the book and your district. It's been the world to me to have you here. So thank you so much.
在今天依然存在，事实上它们正在经历重新投资和全面改造，因为这实际上是一项经受住了时间考验的、一百多年的遗产。你知道的，我想他会对今天去那里的人感到震惊。但这对我们所有人都有利。幸运的是，他再也没有发言权了。好吧，非常感谢议员奥卡西奥-科尔特斯（Acosta-Cortez）花时间与我们交流，并同我们讨论罗伯特·摩西、这本书以及你所在的选区。你能来到这里对我们意义重大。所以非常感谢你。
Of course, it's wonderful to be here. Thank you so much for having me on. Next month, we're finishing up part four, the use of power covering chapters 21 through 24. That's pages 402 through 496 in my amazingly huge printed copy of the Power Broker. In the meantime, you can check me out on my other podcast, The Flophouse, every Saturday. And you can also join the conversation with other Power Broker readers on our Discord. The link is on our website or go to discord.gg slash nine nine PI.
当然，很高兴能来到这里。非常感谢邀请我参加。下个月，我们将完成第四部分“权力的运用”，涵盖第21到第24章。这在我那本惊人巨大的精装版《权力经纪人》中是第402页到第496页。在此期间，你可以在我另一个播客节目《The Flophouse》上找到我，每周六更新。你也可以在我们的Discord上与其他《权力经纪人》读者一起参与讨论。链接在我们的网站上，或者访问 discord.gg/99pi。
The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker is produced by Isabel Angel. It's edited by Comiti. The music is by Swan Real and the mix is by Dara Hirsch. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director.
99%隐形节目对《权力经纪人》的深度解析由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔（Isabel Angel）制作。由科米蒂（Comiti）剪辑。音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作，混音由达拉·赫施（Dara Hirsch）完成。99%隐形节目的执行制片人是凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）。我们的资深编辑是德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。库尔特·科尔stedt（Kurt Kohlstedt）是数字总监。
The rest of the team includes Sarah Bake, Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Artin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora Building, in beautiful Uptown Oakland California. You can find the show on the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server
团队的其他成员包括莎拉·贝克（Sarah Bake）、克里斯·伯鲁贝（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、阿尔廷·冈萨雷斯（Artin Gonzalez）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·雷（Vivian Ley）、拉什马·唐（Lashma Dawn）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、尼娜·波图克（Nina Potuck），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99%隐形的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，现在总部设在北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼（Pandora Building），位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城。你可以在常规的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到这个节目，
where we have fun discussions about Power Broker, about architecture, about movies, about music, about all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most of the time these days. You can find a link to that Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. They learn to work together in some way because of Franklin Roosevelt's love of nipples. So we will learn about that in the next section, Chapter 17,
我们在那里就《权力经纪人》、建筑、电影、音乐以及各种好玩的内容展开有趣的讨论。这些天我大部分时间都在那里闲逛。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到通往该 Discord 服务器的链接以及 99PI 的每一集往期节目。由于富兰克林·罗斯福对乳头的喜爱，他们以某种方式学会了如何一起工作……所以我们将在下一节中了解这一点，即第17章，
the mother of accommodation. When we come back. What a tease. Love of nipples. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
妥协之母。当我们回来时。真是个逗趣的悬念。喜爱乳头。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。